his public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee meeting
the hearings on bills and possibly
executive sessions voting
please note there is no physical
location for the members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
I am confirming that all members of the
committee and the left legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
practice
the public has access to listen
contemporaneously and if necessary
participate in this meeting on the zoom
platform or by telephone
unnecessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and RSA 91-1
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271-3660
in the event the public as a whole is
unable to access this meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
Christina Dyer the committee researcher
will be the staff assisting us
please note that all votes are taken
during this meeting
by roll call votes
we will start the meeting by taking roll
call attendance
when each member states his or her
presence please also State whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
that required a little like to know law
for all the world
representative March
good morning this is representative
Marsh I am currently home alone in my
home office in Brookfield
representative McMahon
representative Nelson here
are you alone I'm in Brookfield and I am
alone
representative captain
hello I am in uh Fremont and I am home
alone with my daughters homeschooling in
the Next Room
representative gay here representative
Cushman
um
representative Chelsea
I'm present in my home in Bedford my
husband and my daughter are in the other
part of the house
representative King here
representative
representative Koval
yes I am here in my home office in
Wilton and there are some other people
in the house nobody else in the room at
this time
representative
representative yes I'm here I'm at home
and there is no one else in the house
representative McKay
representative snow
foreign
ER
thanks yes I am here he said he'd be
joining us shortly he had
um a bit of a health emergency that he
was dealing with and he'll be right in
okay this is representative knurk I am
here I'm home in my study in Freedom and
my wife is elsewhere in the house
leaving for work later
representative Father Ray
here uh at home in my office in Lee New
Hampshire alone
representative Cannon
I'm home alone in my home in Somersworth
represent representative
uh I'm home in Nashua alone in the room
but not in the house
representative Shapiro
I am in my home office in Keene
um on on my own
representative Woods
uh uh present um at my study at my home
in Beau and my wife is someplace else in
the house
representative Merchant
here I'm in Claremont New Hampshire in
my home and my wife is somewhere else in
the house
okay and the chair Pearson
I am here in Compton with my colleagues
um
representative Marsh please yes
if the clerk is asking representative
Mark you let us know or not the
committing members
uh I there are enough committee members
here so with that I will call the public
hearing uh to order for House Bill 75
and recognize uh representative Pearson
uh to introduce his bill
thank you Mr Chief the testimony on this
bill
it is substantially the same bill that
came through this committee 21-0 last
year and was approved on the consent
calendar in the house and went to the
Senate to be tabled with many other good
bills
essentially there's two parts to this
bill
first of all the New Hampshire
Commission on deafness and hearing loss
which I care
and a protocol subcommittee that I
appointed a year and a half ago so look
at various possible pieces of
legislation
one of the items that came up was the
title of our committee
the title of the committee isn't exists
now referred to medical conditions not
to people
other titles were suggested
I've asked a few members of this
subcommittee to do an informal poll in
the deaf and hard of hearing community
in New Hampshire to see what their
pleasure would be
and I asked a few other members of the
subcommittee to investigate to see what
other states call similar commissions to
ours
the overwhelming choice for the rename
was the New Hampshire commission for the
death and
positive
proactive title that speaks about people
along the way this group wondered if we
could form a commission or committee out
of a bill
to investigate how the services for the
deaf and hard of hearing are being
conducted in our long-term care
facilities in the state
after much discussion and consultation
with those who have been in the house a
lot longer than me the conclusion was
instead of having something set
let us invite
representatives of the three major
long-term care facility organizations to
join the commission
I suppose with the person who leads the
County nursing homes the person who
leads the private nursing homes and the
person who leads the extended care
facilities that are not so much interest
each person thought it was a good idea
to have a representative become part of
the commission to bring that perspective
to the various things under
consideration and especially on those
times when we were looking at the
extended care facilities and the
services they provide
each face it was apparent to me
something that I've experienced in a
lifetime of visiting people in the
nursing homes that most nursing home
administrators really care and are
trying to do a good job that they're
willing to learn things that they didn't
know before in terms of caring for their
people
so this good old seems to rename the
commission and add three members and I
just delineated
that is my testimony in acting chair
uh thank you representative Pearson
before I take questions I will recognize
representative snow to tell us where he
is and whether he's alone so that we're
compliant with 91a
again you just muted yourself you were
unmuted before
okay am I okay now
you're fine okay thank you yes this is
representative snow from my house in
Manchester my wife is in the vicinity I
apologize for being late we had a small
little Health thing we had to take care
of this morning and it's all set now and
everything's fine thank you
sorry we understand and we're glad that
you are fine uh representative whoever
had told us that you were going to be
delayed
but with that I'll ask if there are any
questions for representative Pearson
seeing none I'll thank representative
Pearson for his testimony and recognize
ndhhs uh for their testimony
can you hear me
yes we can
good morning members of the committee
thank you for allowing me to speak I
apologize for getting my testimony
request in at the very last minute
um I just saw that this was having a
hearing this morning
um and it's a very important bill
um my name is Jules good
um I do work for Northeast deaf and hard
of hearing services but I'm here
representing myself as a private citizen
I am deaf I live in Concord New
Hampshire
um first of all I would love to just
voice my support for the renaming of the
commission I think it's super great that
you're centering people like me instead
of medical conditions so I really
appreciate that
um in my role I also do work with a lot
of Nursing and extended care facilities
so I also appreciate that you're adding
their perspectives as a part of the
committee one thing that I would like to
recommend as a suggestion for an
addition to the bill would be to add a
member of the public who has lived
experience as a deafblind person so the
deaf-blind community is definitely a
part of the deaf and hard of hearing
Community even though they kind of
bridge you know between the deaf and
blind communities they're still very
much a part of the work that we do and
um and need to be represented in
committees such as this you may notice
um in HB 631 which you'll be hearing
later this week that bill is relative to
standards for interpreters for the deaf
and hard of hearing they are adding into
that bill language to talk about
interpreters for deaf-blind people as
well so I think it's only appropriate
that we include
deaf-blind citizens in our in the
language for this bill as well being
that they're being
discussed so close together
um so I am happy to take any questions
you have about this I am using the
captioning service which I'm so happy is
being provided that's so great
um so it may just take a minute for it
to catch up with what you're saying
before I can respond thank you
bill you were muted
foreign
thank you the spacebar trick was not
working
does the committee have any questions
yes representative Marsh
go ahead
um Can the witness please uh State her
name and organization again we do not
push them slowly slowly
uh yes could you please state your name
and organization again slowly for the
clerk
name is Jules good
j-u-l-e-s last name good g-o-o-d
and I work for Northeast deaf and hard
of hearing services which is abbreviated
and DHHS
thank you Jules for your patience we are
a little slow sometimes we're older
are there any other questions for the
witness
I thank you again for your testimony and
I will now recognize Henry Littman who
had his hand raised
thank you
foreign
excuse me uh Mr chairman I think it was
just me moving my mouse around I must
have hit the raise hand button I
apologize
it happens all the time we're all
working this out as we go through if
there's anybody other members of the
public who wish to testify would they
please raise their hands uh so that we
can recognize them
Christina I see no hands raised
I don't see any either
thank you and with that I will close the
public hearing and House Bill 75 and
open an executive session in House Bill
75 and recognize representative Pearson
for a motion
chairman and to address the confidence
of the person from Northeastern hard of
hearing we are under consideration of
adding for the deaf uh and the deafblind
to our commission discussions have been
begun and this is something we wish to
not just add a member but
significantly recognize that mean so
thank you for that testimony and it is a
work in progress I move on House Bill 75
to pass
thank you is there a second for the
motion
recognize representative Woods is
getting his hand up first as seconding
the motion Is there further discussion
towards the motion
go ahead
if we're going to amend this do we the
changes that you want to make are not an
amendment we're not making any changes
to the bill we are taking under
advisement for us to eventually uh bring
forth an amendment but not now
thank you
yeah the the motion on the floor is
ought to pass if you wish to have an
amendment you would vote in the negative
and uh then bring an amendment forward
and that would certainly be one result
that could be possible from this is
there any other discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
representative Marsh
representative March votes yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes
representative captain
yes
representative yay yes representative
Cushman yes representative Folsom yes
representative Kelsey yes
representative King yes
representative profile
yes
representative Weber
okay yes yes
representative yes
okay
representative snow
yes
representative
Representatives Holloway yes
Canon salmon all right yes
uh representative Nutter Autumn yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods
yes
representative Merchant yes
chair Pearson yeah
is 20 years and one absent
therefore I declare that the motion
passes and the vote of 20 to nothing is
there any objection to consent no
seeing none will put the spill on
consent and I will relinquish the chair
to uh chairman Pearson thank you very
much
thank you representative mark
you now called our
back
he introduce how to build six zero zero
fiscal Mount relative to funding for
newborn screening and I would ask the
bills crimes funds the representative
Marsh to present your bill please
uh thank you Mr chairman uh good morning
for the record I'm representative
William Marsh representing seven towns
in southern Carroll County relevant to
this bill I also chair the New Hampshire
rare disease advisory Council I'm
pleased today to offer for your
consideration how still 600 relative to
funding newborn screening tests which I
found at the request of the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
New Hampshire's newborn screening
program is a wonderful program and the
intent of this bill is not to change the
program in any way for instance in the
last year one of my ballot clerks in the
town of Brookfield had their first Grand
shop the child was diagnosed with spinal
muscular atrophy a test newly added to
our newborn screening panel and
successfully treated with genetic
therapy this baby now looks forward to a
normal life without treatment SMA is
universally fatal
the issue that I have with the program
is how they send out their bills
under current law DHHS builds hospitals
for the filter paper on which blood
samples are submitted for testing
the cost of this filter paper has
doubled in the last year and I
understand it is now approximately 210
dollars per piece of paper
it is expected to increase as more tests
are added to the newborn screening panel
which is reasonable and expected as more
genetic diseases are
they develop treatments for these
diseases
filter paper is the supply and this and
and a bill for filter paper cannot be
submitted to insurers there is no charge
at this point in time for the test
performed
we are simply asking the commissioner to
restructure the current fee so that
these bills can be submitted to
insurance
instead of billing for filter paper the
invoice could read newborn screening
panel
this is already done in other states for
instance in the state of Texas effective
January 1st 2001 that being 20 years ago
HC PCS code s3620 was implemented for
newborn metabolic screenings
Minnesota uses the same billing code you
can see this on their websites
an American Academy of Pediatrics
document about one month preventative
visits recommends hcpcs code s3620 for
newborn screening if not already
performed and the list of CPT codes most
notably
v77.7 special screening of other inborn
errors of metabolism
coverage for Pediatric preventative
Services has been mandated by federal
law without co-payer deductible since
2014 pursuant to 45 CFR
147.130 this bill does not mandate any
change whatsoever in insurance law
regarding a proposed amendment to add
the words collection fees that does not
work for a great many reasons the major
one being that the federal law just
sledded mandates coverage for
preventative health services and says
nothing about collection fees
passage of this bill will help maintain
the economic viability of the various
birthing centers in New Hampshire
because we will allow them to recover at
least some of their costs thank you and
I'll be glad to take questions
I believe we have lost the chair
's right here
good
I'm just giving people the chance to
figure out if they want to ask you a
question
looks like they don't
so thank you for your testimony
and I would like to uh call upon Paula
minahan from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association who has signed up to testify
two and a half
good morning
Mr chairman members of the committee can
you hear me
great thank you
um for the record my name is Paula
minahan Senior vice president state
government relations with the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
representing all our hospitals and we
are very supportive of HB 600 and we do
thank representative Marsh for
sponsoring this important bill as along
with the rest of the co-sponsors
um I have to say
um some representative Marsh did such an
excellent job at explaining this I
really don't have much more to say
except
um everything that he said um that was
um really well presented um this is a
very important bill to our hospitals we
as representative Marsh said we are not
looking to change the program at all we
are looking to just essentially ensure
that the state law is aligned with the
federal law and allow for the hospitals
and birthing the birthing hospitals and
birthing centers not every hospital as
you know provides birthing
um Services unfortunately but have the
birthing centers and birthing hospitals
be able to bill for these screening
tests and get reimbursed and not
dictating what they'll get reimbursed
again just allowing for that opportunity
to do that
um and as he indicated currently the way
the program is structured essentially
the hospitals and birthing centers
pay for the filter paper which
effectively pays for the program
um and
um again we're just trying to allow that
opportunity to to have them be able to
build we do believe it's a very
important bill
um to balance the fees needed to support
the program with the ability to recoup
some costs and we asked the committee to
vote ought to pass happy to answer any
questions and thank you very much
see the chair recognizes Dr Sai charola
DHHS who has signed up to speak Dr
Gerald
can you hear me
yes yes thank you uh thank you so much
for having me here for the record my
name is
um uh good morning representative
chairperson representative Pearson and
the committee members for record my name
is Dr Sai charala I'm the bureau chief
of the Bureau of population health and
community services and the division of
Public Health Services uh I want to
thank our vice chair representative
Marsh who has been very proactive and
collaborative partner on these topics
and also want to thank you for
organizing and meeting between Public
Health our Medicaid and New Hampshire
Hospital Association to discuss the
proposed legislation
so just to give you the background
um uh the the current legislation
amongst the existing law to make clear
where the fees are charged for the
hospitals and newborn screening I'm I
just want to thank the committee for
giving me this opportunity just to
provide an overview of what's the
function and funding of current uh our
program for the New Hampshire of newborn
screening program
so newborn screening program has
represented Amash mentioned is an
essential preventive public health
program it's a population health program
population based program it's a complex
integrated system so what we are trying
to do is to get an early identification
of some of these metabolic disorders
genetic disorders so that way we can
timely and have a timely as well as an
early intervention and that actually can
lead to elimination or reduction of
death and disability so for every new
every time we see what we do is when we
see an abnormal screening we actually
link the infant to there subsequently to
receive any kind of diagnostic test as
well as refer them for the appropriate
treatment
so how what we do in New Hampshire New
Hampshire uh newborn screening program
is approximately we have around 12 000
births every year so we are responsible
for assuring that all the new in all the
infants who are born in New Hampshire
are screened at Birth for inherited any
of these inherited medical disorders so
what we do is we take few drops not we
in a sense in the hospital they take few
drops of blood
and um actually uh a few drops of blood
are taken from infants heal at uh 24 to
72 hours of birth on a filter paper and
that's actually sent to a lab for
testing and this process is done before
the infant leaves a hospital or the
birthing center because time is timing
is everything for in this in this
situation because some conditions need
to be identified within the first week
of life and this all happens under our
state legislation families May refuse
the screening if they wish to and we are
responsible for handling all the
screening results follow up on the out
of range results as needed like
following up with the pediatrician to
let them know about the condition as
well as following providing those
resources to the families and to the
pediatrician so what we do in New
Hampshire is we screen for 37 conditions
not only these we also screen for
critical congenital heart defects as
well as newborn screening so we have an
advisory committee under the legislation
that actually provides recommendations
to our state program on what kind of
clinical educational or operational
aspects of the program is and this
committee actually meets biannually we
also have provide an annual report
that's required under the legislation to
Health and Human Services oversight
committee on previous years uh newborn
screening program activities
come into the funding how this is
actually funded newborn screening
program in New Hampshire does not use
any state or federal funds rather it is
a non-lapsing newborn screening
revolving fund it's funded by filter
papers currently the cost of filter
papers is 146 dollars not two hundred
dollars but 100 146 and it's paid by the
participating Health Care Providers
these include our hospitals birthing
centers
so and basically the filter paper is
used for blood spot testing so we have
around 17 hospitals that are are part of
this group we um the current cost
operational cost annual operational cost
for the newborn screening program is 1.8
million and the funds are used to pay
for the cost related with a contract
that we have with University of
Massachusetts Medical School which runs
our newborn screening or the art lab
program so they are responsible for a
testing screening and shipping and
supplies the fund also supports a 1.5
FTE Personnel for the program a database
system as well as a medical consultant
so our understanding with our current
legislation is it will not impact the
process by which how the the program is
funded but more clarity on on um and
also that fees how the fees are
collected but also important thing is
that this will not have a direct
physical impact on the newborn screening
program so thank you for giving me this
opportunity to talk about newborn
screening program in New Hampshire and
uh please let me know if you have any
questions
thank you Dr Cheryl are there any
questions from the committee or the one
who just tested
seeing none I thank you for your
testimony and the chair recognizes
Heidi roll who is a lobbyist North
America's health insurance plans
uh good morning Mr chairman are you able
to hear me yes thank you
okay good thank you very much um yes
thank you good morning everyone my name
is Heidi Kroll
um I work at Gallagher Callahan and
gartrell and I represent America's
health insurance plans otherwise known
as ahip
um which is the um trade Association for
the health insurance carriers
um and I think there will be a few other
carriers who testify here today as well
um
we're just kind of scratching our heads
on this one I guess
um confused and I think looking for some
clarification
um our understanding is that the
carriers do reimburse
um for a bundle of newborn screening
tests reimburse the the hospitals or the
birthing centers for that
um uh to the best of my knowledge um
talking with some of the New Hampshire a
members
um none of the hospitals or birthing
centers approach the carriers
um to indicate that
um the reimbursement for those bundle of
services was
um in their opinion not adequate to
cover the cost of the filter paper
um
and so I guess we're we're just a little
um concerned that perhaps we're having a
situation where
um rather than kind of going through the
normal
um Contracting process and procedures
that
um hospitals and carriers engage in
um that we're looking for a legislative
um solution or intervention so
um I I may be misunderstanding the
situation
um and uh but that's that's our concern
I guess is that we're looking for a
legislative solution when maybe there
could have been one outside of of the
legislature
um we're just simply working in the
normal Contracting that happens between
hospitals and uh and the carriers
if he would address that
uh yes I'll be glad to address that
although I think Paula minahan would be
a better person to address that it is my
understanding that insurers are not uh
reimbursing for the filter paper because
they're not being sent any bills for the
filter paper so uh I will yield my time
to Parliament
12 minute hand please
Mr chairman this is this is Heidi Kroll
again um I guess I would just say that I
you know I think the concern is that you
know where carriers are paying for the
bundle of newborn screening tests
um which you know presumably is an
all-encompassing
payment for that bundle and we're not
you know uh you know when when services
are reimbursed by carriers
um there's there's not um kind of a
parsing out of all of the individual
parts and pieces that go into a
particular service or a particular test
um so you know for example you know the
cost of a syringe goes up or something
else changes
um that's kind of typically not a uh a
separately build item just because one
little piece of a of a test has has gone
up
um so it's again it gets back to this
you know we're paying for a service
we're paying for a bundle
um and I think at least from the
carrier's perspective we assume that
that's encompassing everything
um Staffing supplies it's got a piece of
you know to help hospitals with overhead
Etc
um
so at any rate that that's our concern
is that um it's it's really kind of not
how reimbursement
um works from at least from the carrier
perspective and again I think there
there were other New Hampshire Ahab
members who will testify today but um
uh that that's what I wanted to share
with you this morning sir I have
recognized Paula menahan to speak
on the call
thank you chairman can you hear me I was
having trouble sorry about that um
so I think
um you know there's more discussion that
we can have but I think representative
Marsh
um explained it pretty well because of
the structure of how the filter paper is
paid for you cannot turn around and put
filter paper on a bill and Bill the
carrier so I think there's just a little
misunderstanding honestly and I I think
we can have that discussion but
um the carriers are not acknowledging
that because there's not a a mechanism
to be able to effectively
um properly and um and clearly without
having any billing fraud um to ensure
that that those costs are recognized you
create as representative Marsh
identified there are codes that can be
build but we need the we need the
structure if you will we need the law to
be able to allow for that
um right now the the carriers really are
not seeing this this charge because of
the way it is currently paid for so
we're just trying to create a mechanism
so that those
um
some of those costs can in fact get
negotiated with the carriers we're not
we're not saying this needs to this is a
mandate at all
um I think there's just needs we just
need to have further clarification
um I I I talk with the CFOs at the
hospitals and they explained um what I
just explained to you
um to me and I think they just
um there's just needs to be a mechanism
again to be able to effectively and and
um legally
um build the carriers for these Services
um and there may be
um some hospitals that have negotiated
something
um and been able to kind of tease out
um for for some of the newborn
screenings but um that is not
universally
um how the hospitals are um have done it
um so we just that's all we're just
trying to
clean it up so that it's it's more clear
that's all
he's going to have the chair now
recognizes to testify to a great Dunlap
thank you everyone this is Sabrina
Dunlap I am director of government
relations at Anthem I would Echo a lot
of what Heidi said I think
um we're just unclear on why this issue
has come up and I
spoke to our Contracting folks and this
has not come up on the negoti on the
Contracting side so it just seems odd
insurers haven't been engaged to this
point and it seems like on the
reimbursement issue we would have been
um engaged and I'm not I'm just not
clear on my legislation is needed here
um even hearing Paula's answer there
because we just it's something that
needs to be negotiated I'm not sure what
a bill would do on this
um also not clear how the bill would
play out as a practical matter it's just
not clear to me what that mechanism is
or why it's even needed um so anyway
just wanted to raise those concerns with
you so thanks very much
thank you
chair recognizes Henry lippman from dhh
yes
good morning chairman Pearson and
members of the committee my name's Henry
Littman I'm the Medicaid director for
the for the state
um and
um understanding
um
what uh representative Marsh and uh
Paula menahan relayed I think from the
Medicaid Program perspective we're
concerned what we see
um out there with respect to
um the number of birthing
obstetric opportunities there are in the
state of New Hampshire are declining and
that being able to recover some of the
costs related to this testing will be a
small part in trying to maintain an
adequate Network for Medicaid
beneficiaries
places where obstetric services are
disappearing are
you know more in the rural areas as well
and
um
you know there are concerns about the
continued viability of obstetric
services and other locations so I think
if
um providing some compensation in this
area would be supportive to maintaining
it and the department I think is
supportive in in working something out
here
thank you Mr Lipman is there anyone else
who wishes to testify
there is uh Andrew Hosmer and Krista
Gilbert with their hands up Andrew
Hosmer did you say yes yes the chair
recognizes Andrew Costner would you let
us know whom you represented
thank you
Mr Husband you'll just have to unmute
thank you very much thank you committee
my name is Andrew Hosmer I represent
Harvard Pilgrim Healthcare we are
signing in uh opposed to this bill uh
much like
ahip and Anthem uh it was this was not
an issue that we were aware of and
certainly think of it as an item that
can be negotiated between the carriers
and the providers here
um we think the bill as written I'm not
I think it creates more confusion on our
part than it does Direction and
certainly we think we'd look for an
opportunity to sit down with the
providers at some point here and craft a
solution
um outside of legislative mandates so
without taking up too much more of your
time I appreciate the opportunity to
speak and thank you
thank you Mr Mercer
Christina who is the other person
wishing to testify Krista Gilbert
okay I'm the chair calls upon you would
you please spell your name and tell us
who you represent
uh my name is Krista Gilbert
k-r-i-s-t-a-g-i-l-b-e-r-t
um I'm representing myself
um I
want to share that I um I have several
connections to the rare disorder
community
though I am representing myself I am the
state ambassador for the New Hampshire
air Action Network which is an advocacy
Branch for the National Organization for
rare disorders I am on the rare disease
advisory Council
um and I'm the vice president of the New
Hampshire rare disorders Association
I just want to share that I'm in support
of this bill
um the newborn screening
um is a diagnosis
conditions and is a life-saving
disability preventing measure and I
believe that this bill would provide
sustainable funding that would make it
easier to add new tests to the panel you
know this year three new tests were
added to the panel and as representative
Marsh stated you know there was someone
this year that was diagnosed with a
spinal muscular atrophy which allowed
that individual to be treated with a new
medication that was really life-changing
for that for that child
so I just I just want to speak in favor
is anyone on the committee have a
question for the one who just gave test
tomorrow
thank you for your testimony
thank you Christina is there anyone else
no other hands raised
say that again please
nope there are no other hands
thank you very much
where's that I close the hearing on how
to spell 600 and at the request of the
sponsor
move into the executive session on the
bill
and I would give representative March as
the prime sponsor the first opportunity
to speak in executive session
representative Market thank you Mr
chairman uh I will move ought to pass
and when I have a chance I'd like to
speak to my motion
do we have a second
second
please thank you representative Marsh
uh thank you Mr chairman uh those of us
who've been on this committee for some
time know that our bills frequently
provide the impetus for uh issues to get
resolved that have not been resolved uh
or even shown any uh any sign of being
addressed in the past and and I am
really thankful for the insurers for
appearing today and and I do believe
that as this bill moves through the
process this may get resolved offline
and it may get resolved to the point
that uh uh the bill no longer needs to
continue to move forward that being said
I think we need to continue this bill
moving forward uh so that the we
maintained uh and support our our
hospitals we all know that we have had a
hospital closure recently uh in the
middle of the State of New Hampshire we
also know that frisbee Hospital recently
has stopped their labor and delivery
program I believe that is the case
um if we don't support those places in
our state where babies are delivered
there won't be any place in our state to
have babies be delivered and that is a
real health problem that we need to
address so I think this is a very small
step towards supporting those
institutions and I'm hoping that the
rest of the committee will agree with me
thank you very much
I heard the word Amendment floated
sometime for the last 20 minutes is
there an amendment coming forward from
anyone I don't have it if there is
not to my knowledge Mr chairman
um Christina are you aware of an
amendment coming to us on this
no I am not thank you very much anyone
else in the committee
representative has a question
representative Kennard
thank you Mr chair I actually would just
like because it seems like the the
conflict here comes down to the question
of uh do hospitals realize they can bill
for the filter paper do they bill for
the filter paper and I think
representative Marsh answered that
question briefly earlier but could he
elaborate just a bit more so we can
understand because indeed if they simply
aren't because it's not allowed then
this bill really needs to go forward to
allow that could you could
representative Marsh clarify this issue
a little better
um yes I'll be glad to do that uh filter
paper is clearly a supply just like a
syringe would be a supply or a diaper
would be a supply hospitals do not build
separately for supplies however this
cost of the supply has been increasing
at a very rapid rate because it is being
used to pay for a test the test being
the genetic tests run on the blood what
we are asking very simply is that the
invoices change to read metabolic
screening panel so that it is clear what
the invoices are for once that is done
there's a their billing codes associated
with that title and at that point in
time negotiations can occur between the
various insurers and the the hospitals
and they can resolve this issue we're
not asking for an insurance mandate
we're not asking for any money to pay
for this we're not asking to change the
program in any way we just want to
change the title on the top of the
invoices
are there any other questions from the
committee
Mr chair yes representative Merchants if
I could speak to my second please
um
sort of uh
reinforcing what uh representative Marsh
is saying I don't see this as a quote
mandate except allowing for the
the ability for the biller to include
um
a mechanism to address the issue about
the supply that goes into the testing
and to representative Marsha's point of
view I totally agree that currently we
built for procedure codes and we built
for things that are related to a service
not so much per se for supplies and this
fundamentally allows for that to occur
it does not
interfere with the ability between the
insurance company and the hospital to
negotiate the price on the invoice
that's still left to them through the
normal Market channels we have today it
just recognizes that there is a cost and
a lot for that to be able to be included
on the invoice to the insurance company
thank you sir thank you representative
Merchant uh
part-time CEO of a facility that has
three primary care providers I can tell
you but I won't
difficulties
that we sometimes have that seem to get
resolved when legislation starts showing
up
so it could well be the case that as
this bill goes through the various
schools that
um negotiation will be satisfactorily
begun and concluded
but it's good to have a bill to help the
process go on so I underscore
representative Marsha on them from
seeing it on a most daily basis anyone
else in the committee
sorry
yeah
representative Nelson yeah I was muted I
apologize I had a question I said how
many tests are done it's one draw number
one of blood either for a newborn how
many tests are now done on that one draw
and how long when they go to read these
tests they just put in the machine and
zap out they come out with something I
have no idea
foreign
Dr Terrell will be the best person to
answer that question
thank you so much for for that question
representative Nelson we currently uh we
have uh approximately 12 000 birds in
New Hampshire so we have we run
basically almost 12 000 tests sometimes
they might be higher because uh for any
child sometimes the blood spot is not
enough so you might have to repeat or if
they are premature so we would have to
repeat some of those tests we have a
contract with uh University of
Massachusetts Medical School that runs
the test we actually currently do 37
tests 37 newborn different kinds of new
uh new for different 37 different
conditions that we test for
so and um you know we basically can zap
them and get the results it takes time
it takes a roughly uh 24 hours time to
get those results out and um that
information comes to us and our newborn
screening Nurse Program
um uh consultant basically calls up
based on if the screens are are at a
different level or abnormal screens we
actually follow up the both the uh reach
out to the family as well as to the
pediatrician for next steps and we also
link those families with their further
screening and further testing as well as
the treatment
thank you very much Dr Terrell anyone in
the committee wish to speak
the chair recognizes representative
Cushman thank you Mr chairman
representative Marsh I'm just wondering
so if these newborn screenings are
mandated
am I correct in that assumption
uh the individuals have the right to
refuse the test uh that is rarely done
but it is allowed
okay
follow up
so
this is a routine screening though that
that most most parents Will consent to
and
is it Medicaid does pay for this
um under but but they're not paying for
the the paper because of the billing
problem
just trying to really we had discussions
about this at the rare disease advisory
Council and according to Henry littmann
they consider uh the uh fee bundled into
their per diem under the Medicaid rate
and if it were recognized as a separate
test they'd say that they would enter
into negotiations such that the per diem
would go down and the test rate would
then be present and you know that's fine
that's their process I'm perfectly happy
for them to go through the process uh
and that really has nothing to do with
the bill what we just want is for the uh
test to be recognized as a test and
build as such
anyone else
the motion is hard to pass made by
representative Mark and second
representative Merchant and would report
please call the role
representative Marsh
but yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes
representative Captain yes
representative gay yes
representative pushman yes
representative Olson yes representative
Kelsey
yes
yes representative yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
snow yes
representative Kirk
yes
representative Solway
representative
yes yes
thank you representative Candace yes
representative yes
representative Shapiro
yes
representative Woods yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Pearson yes
21-0 any objection for it to go on to
consent
closed
executive session
and move on
to how to build
187 relative to the emergency powers of
the commissioner of Palestinians and
services and representative Mark Prime
sponsor would you introduce yourself
thank you Mr chairman
I am pleased today to offer for your
consideration House Bill 187 relative to
the emergency powers of the Commissioner
of Health and Human Services and I will
remind the committee that I did send out
an amendment uh last week uh I believe
it's zero one six one H which I intend
to be introducing at the same time as
this bill
this bill does not address the
governor's emergency orders other bills
do that I don't think they'll come to
our committee this bill addresses
emergency orders from the commissioner
of the Department of Health and Human
Services of which they were too and they
come under a separate RSA that's RSA 21p
on April 3rd the commissioner issued an
emergency order regarding the
prescribing and distribution of
chloroquine to treat covid-19
on September 1st she rescinded this
emergency order the bill also deals with
various powers under the public health
and infectious disease laws
let me go through the bill and hit the
highlights
page one lines 13 to 14 you will note
that we strike in any other law to the
contrary
as some of you may be aware certain
members of my family fell victim to the
Holocaust
the role doctors and nurses played in
the Holocaust is exceedingly troubling
I am troubled that current law allows
emergency orders in New Hampshire to
cert supersede certain criminal laws
not that I believe our commissioner
would ever do that so in principle I
think we need to strike those words from
the statute
page one line 17-23 you can see the
current law which I believe was
appropriately used to limit the
distribution of hydroxychloroquine under
the emergency order
the commissioner identified a shortage
and she took actions to prevent it from
affecting patients
but I'm not convinced that the
legislature intended to give the power
to the commissioner to prevent the
prescribing of a drug
that medical professionals had reason to
believe might be effective
changing restrict to prioritize and
adding lines 24 to 25 and the belt and
suspenders approach we've all become
accustomed to clarify that the
legislature is not granting that power
during build drafting the need for input
into the vaccine distribution plan
became evident
reviewing the statute I saw that we had
an existing Ethics Committee so I called
John Williams and asked who was on it
he told me that this had been put in
place at the previous print pandemic for
H1N1 but there were no current
appointees
the governor subsequently reconstituted
it
to be ready for the next pandemic we
referenced that in lines 26 to 29 and I
will discuss that further in section
three of the bill
page two line 16 and 17 we're changing
none of the language of the existing
statute but we are changing the
reference this is very important
actually
the language of the current statute
clearly states that an individual May
refuse treatment but the current
reference
rsa141c 15 6 States any law enforcement
officer shall take such individual into
custody and transport the individual to
the Placer facility where the treatment
is to be provided
those two things contradict each other
rsa141c16 clearly gives individuals the
right to refuse treatment and remain in
quarantine and I believe appropriately
so
the other reference RSA 141c
20c are the current grounds for refusing
vaccination and is an appropriate
reference here
page two line 29 and on is new language
one of our objectives
by r i mean one of the objectives of
Health leadership is to make sure that
emergency orders are subject to
legislative oversight
we currently have an HHS oversight
committee so we do not need to create a
committee for this purpose
with a current membership of five a
two-thirds vote would be four out of
five members that's an exceedingly high
threshold
chairman Pearson and I met with John
Williams and others from DHHS last
Wednesday and we agreed to language
clarifying that legislative oversight
orders under sections five and six shall
be by the ethics oversight committee
which you will discuss in section three
that was the origin of the amendment
that I circulated last week
we agreed at the same meeting to delete
section 2 as people subject to orders
already have defined rights to appeal so
I will just ask you to ignore that
section we're going to remove it by
Amendment
thank you
section three of the bill is a rewrite
of the Ethics Committee established for
H1N1 to accomplish five things
one the committee should actually have
appointees and exist when it is needed
by appointing legislators to the
committee we can make sure that will
happen
number two the committee should review
investigations orders and treatments
order to make sure they've been done
appropriately and fairly as some have
questioned whether that is in fact the
case
number three last year's committee
members know we were contacted by an
individual representing a disabled
individual who felt that their rights
were violated as a mask order prevented
them from getting needed Medical Care
we discussed having a commission to
address such concerns this Ethics
Committee already in statute seems a
logical place to address such concerns
and we've charged them with doing so
number four the governor used the state
disaster medical advisory committee to
reconstitute this Ethics Committee to
create the vaccine distribution plan
it was appropriate and it was well done
there is currently no data to suggest
that the current vaccines
provide prevent the spread of disease
the data shows that they prevent serious
illness in people who get this disease
if there were such evidence it would be
debatable whether the vaccine should
first be deployed to protect the most
vulnerable members in our society or to
interrupt the vectors that spread
disease the intent is that when plans
have to be made for the next pandemic
the appropriate discussion happens by an
appropriate body
number five uh the part the department
felt that the police and fire members of
the prior incarnation of the Ethics
Committee did not bring to a lot to the
table and they asked that we removed
them from the committee
the amendment we agreed to on Wednesday
rewrites the section to be less
burdensome to the ethics oversight
advisory committee by using Aggregate
and de-identified data I have I believe
with the current surge in covid-19 that
burden would have become burdensome uh
with the number of cases going forward
last we've been in discussion with the
speaker's office regarding the
membership changes to HHS oversight in
last year's House Bill 1245 on page nine
we do not believe those changes were
intended to remove minority party input
from HHS oversight and the amendment
adds a section to undo those changes and
I think representative Pearson for that
language
uh thank you and I'll be glad to take
questions
I have a question
representative yes representative Nelson
two questions uh representative Marsh in
an emergency a dirty bomb or something
like that and you don't have time to
gather people together to this committee
what would happen
outright emergency that decision has to
be made within a couple hours
nothing would be different compared to
the current procedure all the legis
oversight uh by this bill is done
retrospectively and after the fact so
therefore we have put it in place that
whatever decisions were made will be
looked at to make sure that they've been
done correctly and fairly uh but nothing
would prevent emergency actions from
needing to be taken in a short period of
time so we don't want to interfere with
the operations of the department in any
way
thank you
representative Weber
I I did not have my hand up it's
representative Nutter Upham who is
Raising her hand and she's raising her
physical hand rather than one of the
ones on the screen
for taking my question
um representative Marsh I have
um the original Bill and your Amendment
and there was a
I just want to make sure is there any
place in this bill that forces someone
to take a vaccination
uh there's nothing in the bill that
forces anyone to take a vaccination the
Commissioner of Health and Human
Services is currently allowed to order
treatment under the Infectious Disease
statute
um
and not that I believe she's ordered
anybody to uh have a vaccination so that
is currently allowed under current law
and she would continue to have the
ability to order a treatment under the
law as amended by this however we would
clarify the fact that a person so
ordered would have the right to remain
in quarantine and refuse treatment
whereas as I pointed out in my testimony
there's currently a great there's
conflict between the language and the
bill and the statutory reference which
would not allow that to happen so uh I
think that the overall intent of the
bill is to support the right that
individuals have a right to refuse
treatment although they may need to
remain in quarantine if they refuse
treatment for the protection of the
public okay thank you very much for
clarifying that
anyone else in the committee
the chair recognizes Melissa sincere for
from the Department of Health and Human
Services who's going to speak against us
and the chair recognizes you to speak
thank you
um Mr chair and members of the committee
for the record my name is Melissa sancer
I'm the chief legal officer for the
Department of Health and Human Services
and
um we um did work with representative
Marsh and others on the committee to
um adjust uh certain sections of this
bill and there is one section that I
think we still have some concern with
um and I would like to actually turn my
time over to Trish Tilly I certainly can
speak after she's done but uh Trisha
Tilley is the deputy director of for
public health and um and she's going to
raise her hand and and take my time if
if that if the committee will allow that
is acceptable to the chair and it
recognize this because
good morning this is Trisha Tilley um
can you hear me
yes great good morning thank you for the
opportunity to speak about the
fundamental powers of the department to
control mitigate and prevent infectious
disease during Public Health emergencies
as you know my name is Patricia Tilley
and I'm the deputy director of the
division of Public Health at the
Department of Health and Human Services
these powers to isolate quarantine or
control access to an exposure are
designed to protect the public to
protect you and me and by preventing
exposure to people who have or may have
a contagious disease or places or
conditions that are unhealthy
the commissioner also has the authority
and duty to control and potentially
ration the use or sale of life-saving
pharmaceuticals and to prioritize which
groups may have access during a public
health emergency as described by
representative Marsh's introduction
these powers are designed to be used
sparingly and only in extreme cases as
attorney Saint Seer can better explain
in the details of the legal language
there are current safety nets for due
process already built into the statute
for individuals directly impacted by an
official order individuals may request a
hearing in Superior Court in accordance
with New Hampshire RSA 141c as
representative Marsh also noted
never in our lifetimes have the powers
these Powers been so visible and so
needed to the extent that we are seeing
today
the commissioner's Authority is an
important tool in our toolbox to swiftly
control outbreaks and disease and we
have used the expertise of
epidemiologists Physicians and others to
help guide us through these complex
ethical decisions
even in the emergency we are currently
experiencing there have only been two
official orders under p21 made by the
commissioner of DHHS
we have worked closely with the sponsor
of the bill and we welcome the notion of
review by joint legislative oversight
committee as well as the ethics
oversight advisory committee to review
patterns and to make recommendations
we understand that it is not the intent
to create a committee by which Swift and
Urgent decisions are made in real time
to keep the public safe or to routinely
overturn these emergency decisions
we all agree that the privacy and health
information of individuals must be
maintained
we look forward to the opportunity to
working with committees as described in
the bill but we are still concerned
about the ability of joint legislative
committee to overturn decisions made by
the commissioner
attorney Saint Seer will be able to walk
us through the details of the lingual
language in both RSA 21p and RSA 141c
it's important to keep in mind the
difference in the types of orders that
are made
so we have one set of orders that have
been made through the emergency Powers
as representative March described that
talked about the prioritizing of
pharmaceuticals and then we have another
set of orders of quarantine and
isolation that are generally fall under
RSA 141c and that those orders are
related to keeping people safe
um from infectious disease and ordering
folks to quarantine or to potentially to
receive treatment if not quarantine so
I'm going to hand the time back to uh
attorney Saint Sierra she can point to
the specific references but we wanted to
come today and say that we appreciate
and we are willing to work hand in hand
with the sponsors of this bill we think
that there's an opportunity for us to
move forward but we still have concerns
about the ability to overturn decisions
of the commissioner thank you
representative uh March do you wish to
speak at this time or after uh councilor
sincere speaks
let me just say that we did meet and I
believe that the department and those of
us who met with the Department agreed on
almost every point
the only issue that we did not reach
agreement is on page it's on page two of
the bill it's on page three of the PDF
line 31 and that would be the language
that says and may be rescinded by a
two-thirds vote of that committee
and at the end of the day this is a
balance of powers issue either the
legislature has the right to say no when
something is Extreme
buy a super majority vote it's a very
high super majority vote actually or
they do not and that's a fundamental
policy decision that needs to be decided
and I do not anticipate that the
department will ever agree with us on
that
and we'll just continue to discuss this
going forward so thank you very much
point of procedure Mr chairman thank you
guys
um normally we have a sponsor testify
and then other people testify but I
don't remember any time in the past when
the sponsor has been allowed recognized
to answer each subsequent person as they
testify that would happen either at a
subcommittee meeting or at an executive
session and I think it's a bad precedent
to be setting to allow the sponsor uh
second dibs and third dibs and fourth
dibs
it is of course up to the chairman but I
just note that for the record thank you
representative Weber duly noted the
chair recognizes again counselor
thank you so much Mr chairman members of
the committee
um so for the bill representative Marsh
is correct it is
um paragraph eight where
um the the committee would have the
ability to rescind
uh in order that was was created by our
uh commissioner through obviously uh the
use of of experts and and otherwise to
um we would like to change that to
recommendations
um the oversight committee right now for
Health and Human Services obviously is
the legislative oversight committee for
the Department
um the statute specifically says that
it's to support cost-effective
comprehensive Coordinated Care
um it's it's also to promote greater
efficiencies consolidating and
centralizing Reporting requirements and
other responsibilities of the department
to avoid duplication and efforts and and
so I just want to note that typically
our relationship with Health and Human
Services oversight committee is is is
for that purpose we do a lot of
reporting to them and they definitely
are involved in in the work that the
department does providing
recommendations and so we think that
that would be an appropriate amendment
to this bill if that we could change
that recision being able to rescind our
our experts decision making around this
to just being recommendations made to
the commissioner by by the Health and
Human Services oversight Committee in
that paragraph I think our other concern
other than just
um you know that language is that it
seems to be very broad it says any
emergency order issued under
um under this section and and when
speaking with representative Marsh he he
made it very clear that the expectation
wouldn't be to
um you know review every order and that
paragraphs what was previously
paragraphs or maybe they still are
paragraphs five and six where it's
talking about
um ordering somebody to go through some
type of medical treatment as well as
compelling an investigation if we're
investigating a a
facility for not doing appropriate care
or whatnot around the emergency that
that those two would kind of be carved
out in the amendment those two would be
carved out and they would be subject to
oversight by the Ethics Committee but I
also think that other than just those
two paragraphs there are other things
within the 21 on p53 which is what we're
amending here that there are some Powers
just specifically paragraph one where
the commissioner has the responsibility
and authority to carry out all public
health activities within the state if if
all of if while carrying out all of her
Public Health activities
um her his uh her at this point
um that that those would be subject to
um rescission any decision made under
paragraph one would be subject to
rescission and I understand form
representative Marsh that that's not the
expectation but I do believe that that
currently as drafted it is much more
broad than than what we had discussed
and so I'm just concerned from a legal
perspective that that there is a breath
to this order or to this bill that would
um allow for orders to be overturned for
essentially anything that the
commissioner has the responsibility for
so so that that's just um all I I have
to say I'm certainly happy to answer a
question any questions that you have
any questions from the committee
uh representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman representative
Marsh can you please just clarify for
the committee exactly what your
Amendment changes about the bill like
briefly just exactly what is different
representative Marty
uh yes I'm right here just let me bring
the amendment up on the screen it'll
take me a second to do that
okay I now have on my screen Amendment
zero one six one H uh to uh the bill
which I circulated to the committee last
week if anybody doesn't have it
um send an email and we can do it first
of all we deleted section uh two of the
bill
um which would have given
more appeal rights to people who were
subject to emergency orders under
paragraphs five and six previously
mentioned because we realized that they
already have those appeal rights and uh
so therefore that section of the bill
becomes unnecessary uh second we added a
paragraph nine after paragraph eight
paragraph eight being the uh paragraph
that has the rescinding of clause in it
that everybody is questioning about and
paragraph nine specifically carves out
orders issued under paragraph five or
six as attorney said uh and assigns that
oversight to the ethics oversight
advisory committee uh which is precisely
what you said
um
uh then we moved what was previously
section three of the bill up into
section two because we had deleted
section two uh and we reworded the uh uh
charge to the ethics oversight advisory
committee to make clear that these uh
that their oversight was being done in
aggregate with uh de-identified data
um and and the that language came from
the department and when we agreed to it
entirely
uh and the last thing is we added a
section uh to the bill to change the
membership of the Health and Human
Services oversight committee uh because
the number of us uh separately have
realized that that it may be problematic
for a great many reasons and this is the
only Bill currently in the legislature
to my knowledge whereby it would be
germane to change the membership of the
Health and Human Services oversight
committee because we're talking about a
charge to the Health and Human Services
oversight committee so that in very
briefly is what the amendment does
point of order again Mr chairman yes
well I believe it was the department who
was testifying and we have now had the
sponsor of the bill helpful and clear as
he is and I applaud him for that has now
testified four times on the bill uh
questions as they come in during
hearings should be only to the person
who is currently testifying and when we
get through all the testimony of all the
people who want to talk to us that's the
time for us to have the discussion among
ourselves about clarifications changes
and other things but it is inappropriate
to have the bill sponsor testify
repeatedly
thank you again newly noted thank you
representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman
introduce the amendment
I haven't heard a motion to introduce
this event
he
he was attempting to explain it less
when we go through the bill we read
things that won't be there because my
concern is that we're discussing
something that's not in front of us
I'm not talking you know procedure
that but I think the proper thing would
be for him because I like the Amendments
that it should be actually presented to
us as an amendment
I believe in the exact session it will
be
but let me uh and if I may Mr chairman
we have always allowed sponsors to bring
an amendment with them when they
presented the bill initially and to run
through it as part of their initial
presentation that Christina please bring
up records of Mr Michael Walsh thank you
thank you
if Mr Walsh is available would you
please raise your hand
Mr chair I had to crush my hand up for a
question to the previous Witness
let's see if Mr Walsh is here and if not
I'll recognize you and if he is I'll
take you next
I do not currently see Mr Welsh in that
case the chair recognizes it sounds like
representative Kennard yes sir
yes my question is for Melissa Saints
here her comment toward the end was she
felt that this was too broad my question
is are can you give us some guidance of
how it might be narrowed in a way that
would be acceptable to DHHS
yes thank you representative for your
question
um we believe that
the rescission makes the power to
broaden the ability to rescind so if the
the paragraph Was adjusted that any
emergency order issued should be subject
to review by The Joint legislative
committee and recommendations made to
the commissioner that would be
acceptable language and would would
obviously save our concerns but but
um we would we would welcome
recommendations by the by the commission
to hopefully
um you know give us any feedback related
to orders that may have been issued by
the commissioner that they feel
um you know we're not done appropriately
didn't take appropriate information or
whatnot and so that would be our
recommendation
any follow-up
no thank you welcome anyone else in the
committee with a question for uh
the chairman recognizes Kevin Casserly
who wishes to testify
sure were you waiting on me
I didn't understand you say again
were you looking for the next speaker I
was calling on Kevin passerly if he is
not present
then
is he present I do not see him
um
are there okay then the chair recognizes
Heather Evans who has signed up to speak
foreign
s
that exhausts the list that was printed
out for me earlier this morning if there
anyone else from the public who wishes
to testify who has signed up since then
we have Thomas McLeod
the chair recognizes Thomas McLeod
uh yes uh Mr chairman my name is Thomas
McLeod I resided Mount Vernon New
Hampshire I am the chair of the Liberty
defense Fund in New Hampshire and they
uh part of the leadership team of health
food from New Hampshire today I'll
testify uh as a member of the public uh
Mr chairman uh the the amendment
um that is uh that I have here appears
to address
um the concern the main concerns I had
with the bill
um
in particular uh the concern was the the
original Bill appeared to make uh Court
jurisdiction discretionary because of
the words uh if the petition is granted
uh now that section has been uh removed
uh and uh it defers to the original
language in 141c so uh I support uh
strongly support the bill I feel it's a
um a necessary clarification
of the existing powers of the
commissioner and they also support the
amendment and with that all in my
testimony thank you thank you would you
uh accept the question from the
Community member absolutely
does a committing member have a question
subscribe for your testimony Christina
are there any other people
who wish to speak
I see no raised hands
um
and I should have done some when I
should have done some of the things I
did before and with apologies to the
committee and appreciation to its former
chair
do I hear a motion representative Marsh
would you like to move your bill
yes but Mr chairman
um I will be glad to do that I will move
ought to pass with Amendment and the
amendment number is zero one six one H
we're first going to move I have this
wonderful
instruction the Motions are first moved
to adopting amendments so that is the
motion I take now I believe yes I move
can I do a second
second so representative Solomon
now
um
representative marks anything you wish
I I am not certain that the committee
really wants to uh exact the bill at
this time
um but I'm satisfied personally with
Amendment zero one six one H I believe
it addresses all of the Department's
concerns uh with the exception of their
one concern that they do not wish to
have the oversight committee to have the
authority uh even on a super majority
vote to uh rescind an emergency order
and I believe that to be used uh very
occasionally and by a super majority
vote it is an appropriate uh uh a power
for the the committee to have so uh I
would prefer that the bill move forward
with that clause in place
uh
our general feeling is that there is
some value in this and then there are
some problems with this
I would prefer in the executive session
that we retain the bill for other than
um
representative McKay we have a motion on
the floor about the Amendments but then
when it is time to
consider the bill has amended that I
believe then that would be
a good time perhaps I just want to sneak
it in
let me get that but thank you
yes by representative gay
I don't know if I'm sure to thank you
for taking my question or my statement
banking is always a good thing I don't
know either but go ahead okay
um the impression I'm getting is that
the amendment
uh did a good job of removing some
things that felt onerous
and it retains the real point the whole
point that I can see of this bill
is to give legislative oversight to
decisions earlier even though it was
meant in the best
and motivated by very high intentions
one of the statements one of the
decisions by the commissioner this year
outlawed the use of a medicine that has
since been proven to be effective
and so that really should not have stood
this is the only way to prevent that
from happening so I totally support the
amendment because I totally support the
bill
thank you representative
anyone else wish to speak
Mr chairman representative Weber is her
hand up
okay I can't see if I'm here
representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman I was just
wondering if we had time to work on the
bill
or is this a bill that needs to be exact
today
it does not need to be exact today
my concern and I have to balance
not wishing to
run jobs with the fact that Not only was
the calendar extremely tied we still do
not know if we're going to be needing in
any capacity tomorrow
um
I don't know how many days I'm being
assigned so there is a concern
um I might underscore what people have
been saying that really it is do we or
do we not believe that with a high bar
threshold
the oversight committee should have some
say in rescinding good thing yeah that's
it right I understand what the concerns
is I was just trying to find out if we
had time
but I realized that this vote is on the
amendment and so I will I will state
that I think the amendment solves
certain issues that have already been
raised to everybody's satisfaction so
um I am going to state that I will vote
for the amendment and then when we get
to the bill itself we can discuss
whether we want to go forward or whether
more work needs to happen
and I I will ask you a question please
because I couldn't find it at Mason's
I'm a co-sponsor
of the amendments
do I as co-sponsor slash chair
have the right to speak for about 30
seconds absolutely when when we get to
Executive session everybody can speak
and the chair or at least the former
chair often drafted amendments and spoke
to them and and it's only in the hearing
that we are deferential uh to the rights
of the public so that the the sponsors
are not
um
you know
um given both the opportunity to be a
sponsor and a questioner
see what you said earlier
shouting open
it's quite all right
um and and
um but but you you go go right ahead and
you know whatever your opinions are
everybody has a right to their opinions
in an executive session
as my mother used to say you have the
right to be wrong
I think it's been 30 seconds on the
amendments
two-thirds vote
is a high bar and in the amendment we
have given some a point of authority
specifically to the minority leader
which wasn't there before
secondly at least some of the oversight
committee people are medical people in
some capacity or another so it is not an
oversight committee being made of
farmers and mechanics and speaking to
Medical people it's not quite that and
then thirdly
this is a safety boundary
I've got two pages of people who signed
in
in favor of this right
citizens or the citizens legislature and
have the ability to overrule a
government edit
quite honestly safety valves are very
important
because if you put too much steam
pressure
in a container with no vent
eventually it might blow
and I don't want that
so to have at least on paper
the knowledge to people that it is
possible for the citizens to say wait a
minute here I think May provide a safety
valve without it being
you know the inmates taking over the
Asylum part of the industry so for that
reason I not only supported
and unfortunately I I wrote it
with representative Marsh and have to be
taught to DHHS
uh representative Copeland you had your
hand up please
yes thank you Mr chairman
um I I believe that this amendment moves
the bill in the right direction I also
agree with representative gay that um to
um to to do anything to to change the
existing measures in the Bill of the
amendment uh for a two-thirds super
majority uh would essentially uh remove
the fundamental purpose of the bill
which is to provide legislative
oversight
for what it's worth I'm actually not
totally comfortable with the idea of a
two-thirds super majority I will vote
for the amendment and I vote will vote
for the bill because I think that it
moves things in the right direction I
will also point out that the two-thirds
majority because there are five members
um actually is a de facto 80 majority
um so I I think that uh as it is
currently written
um it is entirely reasonable
um to uh to to ask for that I think it
would be uh even more reasonable to ask
for a smaller number uh but uh but I
would support the amendment as it is I
think a lot of work has gone into this
bill I think it moves uh moves things in
the right direction and I support the
amendment the ability of the oversight
committee
who
percent
kicks in simultaneously
with
The increased number of people
so there'll be seven not five
maybe you can do the math in your head
but two-thirds of seven okay thank you
for the clarification
others representative
thank you Mr chairman um I just want to
speak in support of the bill
um and as Amendment
in the amendment sorry I I support the
amendment
um and I think it's a good start it's a
step in the right direction to rebalance
the powers here
others
on the amendment
zero six one eight
house bill 187.
before they call the rule
representative marks
that's yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
Acton yes
representative gay yes representative
Cushman yes representative Folsom yes
representative Kelsey yes
representative King yes
representative Cobalt yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative snow yes
representative nurse yes
representative soloway
yes
representative Cannon yes
representative
another outcome yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods
yes
representative Merchant
representative Pearson yes
21-0 on the amendment
Mr chairman uh representative Moore
I make a subsequent motion of ought to
pass as amended
otpa is there a second
me
I saw representative
representative Brooklyn
now we can discuss the bill as amended
representative mechanics thank you Mr
chairman that I hear the in the
amendment of the actual language that
increases the members of the African
services
you don't have the Amendments did you
okay does anybody have an extra
Amendment are there amendments for the
day
it would be zero six one h
let's see if we can Mr chairman that
would be zero one six one-h zero one six
one eight okay
okay thank you thank you very much
in the amendments
the whole section
two from the Senate fighting from
accounts
Mr chairman would you like me to just
read it
I think he's found it
but you can read it out loud too I would
appreciate it
the the changes are it it as you know or
as you may not know in one of the
um Omnibus bills the membership of the
Health and Human Services oversight
committee was reduced from its former
five house members to three house
members which creates enormous amounts
of concern in terms of
representation both from you know the
various committees and also uh for the
minority and so this would put it back
it leaves the Senate at two which is
where the Senate wants to be it would
have five members of The house's
Representatives three of whom from hell
are from Health and Human Services and
one from the house finance committee
division responsible for Health and
Human Services which is essentially as
it is now but with the clarification
that it's from uh Division I think it's
three and then two members of the House
of Representatives one of whom shall be
appointed by the speaker and one of whom
shall be appointed by the leader of the
minority party and these two are going
to serve as alternates so at a time when
we cannot get a full compliment which is
practically every meeting for one reason
or another there are two dedicated
alternates to sub in for the five
members that we have now so we're we're
basically returning it to the way it was
with five members one of whom is going
to be from finance and three of whom are
protected from Health and Human Services
and then
um we are are adding the two alternates
one from each party so that they can be
appointed if needed
is that a fair summary representative
Marsh
seven isn't it seven
and there are also two senators we
didn't change that
so there are seven yes so there are
seven people in all
which means giving
that is super maturity super super
committee
I believe representative salloway was
asking a question no just seeing him I
recognize representative Solway
he's waving off
okay I still recognize him
anyone else
representative Cushman so just to speak
on the bill now please
as amended I support this bill
um we've seen some overreach during this
emergency I feel we've seen the rights
of prescribing Physicians to order
medications that they deem appropriate
to treat patients be restricted we've
seen that the legislature has had little
to no
power over emergency orders
um and I personally would like a lower
majority on the oversight committee but
I again I think that this is a good
start so thank you thank you anyone else
which I recognizes representative Bolton
thank you
um I am also in support of this bill as
amended for the reason that the chair
gave of it being a safety valve for the
people who are so frustrated that they
have no control and
um that is what I have seen out our way
develop into anger and just knowing that
there is going to be a safety valve that
they actually have
summary of recourse will bring a whole
lot more comfort and will dial down
the anger and frustration that has been
felt
there's no other
questions or statements representative
snow has his hand raised
there you are
the purposes of clarification
we now have five members and two
alternates are the two alternates
clearly identified as alternates and do
they sometimes show up at meetings and
find out if everybody else is there so
there's no purpose in there being there
and see the purpose of the alternate as
if the chair of the oversight committee
understands the day before somebody on
vacation somebody said that an alternate
would be asked to come in to fill that's
fine
so ordinarily how did okay
so then the two alternates are clearly
identified but they would not attend a
meeting unless invited to attend and
would not participate in other meetings
is that correct
I would invite them to attend
and participate
but not vote
if they take the place of one of the
statutory members but be there their
wisdom
everything except voted
and they act clearly identified so they
know they may not get to vote
yes thank you
Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um
first of all I want to thank um
representative Marsh for being so
attentive to detail and so attentive to
explaining the detail which I'm still
not sure I understand
um but I appreciate it
um also for creating the high bar for
um overturning an emergency decision by
HHS
given my appreciation for those things
unlike some of the other people who have
spoken
I probably
um I'm more concerned about the lack of
forceful guidance from our state
government rather than overreach and I
understand we have different ideological
points of view I think there are times
when
um the governor
could have been more
forceful in terms of emergency orders to
keep the state safe
right
a specific question that's I'm not sure
is Jermaine to the
um the specifics of the amendment and
the bill but it did get brought up
initially
um
and I think it's maybe part of the
subtext of the bill which is the whole
issue of the potentially ordering
vaccines
um creating a mandate for vaccines and I
know that representative Marsh you I
think in response to a question early on
in this hearing talked about the fact
that um
if vaccines were mandated which they are
clearly not and nobody has talked about
wanting to do that as far as I know you
said even if that was the case that
people would have the right to
um refuse
but that they would be
um somehow they would
be obligated to quarantine themselves if
that was an order if I'm understanding
this correctly they would be obligated
to quarantine themselves
if that scenario
even came up
um how would that quarantine be enforced
or would it be enforced
may I respond Mr chairman
yes as I stated in my testimony under
existing law and under the law as it
would be amended by this if we do enact
it into law the Commissioner of Health
and Human Services retains the right to
order treatments those treatments
include vaccination
uh under existing law we clearly have
the statutory language that says that a
person has the right to refuse such a
treatment however the statutory
reference in existing law then directs
that person to a Justice of the Peace
who shall order the person there's no
discretion given to be brought in in the
treatment be given so I think it is at
least debatable that under existing law
the commissioner could in fact mandate
vaccines in order whomever she wants to
to have that done and there would be
very little in the way of recourse that
might be found differently in the courts
but it's at least confusing if we pass
this bill as we have amended it then it
is abundantly clear the commissioner
retains the ability to order treatments
but it clarifies the fact that people
have the right to refuse treatments and
remain in quarantine which if nothing
else gives the courts decide time to
rule on the subject before anything is
actually done to anyone which I think is
a very sensible measure we did not
remove the ability of the Commissioner
of Health and Human Services to order
treatments in the first place I agree
with other people that I think that that
would be a step too far and interfere
with the operations of the department
which we do not wish to do so this bill
was a very fine Balancing Act
representative Weber
can I can I have a follow-up yes you may
have a follow-up I apologize for not
giving you that chance representative
Shapiro that's okay
um I certainly think it makes sense to
um
take the contradictions out of the bill
that it doesn't make sense to say that
um somebody can refuse treatment but
then law enforcement in some way can um
have them not refuse treatment so I
think taking the contradictions in law
is out of the bill out of out of law is
important but in the scenario you
described if someone was to refuse if an
order was given
for treatment
and a citizen refused treatment
What would
what would the measure to enforce
um quarantine be or would there not be
any
representative Marshall the measures to
enforce quarantine are not addressed in
this bill in in any way uh honestly I do
have a billion uh relative to health
officers that's going to Municipal and
County government my opinion is that
arguably it could have gone to this
committee but it's going to Municipal
and County government which will involve
local Health officers more directly in
enforcing quarantine orders and I agree
with you that that is a very important
issue but it is not a subject of the
bill before you right now
thank you very much
representative Weber
um I think I think
um my comment probably relates back to
representative Snow's question about the
composition of the Health and Human
Services oversight committee which of
course is a whole different issue from
the the committee that would be making
these decisions uh
I was just going to point out that we
have any number of committees like
jalcar already who have appointed
specific
alternates and generally speaking they
either go to or monitor all the meetings
so that they will be familiar with the
actions that have happened in the past
and that they will be ready to step in
if they need to step in but it's not a
New Concept for a number of the
Committees that we have
so I just wanted to clarify that thank
you
reprogenerative Acton
uh yes uh thank you for letting me speak
I I come at this I'm in support of this
bill and and I come at this as a
somewhat of a moderate on the issue I I
have no problem wearing my mask I'm
already set up to get my my vaccine in
March uh I generally supported the
governor but in this case here it's not
a conceptual thing we're working on the
the decision to ban hydroxychloroquine
was a very questionable act there was a
lot of research that that shows that
this was working and it and it appeared
to be politically motivated and so I
think we we definitely need some type of
of uh checks and balances from the
legislature on decisions like this
because we don't know what kind of
pressure is being applied to Health and
Human Services Department from the
federal government or or whatever other
entities we need to so we need to be
able as a legislature have a say in in
big decisions because
you know hydrochlorothia may have helped
patients who didn't get that help and uh
that was a really questionable call so I
I hope we can pass this thank you
thank you Representatives now
yes this is really just a follow-up to
my last question we know seven members
of the Health and Human Services
oversight committee if four of the
regular members at both alternates show
up who chooses which of the two
alternates will now be the voting member
that could lead to some uh criticism if
if somebody feels the wrong one was
chosen
you could indeed I believe that would be
the choice of the chair the choice of
the chair
thank you
representative works
uh thank you Mr chair did you say
representative Woods or
I did no thank you uh this is just a
sidebar question almost uh was there
consideration on the Ethics Committee to
have an Ethics a medical ethicist on
board not that the the folks identified
wouldn't act ethically but
um sometimes another dimension is
brought into consideration by a real
formal ethicist
may I answer that question Mr chairman
yesterday
uh yes the Department of Health and
Human Services did mention that uh but
then they informed us that they were not
prepared to bring the language forward
at this time and that they were
perfectly content with bringing that
language forward in the Senate and
perhaps we will continue to negotiate on
the membership of the ethics oversight
advisory committee
brought that question too because I have
taught methods
and there are
sort of protocols in doing ethics that
sometimes coincide with common sense and
sometimes don't so I brought that point
too uh I would like that in this bill
but going forward to looking
again at what the Ethics Committee
will bring in as experts when they're
discussing ethical questions so
representative Woods on tracking with
you thank you
representative merchants
uh thank you Mr chairman uh I wanted to
commend representative Marsh for what
you're doing one of the things I just
wanted to bring the attention to the
committee
when we had the hydroxychloroquine issue
one of the unintended consequences that
we had was that many patients that were
on chronic therapy for rheumatoid
arthritis because all of a sudden the
supply chain a drug disappeared
literally and patients who needed it
routinely for the underlying long-term
chronic condition we're faced with a
consequence was no alternative to it at
that point in time
so representative March I totally
support a physician having the ability
to prescribe based upon the patient
however I do have a concern as a
pharmacist about how do we prioritize
drug therapy and the availability of
those drugs in order to take care of the
patients how we prioritize that
accordingly because unfortunately one of
the ways we dealt with it was the
Restriction which then put a halt to it
so I'm fundamentally okay with
prescribing it but how do we help the
pharmacist in the community to be sure
that patients who are on chronic
medications like this
are in fact able to get the medication
thank you
may I respond yes
I think as I made clear in my testimony
in this bill what the uh Commissioner of
Health and Human Services did to
prioritize the distribution of
chloroquine and hydroxychloroquine I
think was totally appropriate and was
well done uh that being said uh I I
think that for her to say that one could
not prescribe the drug which would for
instance allow a patient to order a drug
from a mail order pharmacy out of state
uh was inappropriate and overreach
because there was never mentioned in
this statute the ability to restrict
prescribing so uh I think we're again
trying to walk a very fine line here and
we've done our best to thread the needle
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman I just want to
speak to a concern of one of the
representatives a little while ago about
enforcement of quarantine worrying that
there was no way to do such but it is
already written into statute that they
will use the least restrictive means
possible and that a person should be
able to choose where they have their
quarantine but if it is written into RSA
141c under Section
uh 13. that if anyone refuses to
cooperate with the quarantine orders the
commissioner May issue a complaint
that's sworn before justice of the peace
and they can give it to any law
enforcement officer who then has the
ability to take that individual into
custody and transport them back to where
they were to be quarantined
so just to alleviate that concern I
think it's in there that's helpful
anyone else
the motion is ought to pass
as amended but still 187 amended by 161h
ought to pass Amendment as amended
built by representative Moore seconded
by representative Cushman with the court
please call the role
representative Marshfields yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes
representative Acton yes
representative gay yes representative
Cushman yes representative Folsom yes
representative Kelsey yes
representative King yes representative
copology yes
representative Weber
yes
oh representative McKay no
representative snow yes
representative Kirk
yes
representative Solway yes
representative Cannon yes
representative yes
representative Shapiro
no
representative Woods
yes
representative Merchant
yes representative Pearson yes
19-2 unless
really
successfully talks me out of that
I've been flying not submitted on
consent because I think yeah the issue
is
judge that
we can discuss it on the floor Mr
chairman I agree it should be on the
regular calendar yep as do I thank you I
would have objected to consent as well
regular calendar
um before we have a five minute break
the uh somebody from the fourth floor
brought down
representative knurse Amendment to the
next bill that we will be hearing and
everybody in the room here has received
a copy of a message zero zero three two
h
D have the people at home received
Mr chair may I speak that I I had set it
up email a couple of days ago but seeing
what happened in the previous one where
some people didn't have the amendment I
sent an email I sent it over and asked
them to please come down with a few
copies for the people that were there in
person everybody else should have it on
their email well well I I didn't want to
proceed if we
now finish the executive session
but
yep
Ken you're not muted oh
you're welcome
enjoy yourself
together
our sales
it's just it's anything for sale man you
know
you see it sometimes that she realizes
yeah a Realtors
trying to promote a competitive that
he's uh yeah I call it a pseudo watching
yeah but notwithstanding that but the
rates what they have
not much more for homes
the affordability issue is is right of
ambulance available now
you folks in that conference room just
be aware we can still hear you
yeah is it interesting
they're here to help
my assistant
[Music]
it's
everything
but
just to make sure that we should also
replicate here
budget obligations
based on evaluations
oh yeah
but so you want to do it
challenge folks
great
this is
one of your brothers
[Music]
I don't know do you remember
okay
structure would be nice if we can move
that screen to the middle of the room
so much bigger
can we really see us because we're so
tiny in that condition as well
that's okay
um
on them
[Music]
there was an emergency
furnace and stuff
I've had enough problems supporting
people
lost it again
everything
manages
they'll just screw up 14
000. you representative March yes
[Music]
there's no way I can read
Beth I got your email you don't need to
cause feedback
okay
um
and would representative
introduces bill please
yes sir Mr chair
um let me just pull it back up here okay
this bill will look familiar to those of
you who are on the committee last year
and I sent out a rather long and
detailed information on it to everybody
before so you could review the amendment
and the bill and try to make sense out
of it
um one thing that oh sorry for the
record I'm representative Jerry Carroll
three Madison Tamworth Albany and
freedom
now one thing that covid-19 has taught
us this year is the importance of
vaccines and the need for their
widespread use the vaccines really are
one of our most important Public Health
tools because they prevent millions of
illnesses and same save numerous lives
each year what this bill does is to
substantially decrease the costs of
vaccines to our insurers and hopefully
increase vaccination rates
the bill establishes a public-private
partnership between DHHS and the
insurers to enable the insurers to
access a federal program to purchase
adult vaccines at about one half of what
they normally pay
this Universal purchasing program is in
bulk and only available to governmental
units not to the insurers individually
or the providers individually
this program will allow the insurers and
therefore ultimately all of us who pay
their premiums to save millions in
vaccine costs
all administrative costs to this program
are covered as this program is designed
by the insurance companies
currently there are three other states
that do this Alaska Rhode Island and
Vermont
so what this does does is this bill
extends to adults the already existing
very successful program for purchasing
pediatric vaccines in New Hampshire the
implementation should be pretty
straightforward using in for the
existing things we've learned in
infrastructure of that pediatric program
the Pediatric program was established in
2002. the insurers are assessed a fee
for each insured pediatric life those
funds are then aggregated and sent to
DHHS to purchase the vaccines at the
significantly discounted federally
negotiated vaccine prices
in so doing in the Pediatric program the
state purchases about 38 million dollars
of vaccines for about 28 million dollars
a savings of about 10 million or twenty
six percent
these vaccines are then distributed to
the providers free of charge to
administer to the patients
New Hampshire achieves a very high
pediatric vaccine rate with this program
the New Hampshire vaccine Association is
a non-profit corporation that was
created to actually just do the job of
assessing and collecting the funds from
the health insurers
so in drafting this bill
I use the language of a 126 Q which is
the Pediatric Statute in collaboration
in collaboration with Beth Daley the
chief of the Bureau of Infectious
Disease Control and DHHS Patrick Miller
the CEO of New Hampshire vaccine
Association and Heidi Kroll who
represents all of the insurers with ahip
this bill amends the existing statute to
cover the adults up to age 65. after
that Medicaid sorry Medicare Part D B
and D cover many vaccines and we really
can't tamper with a federal program in
terms of its funding
all of the vaccines recommended for
adults by the CDC would be covered
the CDC has already determined those
vaccines to be cost effective and
recommends them and those
recommendations were sent to you as well
in a link
covid-19 vaccines are not specifically
included in this bill
because they're not yet on the CD list
in their CDC list and they're currently
being provided at no cost by the federal
government
but at some point the federal government
will stop providing those vaccines for
free and they will likely then be on the
CDC list and they would then be covered
by this bill as well and indeed
depending on the duration of immunity
that is achieved by the current coveted
vaccines they may become routine
boosters done every year and that might
really increase the volume of adult
vaccines that we don't know
the key thing is that the recent
experience and the covet vaccine rollout
has demonstrated great demand for the
vaccine
so the New Hampshire insurance
department last year for this bill that
was when it was called
hb1655 they looked at what the uh cost
benefit analysis would be to to roll
this bill out to adults they use claims
data from 2018.
they demonstrated that the insurers paid
on claims 8.2 million dollars for
vaccine material that was a billed
amount of 13 and a half million but they
paid claims of 8.5 because nobody really
covers of course the the build rate
and they noted that the CDC contracted
prices for State vaccination programs
are on average half of that that is paid
for the same vaccines and the paid
claims data
so that demonstrates an expected cost
savings to the insurers with this
program of about four million dollars
for about eight million dollars of
vaccines
since the total administrative costs for
the adult portion of the program that's
the new portion are four hundred
thousand dollars and those are fully
covered by the assessment of the
insurers
there is no cost to the state for this
and the insurers invest four hundred
thousand dollars to realize a four
million dollar savings a ten to one
return on their investment so really not
a bad deal besides that direct Savings
of the boat purchasing at a discounted
rate the potential also exists that we
might increase vaccination rates this
would result in further savings from the
avoidance of medical costs from
complications such as hospitalizations
for flu and other diseases
now those on the committee last year
remember we passed it out of the
committee we passed it out a house but
it died a coveted death
um even though I was encouraged by some
people just to put the bill back in as
it was every bill can be made better by
continuing to work on it so I continued
to work on it in the summer in the fall
and even in the winter here
um and finally reached wording which is
acceptable to DHHS the medical society
new Futures and the insurers
unfortunately the work with the insurers
was still going on after the bill had
been signed off so I did have to provide
that Amendment which is
20210032h which I have sent to you and
that Amendment covers some changes we've
made to satisfy some concerns of theirs
so basically as far as the language a
lot of times you'll just see the phrase
and adults added because that rolls it
out there are a few things that are a
little bit different and there's one I'm
going to point out a few that are
different from last year if you turn to
page one lines 10 to 12.
so that is different than last year
the current language and statute has to
do with calculating the medical loss
ratio which is the percentage of
premiums used for health care not for
overhead but that language is superseded
by the ACA when that was pointed out
last year we just removed the language
because we felt it was really not
necessary
however given concerns about the
potential repeal of the ACA by the
Supreme Court we opted to put that
language back in with the introductory
phrase that it is in effect and less
preempted by federal law
there's another spot that we had to put
that language in and that's on page two
lines 27 to 30. again all those details
are in the written testimony I sent to
you earlier
um they're page one line 17 to 20 just
makes it really clear that the dhh costs
of administering the program are
included in the assessment to the
insurers so that the costs of DHHS are
covered fully the reason that's
important is a little bit of a kind of
sloppy wording when it was passed in
2002 for the Pediatric program said
Administration and that was interpreted
to just mean the actual administration
of a vaccine by a provider and so this
corrects that
in 2020 there were concerns raised about
the liability risk to the state for any
adverse vaccine reactions proposed by
particularly two vaccines the the
polysaccharide pneumococcal vaccine and
the disaster vaccine because they're not
including the vaccine injury
Compensation Program that covers
childhood vaccines our solution last
year was to exclude those two
now the risk of liability for the state
is really vanishingly small is they're
really only a purchasing agent they're
they're basically helping the purchase
and The Taking of adult vaccines
currently and in this program is
voluntary with informed consent obtained
given the importance of the two vaccines
particularly pneumococcal vaccine during
covid
in preventing costly hospitalization and
death we felt that our better solution
was to continue to cover all the CDC
recommended vaccines and we inserted
language removing liability from the
state that is that language is already
in statute for the New Hampshire vaccine
Association that language is on page
three lines 11 to 14. so that just
simply mirrors these the statutory
protection of nhva only for the state
on page three line 17 to 20 again
reinforced that the vaccine fund raised
from the assessment covers the
administrative costs if you turn to the
amendment again 202
10032 h
it makes the following changes on page
one line 17 another spot I just happened
to miss the word adults and adds that in
page one line 28
this is on the amendment I'm referring
to the amendment numbers here page one
line 28 of the amendment to page two
line five sets a cap on the DHHS program
costs subject to adjustment for
inflation and program volume
there was no cap before
now you may notice here that the costs
suddenly say 400 sorry 848 000 whereas
in the fiscal note it says 364.
the reason for that difference is this
represents the total DHHS costs for both
the Pediatric program and the adult
program in other words this corrects
that little bit of a glitch that didn't
allow DHHS to put its costs into the
assessment in the original pediatric
bill it shifts their administrative
costs for the Pediatric program to the
insurers who again are comfortable with
this language
it's actually a fairly small amount but
nevertheless page two on the amendment
page two lines 11 through 14 are added
to ensure transparent accounting of the
DHHS program costs
all this is publicly available
information
but uh it is buried away in various
minutes and so on in the you know I'm
sure vaccine Association and they wish
to have it quite clearly identified it's
a two-page report that is released and
on their website under their annual
report and so this would be clarified as
far as what the costs are the New
Hampshire vaccine Association already
puts in their costs but this would also
clarify the dhh costs
now there's another issue on page two
again on the amendment page two line
17-22 that just ensures protection for
the insurers that they won't be billed
by providers for a vaccine
for which they've already paid in the
assessment
and then the last thing page two line 23
set the effective date as upon its
Passage
this is to enable DHHS and nhva to start
working to set up the program which will
take time to implement
we did discuss this last year we pushed
it way out because we were thinking
about having it when the program is up
and running
but what we really need with the
effective date is allowing the work to
begin at its passage there will be a
certain sequence there's a sequence to
the assessment and and the processing of
the funds and getting it back that will
ensure that this won't really be running
for a couple of years probably but they
need the authority to move
an analogy on that is the therapeutic
cannabis law it was passed in 2013 with
the phrase upon passage it's effective
but we know that that program wasn't
really finally fully functional until
2016. so this does not imply that
immediately this is all going to be
happening it gives the authority
again if we look at the fiscal note on
the original bill it's important to
realize that 100 percent of the DHHS
administrative costs of this program are
returned to dhhs's revenue through the
vaccine fund raised by the insurance
assessment it is completely budget
neutral
all funds assessed in year preceding the
purchase of the vaccines I'm sorry as
the funds are pres are assessed in the
year preceding the purchase the assessed
funds will be available through the New
Hampshire vaccine Association to DHHS to
cover the program startup costs in uh in
the um Amendment on page two lines three
to five we gave authority or ability of
the nhva to assess the startup cost to
it to kind of add a little bit if needed
for the first year or two as the program
gets off the ground
so in summary the citizens of New
Hampshire are already realizing Savings
of about 10 million dollars in vaccine
costs per year from the Pediatric
program
if we extend it to adults that will lead
to about another four million dollars in
savings to the citizens of New Hampshire
and that's to our insurance companies
but through them with uh saving them
money that'll hopefully save us money in
our premiums and of course a much
greater number of amount of savings than
four million dollars if the in the
future the covet uh issues drive more
vaccine uptake either because of covet
itself are people having a better
awareness as to vaccines
I want to take a moment which this is
not what I sent to you before but we all
got a bunch of emails in the last 24
hours
some of them make some statements that
are simply not correct so I will just
quickly address those again this bill
adds nothing to the budget the amendment
does not increase administrative costs
and it actually
decreases the cost to the state because
it shifts some of those dhh costs to the
Pediatric program which their current
which DHHS currently has to pay shifts
that to the insurers it makes them
clearer and it caps them
there was a comment made that the
administrative costs of DHHS can just be
increased whenever they want but that's
not correct there are caps it's covered
it's um controlled
and it was also a concern that it
doesn't cover age 65 but again I do not
think that we as a state can tamper with
Federal program reimbursements that is
those vaccines uh many of them are
covered under uh Medicaid D for the
actual vaccine and the vaccines are
covered as in Part B as well this bill
does not interfere with your vaccine
choices vaccination continues to be
voluntary this just makes it cheaper
concerns about New Hampshire vaccine
Association the insurers summarized as
the best they were quite pleased with
the financial stewardship of nhva which
has actually decreased their
administrative costs over years
and there are also concerns about
oversight event vaccine inventories
there is very robust oversight that's
the major source of the administrative
costs and Dr Daley can discuss that uh
the uh there was also a concern that a
scripture rights for damages rated to
vaccines not true but only protects the
state of New Hampshire
um if you wish to sue a provider you
still have that same right and then
lastly that that's it's some kind of
thing that's going to be damaging and
can't be done three other states
successfully run such programs
so that's all I have for statements for
you I'd be glad to take questions
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman
um what is the federal program that
DHHS uses to purchase vaccines
is that the vaccines for children
program
actually I'm going to let Dr Daley go
over that because the mechanics of how
that part works is much more in her
field
okay
I have a different question
daily sent now it would probably answer
a number of questions that we could
anticipate but if not then I'll come
back to you
chair recognizes Beth Daley from DHHS
okay good morning everyone hopefully I'm
off of mute now can you hear me okay
yep
great well thank you so much
representative Pearson and members of
the committee I'm Beth Daly chief of the
Bureau of Infectious Disease Control at
the New Hampshire Department of Health
and Human Services and I'm here today to
provide information on House Bill 604 I
want to thank representative knurk for
bringing forward this bill in support of
vaccinations to protect and improve the
health of our communities you all know
the benefits of immunization it's
considered one of the greatest Public
Health achievements of the last century
and increasing access for adults
specifically is important because our
immunity from some vaccines received as
a child wanes over time and because some
adults are at increased risk for severe
infections due to chronic medical
conditions which are increasing as our
population gets older and those chronic
illnesses become more common
additionally vaccinating adults protects
the people around them who may be
especially vulnerable to infectious
diseases and can't be vaccinated
themselves such as small babies who
aren't able to get the pertussis vaccine
pertussis or whooping cough and they can
actually go on to die due to that
infection so vaccinating those adults
around a baby will help protect that
baby as well so we have some of the
highest childhood immunization rates in
our country in the country however our
adult coverage is much lower and we
continue to see vaccine preventable
diseases that result in preventable
hospitalizations in adults in I'm sorry
hospitalations and deaths in adults so
during my 16 years here at the
department we've had an adult die from
Chickenpox a newborn baby die from
whooping cough after Contracting that
illness from their unvaccinated parent
and then we recently experienced a very
large outbreak of hepatitis A which is
also a vaccine preventable disease with
over 300 cases 200 hospitalizations and
two adults who died from that very
preventable illness so just to bring
home those
public health benefits not to mention
influenza which you probably know there
are you know 50 or so adults who die
from influenza
every year in our state not to mention
all the people who die from pneumonia
which is probably due to influenza as
well
uh currently the CDC Advisory committee
on immunization practices recommends
immunization against as many as 15
different infectious diseases during
adulthood and this really depends on
your age and any special risk factors
you have we want all adults to get their
influenza vaccine every year as well as
their tetanus diphtheria and acellular
pertussis vaccine every 10 years or
sooner and then you heard about that
important pneumococcal vaccine that
representative canner talked about
so now I'm just going to switch gears to
talk about financing in terms of how we
pay for vaccines in the state we have
that Federal vaccines for children
program this provides vaccine to all
children who are on Medicaid uninsured
or underinsured or who are American
Indian or Alaskan native the way that we
purchase vaccines for the rest of the
children because that vfc eligible group
is about 40 percent the remaining 60
percent are purchased through our
partnership with the New Hampshire
vaccine Association and is paid for by
the payers
we consider our state then a universal
purchasing program for children which
means that we purchase all of the
vaccines in the state
four children off of that CDC contract
which allows us to save those funds
so this bill is creating a or proposes
to create a universal purchase program
likewise for adults under the age of 65.
there are 10 states in our country who
have those Universal purchase programs
for children and there are the three
states Alaska Rhode Island and Vermont
that have Universal purchase programs
for adults in terms of how we oversee
these programs obviously we have very
strict standards from the federal
government around operation of our
Childhood Program this includes
oversight of all of the vaccines that
are purchased through our program we
oversee the shipping and administration
of every vaccine dose that's purchased
by DHHS it's tracked in our vaccine
ordering management system and we have a
very robust quality assurance and
accountability program so any health
care provider who is receiving doses of
vaccine through this program
must sign agreements and meet very
strict requirements for accountability
of the vaccines they receive this
includes implementing the required
vaccine storage and handling practices
so that we don't have any loss of those
vaccines maintaining emergency
procedures to prevent loss of vaccine
during power failures and making sure
that there's that accountability for
every dose of vaccine we provide
training to them and technical
assistance and we also visit every
location that has our vaccines on site
at least once every two years to assure
their compliance with our program
policies and procedures
so these oversight and monitoring
activities along with the care taken by
our health care providers and handling
the vaccines has led to New Hampshire's
exceedingly low vaccine wastage rate
it's less than one percent which is well
below cdc's goal for State immunization
programs which is five percent
so with the new adult program that's
being proposed we assume that we would
have to enroll about 350 to 400
additional provider office locations
this is above and beyond the Childhood
Program and so in order to implement
that oversight of their vaccine ordering
safety and accountability we have
assumed that we'd need to hire those
four positions that have been outlined
in the fiscal room
uh so in conclusion DHHS are the
insurers Health Care Providers and the
vaccine Association have all been able
to work in Partnership to successfully
offer vaccines to all children in our
state and as a result we enjoy High
immunization rates and low rates of
vaccine preventable diseases an adult
program that's modeled after that
Childhood Program is feasible and would
offer public health benefits of
increasing access to vaccines and
decreasing infectious diseases that
would also offer the cost savings that
representative canark outlined for us
um so thank you very much for the
opportunity to testify and I'd be happy
to address any questions you have thank
you
any questions
yes
Mr chairman yes representative Merchants
oh thank you for taking Mike
but thank you for that Mr chairman and
also
Bethany for taking my question
um this is more probably in the details
in the weeds but as a pharmacist today
when we bill for the vaccine we also
bill for the administration of the
vaccine and so forth
um it's sort of dovetails together
my question to you or someone else maybe
in the insurance industry
if I don't have a vaccine to bill for am
I going to be able to bill for just the
administration of the vaccine is that
going to go to the insurance company
under the drug benefit or go to the
insurance company under the medical
benefit
so I can start by answering to say that
you can bill you in fact you do Bill
separately for the vaccine dose itself
and the administration fee so under the
Childhood Program those providers who
are administering the vaccine they do
not bill for the dose itself because we
have already purchased that for them and
the payers have provided the funding for
that they do charge the administration
fee and that will get covered by the
insurance company then or the insurer I
don't know the answer to the more
detailed billing side of that because I
don't know insurance billing
thank you I
could we have someone
um do some research because my concern
is that we get into a billing issue
where
all intent we want to
expand if you will the vaccinations for
adults which I totally support I just
don't want to have a situation where all
of a sudden the pharmacy we don't have a
billing mechanism to accommodate the
expansion of the program today we don't
deal with that with children because the
most part we don't build for children
vaccines per se because it's not really
part of our scope of practice
those we expand this to adults I think
that could be a problem
so just to reaffirm you can bill for the
administration fee I just didn't
understand the second half of your
question which maybe the insurance
department is on and can answer or an
insurer what what I understand is that
when you build for the vaccine for the
product itself at that time you also
bill for the administration of the
vaccine if we don't bill for the vaccine
itself my concern is a mechanism to
build only for the labor and not for the
product
there
but you can
and I heard representative
yes well
am I allowed to speak I'm sorry I didn't
realize I wasn't muted I was just
whispering to myself yes you are you are
allowed to to char to bill for the
administration the provider can bill for
the administration of the vaccine that's
currently there it would still be there
it's not precluded
if I may miss the chair not to get into
a discussion with um president but I
just take it offline but my concern is
that that's in the medical side I'm just
concerned a lot of things in a pharmacy
on the drug side which operates
differently than the medical side
we're about to hold this uh for the
exact session
please
representative snow wishes to speak
yes thank you Mr chairman my question is
I got emails from a couple of members of
the public who were against this bill
because they thought it was going to
require them to be vaccinated even if
they didn't want to and I could find
nothing and I don't believe that has
anything to do with this bill does it
I don't think so thank you
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman
um Dr Daly
these DHHS administrative costs does
that include is that all staff and
programs or does that also include new
costs for the state vaccination registry
so the cost for the adult program our
new staff who we need to go do that to
assist with the vaccine ordering and go
out into those provider offices and make
sure that they are following
um the all the policies and procedures
to prevent vaccine wastage
so follow-up so then none of this money
that you anticipate to be needing to
spend is going to go toward bolstering
or expanding or at all going toward the
New Hampshire immunization information
system
so remember that the immunization
information system does two things one
part of it is a registry the other part
is the vaccine ordering system so in
order to run this program we have to
have a in Information Technology
solution to order vaccines for those
provider offices so it might be possible
that we might need funding to support
the ordering aspect but it would not
support the registry component of the
system
what we have presented in the fiscal
note is the new costs that are
associated with the adult program
and we have asked the vaccine
Association to support our vaccine
ordering system
in the past but that has not been
approved because it was not allowable by
under statute
thank you any other questions for Dr
Daley
being none of the chair calls Dr J J
Smith from the New Hampshire Public
Health Association Dr Smith
let's see there we go says I can now be
unmuted great hi
um I am fully in support of this bill
SSR Association we're very happy to see
this and actually my only reason for
being here is to iterate support and we
did send a letter
um did a bunch of uh research on the
part of one of our members of our policy
committee and my main purpose is just to
be here in case anyone wants to speak to
someone who is a primary care physician
or was I I guess I am retired
um I've been doing advocacy for about
five years now
um after retirement but I have a lot of
knowledge of vaccines in both my uh
clinical capacity and as a healthcare a
public health person so I I really have
nothing more to add to all of the
wonderful stuff that Dr knurk has said
um but I do realize that despite your
having medical expertise on the
committee you don't have Primary Care
people on the committee that I know of
yeah
any questions for Dr Smith
seeing none the chair calls Holly
Stevens from computers
all right are you guys able to hear me
yes
um thank you Mr chairman
new Futures appreciates the opportunity
to testify in support of House Bill 604
relative to expanding
the New Hampshire vaccine Association to
include adult vaccines and just for the
record my name is Holly Stevens I'm the
health policy coordinator at new futures
new Futures is a non-partisan non-profit
organization that Advocates educates and
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of New Hampshire residents in
this role we work extensively with
policy makers Health Care Providers and
families to improve overall public
health and improve health Equity across
the granite state
House Bill 604 is a great step in moving
the New Hampshire's and moving New
Hampshire's Public Health needle in the
right direction
expanding the state's vaccine program to
include adults will save money while
making CDC approved vaccines available
to all adults in New Hampshire
regardless of insurance type or status
and I did just want to hit home that
point that this program will also
include individuals who are uninsured
and individuals who are underinsured
meaning they have a plan that does not
require
it to have the
the requirements of the AC ACA to
include all preventable
preventive medicine costs so anybody who
has a catastrophic plan or things like
that they would also be able to get
vaccines under this program
um as you heard representative Canucks
say that this bill if it was were to
pass would join only three other states
that have Universal vaccine programs
and also just to really Hammer this
point home while it does make these
vaccines available to all adults 18 to
64. it in no way
mandates adults to receive any
vaccination on the adult vaccine program
is entirely voluntary
I also did want to uh just point out too
that I did some research
um there's very limited research about
whether a universal vaccine program
would increase
um the uptick of individuals becoming
vaccinated but I did want to let the
committee know that in 2018 to 2019
Rhode Island which is one of the states
that has a universal vaccine program
they were number one in the country for
adults receiving flu vaccines and again
I just want to point out point out
that's a correlation it doesn't mean
that one caused the other it's just
water for For Thought
um
and although this bill wasn't it was
introduced originally in advance of
covet 19.
um because of the pandemic it was left
on the table as you know
um the covid-19 virus has not affected
all populations in our state equally
offering no-cost vaccinations to all
adults will help improve racial Health
disparities for historically
marginalized populations and will assist
in improving the Health and Wellness
of all Granite Staters now and into the
future
and also as representative connect
mentioned in his testimony
um last fall
um the New Hampshire vaccine Association
the Department of Public Health and I
just want to say thank you if if uh Dr
Daley is still on this call she actually
did provide
um I would say a significant amount of
her time given what's going on right now
in the state
um to this endeavor
um but the Department of Public Health
representative canark and new Futures
and the insurers virtually met a few
times to discuss the language of this
bill and the amendment that
representative knurk sent to you
2021-0032h was the language that all of
us were able to come together and agree
upon
um it ensures that the insurers cannot
be what they thought might be double
billing but it also ensures that
patients cannot be charged for that That
vaccine either regardless of where they
obtain it so it ensures that the
insurers can't pay for it twice but it
also there's language in there that
ensures that that cost can't be
um passed on to the patient in the way
of getting paid twice either
um it also has
administrative cost controls that were
requested by the insurers so that the
department couldn't just raise
administrative costs willy-nilly to
cover other things as they as they
wanted to and I'm not in any way saying
that they would or that they do it's
just a protection so that something like
that could not happen
um and it also
um has transparency requirements so that
um all of us can ensure that the program
is functioning the way it's designed to
which essentially is allowing adults to
obtain vaccines at no cost to them and
that the insurers are receiving a
savings as well
the expansion of the state's vaccine
program is cost neutral to the state
because the assessment collected as has
been mentioned a couple of times comes
from the insurers to cover both the
vaccines and the administrative costs of
the program
House Bill 604 as amended is a bill that
truly is a win-win for all involved
even if the expanded vaccine program in
the covid-19 pandemic experience don't
result in more adults getting vaccinated
it will still cost the insurers less
than they are currently paying now for
their covered adults who do choose to
obtain vaccines
and lastly if there's anything that the
covid-19 pandemic has taught us is the
importance of vaccines in preventing
illness and death
and so for all of those reasons new
future strongly urges the court excuse
me the general court in this committee
to vote ought to pass as amended on
House Bill 604 thank you and I would be
able to answer any questions if anybody
has any
thank you Miss Stevens any questions
yes representative gay thank you thank
you Mr chairman uh thank you for taking
my questions it's extremely simple
you've talked about you know everybody
talks about the two costs one is of the
vaccine uh
liquid itself and the other's
Administration
I heard multiple times that patients
won't pay at all for their adult
immunizations
so then who pays for the administration
the administrative cost that's the cost
of actually putting the needle into the
skin and pushing the plunger is a cost
that is billed to the insurers
now one thing that I would like to make
clear is somebody who doesn't have
insurance unless a provider is willing
to waive that cost like if somebody
walked into their local pharmacy didn't
have insurance and said I want the the
flu vaccination
um the pharmacy might say well we charge
x amount of dollars to actually push
that medicine into your skin that being
said the state already has a list of
providers that will provide vaccines
that are purchased by the state
um
and they are given to
um folks without insurance
um at no charge anyway so there are
still places that somebody without uh
insurance if the uh
if the pharmacies weren't willing to say
take that cost on themselves that they
would be able to go to another provider
and receive that vaccination for free
um which wouldn't cost them a dime not
for the administrative cost and not for
the the vaccine
any other questions representative
Cushman
so if uh
if if a patient is uninsured and if a
physician's office you know sees
uninsured patients do they have to
purchase a separate inventory that
for those uninsured patients
that isn't covered by this no I mean and
I if if Dr Daley is still on the school
and she wants to correct to me it's my
understanding that say I I do have
insurance but say I didn't and I walked
into a convenient MD
um that and I said I want the flu
vaccine that they might say to me well
the vaccine itself is going to be
offered to you at no charge it's free we
get it for free but we're going to
charge you five bucks to put the needle
in your arm
so the the
all of the entities that have the
vaccine they get it for free so they
absolutely should not be charging
anybody for That vaccine whether they
have insurance or whether they don't
have insurance
follow up
is anyone are any providers able to opt
out of this program and then the added
oversight and regulations that come with
it
I've I is can anybody tell me if they
see if Dr Daly is still on
or whether she had to hop off
she still is on okay
um I if it's okay representative if it's
okay I'd rather leave that question to
her since she's involved in the state
and the contract with the state with
these providers Dr Daley could you
answer that question for us
yes so thank you for the question and
the opportunity to answer it
the program is voluntary from the
perspective of the health care provider
they don't do not have to administer
vaccines to the patients they're going
to want to do that though and they are
already should be doing
um managing their vaccine inventory in
the way that we
um will train them and ensure that
they're actually doing can I clarify
I was trying to ask
um yes representative equipment wishes
to clarify her question my question is
can they purchase vaccines outside of
the program if they don't want to be a
part of this program but they still want
to purchase vaccines to administer to
their patients
do they have the option to do
so yes they can still purchase those
vaccines at the higher cost on the
private marker Market I'm not sure why
they uh would want to do that but they
can do that the problem is is that
they're not going to be able to Bill
insurance for it though they can build
that administration fee but they will
not be able to bill the insurance
company for the um for the cost of the
vaccine because those insurers are
already contributing into the to
purchase That vaccine at the lower cost
it's based on the number of insured
individuals they have and so they're
already paying for the vaccine and
they're not going to reimburse that
provider who chooses to buy it off the
private market for a higher cost
any other questions for Ms Stevens
saying none thank you and the chair
recognizes Tyler Brennan from the
insurance department
hello uh Tyler Brannan from the New
Hampshire Sheriff's Department I am the
director of Health economics we do not
have a position on the bill and um as
was mentioned earlier uh in in response
to legislation last year we did an
analysis of our claims data on vaccine
use in New Hampshire and the prices and
there has been background on that
already just to say a little about the
chis
um this is the New Hampshire
Comprehensive Health Information System
which is basically a claims data set of
anonymous Health Care claims that we get
from Health insurers
um it is not all of the data on all of
New Hampshire residents but it is a
really good sample so that's relevant I
think because of some of the comments
I've seen around the analysis but um but
the analysis in the report our public
information they're available on the
insurance department website I will send
a link to the report to committee
members so that you have that at your
disposal
um because we don't regulate all of the
entities we can't collect data on all of
New Hampshire residents so if somebody
is under a self-funded employer in other
words the employer retains the risk for
the actual Administration claims but a
company like Anthem is paying a health
care provider we wouldn't necessarily
see those claims data So within the
database they're in the report it is
mentioned that they're about 13.5
million in vaccine that was billed in
2018 with about 8.2 million that was
actually paid out according to this
negotiated prices the report also does
say that the CDC contracted rate would
be about half of that amount what I want
to be clear about is that 8.2 million
does not represent the vaccines for all
of New Hampshire residents within the
report there is also an analysis of
approximation of how many people we have
in the claims data versus how many
people there are in New Hampshire and
it's a about half so if you wanted to
get a kind of a better understanding of
the total amount spent on on vaccines in
New Hampshire you'd probably be going
down the road doubling those numbers
quite a bit so um some of the findings
in the report are that about half of
adults have received a vaccine almost 80
percent of the people in the 55 to 64
age group have received a vaccine by far
the most common is for the flu and
that's about 70 percent of vaccines
being administered 87 percent of the
vaccines are just for the top three so
in addition to the flu this is the
vaccine for for tetanus diphtheria and
pertussis and ninety percent of the time
the vaccine was was obtained in a
provider office or a pharmacy
uh we have reviewed the amendment and we
also agree with the very important
conclusion that our insurers do not get
assessed and billed for the vaccine so
that's our understanding of how this
would work
um representative Merchant raised the
question about billing for an
administration fee uh without actually
billing for a vaccine and our
expectation is that carriers would
continue to pay that administrative fee
they may ask a provider to do something
to to clarify that the administration is
for a vaccine that's Covenant of the
program but that's something that can be
worked out I think between the provider
and the insurer we did an analysis of
the vaccine data several years ago and
observed that many providers were
billing like one cent for the vaccine I
think just to clarify that that that was
the reason the administration was being
billed how a pharmacist would bill would
be different than I think a medical care
provider and that just has to do with
the types of coding systems and billing
forms that are used but I do believe
that the the claims processing system
between a pvm and a pharmacy does allow
for payment for vaccines and the
associate Administration so I wouldn't
Envision that being a problem either but
um but clearly the department would be
happy to to work with the parties if
issues do arise
don't have much more to say I appreciate
the chance to testify and happy to
answer any questions
any questions from Mr Brennan
that Mr chair
yes
if I could to Mr Brennan thank you
is it okay Mr chair chairman I am I
don't know who's speaking this
representative Merchant sorry
uh there you are uh yeah okay
um question to Mr Tyler Brennan um thank
you for taking my question first and
foremost
my concern is that it's assumed that
under the PBM contracts that that will
be the case I'm just concerned that if
we don't clarify that we could
potentially have an unintended
consequence where the pbms are not
playing a ball which is different than
the insurance carrier because they
really work under the insurance company
through a contract
um so going forward we have the
possibility
that patients going into Pharmacy may
not have reception because of the
financial situation
okay so your question is perhaps whether
or not we need some sort of Provider
Contracting standard for pbns
um
this may be solving a problem that
doesn't exist but I'm trying to think
what I mean the the carrier is
responsible for sort of making sure that
a patient has access to the vaccine so
if they refuse to pay a administrative
fee or something that is equivalent to
that to a PV um to a pharmacy I think
that would raise some concerns about
um about coverage but I I'd have to kind
of go back and look and think about this
a little bit more to to to be absolutely
certain that your concern would be
um fully addressed at least in existing
statute now
thank you for taking my question
any other questions for Mr Brennan
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you the chair now recognizes
Sabrina Dunlap who is with and so
hi there that took a while
um thank you Mr chair thank you members
of the committee Sabrina Dunlap director
of government relations at Anthem and
just really briefly wanted to offer our
support for the amendment and thank
representative knurk for um working with
us on this
um so happy to take any questions we
don't have much more to add thank you
and thank you what you recognizes Laura
Condon she identifies herself as a
member of the public and she wishes to
speak against the bill
can you hear me yes okay thank you
well good afternoon Sharon Pearson and
committee members my name is Laura
Condon I live in Bedford and I'm a
volunteer Advocate with the national
vaccine information center and I have
worked for a non-profit in the insurance
industry for 29 years I have served for
five years in the board of directors of
the New Hampshire vaccine Association as
a public member I was appointed by the
Senate President and I continue to be
act an active member of the public in
those meetings and I served as a member
of the audit committee while I was on
the board of directors of the vaccine
Association
I'm opposed to this bill that will
provide for DHHS and vaccine Association
taking over the purchase of adult
vaccines because it would greatly
increase the cost of vaccines by over
three million dollars Private Industry
is doing very well and a financial
analysis will demonstrate that
I wish to thank representative konark
for bringing this bill forward for
discussion of this important issue and
to finally Force an appropriate review
of the costs information and documents
that represent panerica has provided
assist in this proper review of costs
and will show a significant cost
increase under this bill
I also recognize representative Canuck's
motives to be genuine and sincere to
insist in bringing down costs of
vaccines for New Hampshire consumers
however this bill will actually do
nothing to change the cost of vaccines
to New Hampshire consumers
under the Affordable Care Act it is
required the vaccines be provided
without cost
to all covered persons there may however
be as you've heard discussed a charge
for the administrative cost injection of
the vaccine but also a cost perhaps for
the office visit with the doctor this
bill does not change those costs those
over age 65 are covered by Medicare and
this bill would have no effect on them
this bill would have no impact on the
poor without insurance and DHHS provides
as you've heard under current law many
vaccine clinics where the poor may
receive vaccines free of charge they
will not be able to and it was a
misrepresentation go into a doctor's if
you are uninsured you would not be able
to go into a pharmacy and receive this
free Supply as an uninsured person
um because the uninsured person had
nobody who paid into the purchase of
these vaccines so that's how it works
with the child program you need to be
insured to access this supply of
vaccines so that was a misstatement I
wish to clarify there
between private businesses the insurance
industry and DHHS there's currently
ample supply of adult vaccines provided
cost effectively in many locations from
your doctor's office to clinics to the
corner drug stores gosh you can even
give vaccines in a grocery store we do
not have an availability of vaccine
issue
I wish to remind all that this bill is
not about the benefit or risk of
vaccines it is not about whether or not
people should get vaccines and it's not
about mandating vaccines this bill is
squarely focused on the cost of vaccines
there are a number of concerns relative
to this bill and I did send the
committee an email yesterday afternoon
and those concerns
um include that the child vaccine
purchase program would be put at risk
currently the child vaccines are being
purchased through the the federal
contract with the vfc program that vfc
program is originated from the the
section 1928 of the Social Security Act
that provides for that Federal program
that provides vaccines for poor children
it is exclusively a pediatric vaccine
purchase program there was no authority
to use that vfc contract in that program
for the purchase of adult vaccines and
the concern is of course if there's
effort to violate that Federal contract
that the the
um the vfc program in New Hampshire
could be shut down and poor children
could be left without vaccines so I
caution us not to pass legislation that
would violate that Federal contract in
that email I did provide you with
section 128 of the Social Security Act
um the cost comparisons here are not
accurate there has been comparisons of
the CDC market price
um numbers
um which are actually manufactured
suggested retail prices that no one
actually pays Doctors Hospitals
pharmacists are purchasing all their
medical supplies and pharmaceuticals
including vaccines through
um provider discount programs group
purchase programs and they recognize
significant discounts for those programs
including rebates but actually that's
not even a relevant number here
the true cost comparison is to compare
the price that DHHS would purchase these
vaccines for through what is the
negotiated claim amount that insurance
companies are paying because this we're
talking about what insurance companies
are going to pay either what they're
paying now under the current model or
what they would pay through this vaccine
um Association so that is the cost
comparison that we we need to to make
here
and um the costs keep growing with this
you know this amendment that's been
added to this bill
um there is
um now administrative costs totaling up
to 848 000 a year plus whatever
additional cost that the DHHS which has
three seats on the board of the vaccine
Association might deem as quote unquote
reasonable and reasonable is actually
the language used in the amendment
um
and um
the the pro the the funding of dhh Staff
their vaccine registry their vaccine
ordering and inventory program should be
funded through the general fund it
should not be born in the backs of New
Hampshire health insurance consumers
will already pay some of the highest
insurance rates in the nation
this bill won't provide vaccines for
many adults and may increase costs and
limit availability
let me explain that the bill does not
will not provide vaccines if you're age
65 and older it will not provide
vaccines to the poor it will not provide
vaccines if you're uninsured your doctor
and pharmacist will still need to
purchase vaccines for that population of
adults
they are getting remember they are
getting their vaccines as a significant
discount this doesn't speak to the cost
this speaks to availability of vaccines
because they're buying in bulk if now a
a portion of the adult vaccines they
purchase are being offloaded to be
purchased through this program they will
no longer have their bulk discounts that
they currently enjoy so that would
creates a disincentive for them to
continue to stock adult vaccines for
those age 65 and older those on Medicaid
those are uninsured so it could put the
adult vaccine availability at risk
um and you know and and will they they
abandon is not a viable business if they
lose those discounts
um
this bill will be burdensome to those
vaccine providers there will be a
requirement that they may tune separate
vaccine inventories for adults those
that they get quote unquote free from
the state need to go in a separate
refrigerator and freezer from the
refrigerator and freezer they now
currently have for the inventory that
they purchase and they own
and there is no mechanism here for
controls on that multi-million dollar
inventory it appears to be on the honor
System that you know busy pharmacists or
their college intern or administers
vaccine isn't going to reach into the
free Supply and use it to administer
somebody who's not covered under this
program and I mean that's certainly
that's not a solid um or Sound business
practice and um we would certainly want
oversight over that inventory
um the the other
um
things to remember is that this um it's
not a broken system the system we have
now
um vaccines are already supplied at
um like I say you can get them at a
grocery store they're already free under
the Affordable Care Act
um consumers cannot be charged for the
cost of vaccines
um under Medicare you cannot be charged
for the cost of vaccines
um and the poor people are provided by
DHHS this bill was actually not a
request of insurance industry not a
request of DHHS and not a request of the
vaccine Association it was brought forth
um by contact the representative canark
had in the community concerns about
costs of vaccines it appeared to be
somebody over the age of 64 which of
course wouldn't cover
um the final consideration here is that
DHHS is working around the clock during
this coveted crisis and now is certainly
not the time to burden them further
we're trying to set up this new program
so let's get back to normal first before
we burden them I can walk you through
the financial analysis that shows that
this bill will increase costs three
million one hundred and thirty one
thousand 997 I did provide you with an
email late last night that had some
attachments to it
and um let me walk you through that and
remind you again this is not about the
cost that doctors and pharmacists
purchase vaccines for this is squarely
talking about the cost to health
insurers what they are paying to doctors
and pharmacists versus what they would
pay to DHHS for vaccines that is the
cause comparison so please do not be
distracted by any sort of CDC pricing
this last night we will be able to read
it we do need to move on we have several
people who need to testify and we have
as much fun coming would you take
questions
I I will take questions
does anybody wish to ask a question
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman
uh Miss Condon
um we've confirmed your position what
your position was at the New Hampshire
vaccine Association
I was a public board member there was
appointed by the Senate President I
served her five years and I was on the
audit committee there and what I brought
to that board is there were significant
deficiencies in oversight in reporting
and accountability
um policies and procedures and I push
for a good number of changes there
follow up
um so do you believe I understand that
this organization has to submit annual
reports to the president of the Senate
speaker of the house and the the
governor do you believe that those
reports that are submitted offer
sufficient disclosure of the
association's activities and their
financial reports
thank you for that question again you
know as a member of the board in the
audit committee those you know two-sided
um
brochures essentially amount to you know
a marketing brochure and we're not full
disclosure at all they did um their own
erroneous cost comparison of the vfc
price and compared to market pricing
costs which is not the comparison we
need to look at and I've long argued
that the comparison needs to be between
um what the DHHS is paying for the
vaccines compared to what the insurance
industry pays on claims that negotiated
discount because every service that
insurance companies engage in with a
provider they negotiate discounts they
negotiate discounts on you know office
visits vaccines and everything and as we
saw in the the um New Hampshire
insurance department document is they
negotiate a discount of some 40 percent
on vaccine uh claims
and and that's the information that
should be provided I think the amendment
is deficient in what it calls for for
disclosure to the legislature thank you
thank you representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair chairman uh Miss
Condon my understanding is that in the
vaccine world as far as what's free
um this goes back to the prior
Medicare what was created that would
include influenza
and also pneumococcal and one's pretty
emergency like tetanus and so forth
haven't been a practicing pharmacist I
can assure you that there's many times
in a pharmacy that patients have to pay
for a vaccine and many times the cost of
That vaccine is exorbitant even though
it's being quote paid for by the
insurance company because of the co-pays
and deductibles so that does become a
barrier to a lot of the patients getting
a vaccine so I want to be clear at least
my understanding haven't worked in the
pharmacy for a long time that not all
vaccines are free
um under the Affordable Care Act it is
required for insurance individuals that
there should not be a charge for the
vaccine there may be charges for the
administration of the vaccine subject to
deductibles and co-pays and that's for
insured individuals
you know you might be talking about
um Medicare patients Medicare
individuals Governor part b or d but
again this bill does not address that
population would have no impact on that
[Music]
thank you representative Kelsey
yes thank you Mr chairman uh Miss Condon
do you think it would be fair and even
reasonable to fund a state vaccine
registry an Associated Department of
Health and Human Services staff through
the vaccine Association
I I actually think that's tremendously
unfair
um to impose that you know burden on uh
New Hampshire Insurance consumers the
statute provides for every dollar of
this cost to be funneled through
um and included in in premiums as
Medical Loss and I think that's a
violation of the the federal Affordable
Care Act that it protects New Hampshire
consumers from excessive administrative
costs and what this does by placing on
the burden of insured individuals it it
means that the rest of those in the
state who might be using these um DHHS
Services of the vaccine registry which
include Medicare Medicaid individuals
the uninsured are not paying the burden
of that so this is very much unfairly
imposed on New Hampshire Insurance
consumers driving up our rates further
thank you for the question
anyone else from the committee who
hasn't asked a question
thank you for your testimony the chair
now recognizes Jessica
polisky who is a member of the public
we have Jessica kliskey
can you hear me
yes okay thank you Mr chairman Pearson
for taking my comment
um I second everything that Laura Condon
said but I wanted to point out a figure
for the people who in New Hampshire that
are enrolled in the Medicaid Program
which is around 45
000. that's significant for people who
won't be at um
you know this this this bill would not
be effective for and
um also because we're talking about
costs
um I think it's important to remember
that back in 2014 we spent about 1.4
million dollars on um a contract to
build an immunization registry that was
failed
um and you know we heard a lot about we
have the highest rates of vaccinations
then we need this money to spend on this
um on this bill so I I just question
um
you know if everything is
um as it seems that's pretty much all I
have Laura said everything else that I
was going to point out so thank you for
your time
thank you thank you it's from the
committee
representative gay
Mr chair uh thank you Miss Chrissy for
explaining he said something about in
2014 we spent over a million on what
then it failed
um we hired science Technologies
Corporation to build what I'm assuming
is a technology piece to an immunization
registry that was
um not completed
from what I understand so I just wonder
if we need to consider that not
everything
um
you know that we're going to have
taxpayers pay is
um necessary
thank you what else
thank you very much the chair recognizes
Andrew Hosmer
thank you very much Mr chair members of
the committee I'll be very brief here uh
again my name is Andrew Hosmer I'm
representing Harvard Pilgrim Healthcare
on New Hampshire's largest
not-for-profit Health insurer
um
we certainly support the bill as amended
and I'd second comments made by previous
proponents uh including uh Sabrina
Dunlap so we're our we are anxious to
continue working with stakeholders to
increase the number of people who
receive needed vaccines that lowers the
cost of acquiring and dispensing
vaccines and puts in place a process
that allows for transparency and
accountability so for these reasons we
are in support of Representative nurse
Amendment thank you very much thank you
when you take a question if there is one
I'll do my best
CNN thank you for your testimony Mr
thank you
you're recognizes Joanne rainville a
member of the public
hello
hi good you can hear me I'm kind of new
to zoom
um yes I am a member of the public and I
am also the on Executive Director of the
Tamworth Nurse Association
um and I was the one who went and and
got Jerry Corner's ear and said we need
help getting vaccines into people and
they shouldn't have to come with their
hat in their hand
um to be able to get a flu vaccine
and in with the Tamworth Community
nurses we don't Bill anyone so we don't
build Medicare or Medicaid or any of
those things but we really try and get
people be a conduit for people to be
able to get health care when I started a
tcna
um 20 years ago now
uh vial of vaccine was 38 dollars
it's now about 175 dollars
uh when you're not billing anybody it's
kind of hard to make up that cost and
it's too important to stop to turn our
back on people who need it we also have
to keep in mind that there are people in
New Hampshire and I'm sure in every
state that I'm not signed up for
Medicaid
or help or different Health Options that
they may have and that's for their own
personal reasons but
we want to keep those people healthy too
because they turn around if they get the
flu
then they're probably going to infect
other folks
um and then there's just the fact that
when especially frail people or people
with pre-existing conditions they don't
get the flu shot
um that you know we see an increase in
hospitalizations ER visits doctor's
office visits and we've also got with
covid people who are very reluctant to
get near any health care provider
so my thought when I first went to Jerry
was let's just remove one barrier
that stops one person from being able to
get an inoculation
and Jerry I thank you for your hard work
on this and I thank this whole committee
for letting me speak if you have any
questions I'm here
saying not the final person on my sheet
is
Heidi Kroll from America's health
insurance plans am
en
good afternoon Mr chairman are you able
to hear me yes great thank you
um yes good afternoon everyone Mr
chairman and members of the committee my
name is Heidi Kroll
um I represent
um ahip America's health insurance plans
um I work at Gallagher Callahan and
gartrell
um and I am home with my son this
afternoon so I apologize if you hear
background noise
um uh ahip um does not take any position
um or it's neutral on the underlying
question
um that all of you are facing as to
whether or not to expand the vaccine
program to adults
um but we uh certainly are supportive of
um promoting the use of vaccines to
prevent disease
um save lives and reduce unnecessary
health care costs and if the
commission's decision or this
committee's decision is to expand the
program then ahip is supportive of the
um Amendment um to House Bill 604 which
you've been discussing here
um for the past hour or so
um From ahib's perspective there are
several important aspects of the
amendment that I would just like to
quickly touch upon
um one is the capping
um the Department of Health and Human
Services administrative costs associated
with the vaccine program
um there's two aspects Happening Here
one is that carriers will be assessed
for the full cost of dhs's
administrative costs associated with the
adult program in addition
um carriers will be asked to Bear
through assessments
approximately 60 percent of hhs's
administrative costs associated with the
childhood vaccine so both of those costs
coming from hhs's administration of
programs would be new in terms of being
uh part of the assessment on carriers so
um we were concerned uh to make sure
that
um there's kind of a checks and balances
on the administrative costs so that we
don't erode these savings
um from purchasing vaccines through the
program
okay
um the second uh piece that's important
to us um with this is the enhanced
annual reporting on program cost and
savings
um having listened to the discussion
this morning there's perhaps more that
can be done
um to further enhance that but Our
intention at least was to increase the
transparency
um and accountability
um in terms of making sure that the
public and legislators have uh easy and
ready access to
um good information about the the cost
and the savings
um and the final piece um that was
important to us and and I should say
that um uh representative Corner
um and other stakeholders really spent a
lot of time
um talking with the carriers talking
with me
um and just a lot of stakeholder
dialogue uh over many many many weeks
and we're very appreciative for that
process so I neglected to say that in
the beginning but um I wanted to mention
that um it was a very good process uh so
in the third piece that was important to
us
um and uh we think has made an
improvement to the bill uh with the
amendment is simply clarifying the
duties of the accessible entities namely
the carriers
um and there's been some discussion
about that but uh carriers um are
committed um to
um paying for the administration of the
vaccine namely paying providers to um
Put the Needle in somebody's arm and
administer the vaccine
um but because we are or would be paying
for this this vaccine through the
assessment we were concerned about being
double billed if you will and so the
language and the amendment I think
alleviates that concern
um and it should also help ensure that
uh you know the savings are maximized
for the benefit of New Hampshire
citizens
um so with that I'd be happy to answer
any questions or if I'm not able to I
can take them back and and respond later
but I appreciate your time this
afternoon thank you very much
any questions for Ms Cole
representative gay
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question how do we get the
actual cost of the vaccine since it's
been pointed out to us that the
comparison of the new purchase price is
this if we pass the Bill if we get that
price and compare it to what is
currently being paid
is not the retail what is the wheel
so that we can see the real cost savings
I'm I'm not the best data person to to
ask your question of um my you know my
understanding is um I have seen the um
report that the insurance department
prepared I believe it was last January
um when when the uh last year's version
of this bill was being considered and so
you know I my understanding is that in
that report it sets forth um information
about what the carriers were billed by
providers for the cost of the vaccine
the actual product
um and that what and then what carriers
actually reimbursed exactly that and
that report also includes
um some estimates or averages of what
um the CDC price
would have been had we paid a CDC price
instead of a carrier reimbursement
um that that's the data that I'm Avail
that I'm aware of
um but I and I uh I can't
speak to some of the other data that's
been discussed here this morning I
apologize it's just not my area of
expertise
foreign
thank you thank you for your testimony
uh we have one more
and that is Patrick Miller Mr Miller if
you would care to
um give us your testimony please
good afternoon chairman uh can you hear
me okay yes I can thank you thank you so
much
um for the record my name is Patrick
Miller I'm the executive director for
the New Hampshire vaccine Association
um as mentioned earlier we are created
by Statute in 2002 to manage the
childhood vaccine program we don't set
any vaccine policy or create vaccine
laws but we do collect the assessments
um and and place those assessments on
the carriers and then provide that
funding uh to the State's Department of
Health and Human Services to purchase
the vaccines
um while the New Hampshire vaccine
Association cannot take a position for
or against the bill
um the vaccine Association has worked
closely with representative knurk the
insurers and other stakeholders have
been on this call regarding the Bill's
language revisions our goal is to just
be ready to implement the program
changes and ensure that the department
receives the necessary funds to support
the universal vaccine purchasing program
I think in terms of uh representative
Gay's questions around the costs um
there are there is publicly available
data that I can provide to you that we
receive from the Department that shows
the uh essentially the purchase price
that the department is paying today uh
compared with the retail price
um so that that data is currently
available and can certainly provide that
um and
um I would say also in terms of the
public reporting piece we have
um work to try to increase what would be
reported publicly in terms of the
amendment to the bill and certainly
would be willing to work with the
committee or others to uh to continue
those discussions and to make sure that
there's full transparency we do operate
under the state's right to no laws and
all of our information is uh is publicly
available on our website so if you have
any further questions I'm just here
today to be able to answer them around
the mechanics of the Hampshire vaccine
Association and the work that we do on a
daily basis so thank you for your time
this morning for this afternoon at this
point
yes representative McMahon thank you Mr
Miller yes I will assume that you heard
the testimony of a former member of your
organization is founded
yes and she stated that they clocked
zero to three million dollars based on
the database that she provided all of us
is that factual or made up
um I I think it differs from the uh cost
estimates that the insurance department
and the Department of Health and Human
Services
um have already provided testimony on
[Music]
I get the benefit of your
guidance Mr Miller is that the testimony
provided by this Condon should not be
taken as factual and based on reality
could you perhaps clarify that question
I'm not sure that I well yeah exactly
what you're asking Mr chairman yes go
ahead I answered the question
specifically as to a um the basis of
being a State Rep deciding policy for
every citizen in our in our state and
that will be here in testimony is in
fact the truth
to do
under understood I guess what I can
certainly report about the program is
based upon again the the data that's
been provided through the insurance
department the health department
um it's believed that um what's a fact
that vaccines will be able to be
purchased um for a lower cost it will
increase access
um and um you know ultimately should
allow uh theoretically insurance
premiums to be decreased at some level
given the fact that the insurers are
receiving you know discount on the
vaccine so uh from from my perspective
I'm working with the data that's been
provided to us by the two uh departments
and um and that's really what we use for
our Actuarial models that sets the rate
every year we also I think just in terms
of our board composition it's important
to point out that we do have
representatives from the insurance
industry that that sit on that board and
provide oversight but we also have
oversight board members that are from
the government from Health Care
Providers and public members as well
self-insured entities so their their
focus as I mentioned a few minutes ago
is is not to set the policy but it's
really to uh to make sure that we raise
the funds from the insurance carriers
that were required to raise by the
statute to make sure the department uh
can meet their obligations in terms of
vaccine funding
thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question thank you
um so I just want to know Natalie
allowed direct Primary Care in New
Hampshire how is this going to affect
those Physicians who want to who
participate in that model of providing
health care doesn't this disenfranchise
them if this is passed from then
um providing vaccinations because they
can't for they can only purchase it
through the state
and they can only
they can only do it if they're going
through insurance
so I think um if Dr Daley's still on
this might be a better question for her
but my understanding again what she said
earlier too is that it's it's voluntary
on the part of the provider to
participate um in the program so if they
wish to continue to
um you know purchase outside
um they could do that but they wouldn't
be able to be reimbursed for it as my
understanding
thank you thank you any other questions
yes
thank you thank you Mr chairman I'll ask
you the same question about the cost
because it seems like the whole point is
to save money so that depends on cutting
the cost of the vaccines and that that's
making them available to people who
don't have insurance
I wanted to see how to get the cost that
we pay now
as compared to the cost they are being
promised
uh if we get the get it from the CDC so
I don't want the comparison of the price
we pay now to retail I'd like the price
we pay now compared to what we
anticipate uh to be cheaper
uh this is Patrick Miller I'll attempt
to answer that
um so in terms of the the pricing
um again the there is the the difference
between the CDC price
um and and the retail price
um and the providers uh would
essentially uh
would not be billing you know as they do
today for the the vaccine itself they'd
only be billing for the administrative
um costs for those vaccines
good
you're talking apples and oranges here
I'm trying to find out the actual cost
of the vaccines that we pay now
not the retail compared to the
anticipated cost savings if we go
through
this program if we create this program
to buy through the CDC retail right so
that that's provided that's provided in
table five of the insurance Department's
report
um where they basically compare buy the
different types of vaccines what the
average pay per vaccine is because each
insurance carrier and PBM will have a
different different contract uh
relationship with their provider
networks
um and then it also compares the the
private sector and then the CDC so that
table shows that essentially for all the
different vaccines that are listed
um the savings if you will between
what's currently being paid and then
what would be paid
I believe I believe that's the table
that would answer your question
representative
representative Folsom
um I think what we're looking for is how
can we get that form
see that information in print do you
have it available to send to us
um may I may I speak Mr chair for a
moment I sent that out in the packet
the report of the New Hampshire
insurance department was sent to you in
the email by me
so that you have that so if you look in
your email from me that was one of the
documents I sent
and the comparison was not between the
retail price and the CDC price it was
between the price that was paid on
claims that's the negotiated price and
the CDC price uh so the what Patrick
Miller is referring to you have that
available to you
thank you
not at all
any other questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
for your time
um
I'm going to give us about a 10 minute
recess
but before I do
a couple of announcements
number one representative Acton when you
write the blurb on HB 378 which we
executed last week
yes I will send me a copy and one to the
clerk thank you on the bill 187
representative Marsh is writing
uh positive blurb two people
voted against 187 would one of them wish
to write The Minority Report or
something to say thanks off
and forget the other person who told us
no
it was me
representative Shapiro
um I was extremely ambivalent about my
vote and I would certainly defer to
representative McKay
it's not necessary to have a negative or
a Minority Report
um I just wanted to give you both the
option he declines and you don't have to
but if you wish to you May
I will decline as well
thank you
tomorrow
we will meet
tucked in snug in everyone's home
we will be going all virtual tomorrow
because waiting for cheers
February 16th
we will meet we have to inject some
bills uh because they're early bills
and it looks like but it's not a hundred
percent confirmed
Aaron Goulet was chief of staff and
speaker has suggested that date and I'm
asking Christina if that could be
confirmed by the fourth floor so we'll
know
another announcement uh that February 16
sir February 16 which is Tuesday the
place is closed on 15 for President's
Day so it would be Tuesday the 16th
time
yes
a partisan thing there will be a
republican Zoom Caucus meeting at 7 pm
representative Acton please send it out
um I would ask the ranking member if she
had an announcement for her people
are we talking about with respect to the
um not not for this week no and and
um
if if you're asking me about the 16th we
don't know yet
we do not know about the 16th yet
I was making an announcement for uh for
Republicans to meet tonight at seven on
the zone and I'm giving you the
opportunity if you wish to speak to your
fellow Democrats
I appreciate the opportunity but I tend
to just email my fellow Democrats about
those issues and um but I thank you for
the opportunity anytime please request
to be happy to I will do that thank you
and uh it is okay if you promise not to
spill to eat at your place and now I
will give us about seven minutes
stretch and do whatever and we will
resume with this same bill after about
seven minutes around
is
I mean
foreign
[Music]
how was your day
thank you
I'm trying to make sure Hey Joe Shapiro
are you in the room now
Joe are you there
um
and Ken remember that this is going out
to everybody over the airwaves right
all right
we've got to behave
are you asking for me
are you saying your identities on the
floor was somebody talking to me
no was
there you go the commission on on opioid
deaths you're going to try to go to that
today
um I am going to try although we only
have an hour until five o'clock I know
I was gonna call the office and see
which is more critical I would say the
caucus is but anyway so I agree with you
I'm gonna go for a little while anyway
okay representative snow remember that
we may be voting at any time here
I know
this is the first meeting of this
commission that we reported to last
August so we at least we I even if we're
late well if you're glad we make an
appearance I guess that's okay
I'm only going to go if this ends oh
yeah that's the same thing here I agree
all right
we're not going to be voting today
anymore
so if somebody has to leave
I want you to know that we will not be
voting because we're quite a bit behind
and representative Solway is texting me
every 15 minutes he wants me to leave
because he wants me to be saved I
appreciate that so with that in mind we
are now back on House Bill 604
chair recognizes Joan
and I would say to anybody who's going
to be speaking from now on we've heard a
lot of testimony all the questions
have been asked it could be all the
information that could be has been and
so each speaker on the rest of this bill
will get one minute
I have instructed the technical people
to shut off mites at one minute so
tell us what you wish to tell us we want
everybody to have a chance to have a say
but we're running quite behind so the
chair recognizes Jones
Miss Pedro has dropped off the line
this channel recognizes Nicole nordlands
I don't know if you can hear me
you can
hello yes we can hear you great as an
elected uh but thank you for hearing me
as an elected budget Committee Member in
my town we paid close attention to
health insurance increases
um I oppose this bill because as
mentioned the costs and increases of
administrative costs are borne by the
insured and it is not my understanding
that a health insurance company is
willing to give up that Revenue without
trying to find recourse thus resulting
in increase of health insurance rates
for all of us so therefore I oppose this
Bill thank you for allowing me to speak
you said everything that needed to be
said
characters so you're my doctor child
thank you thank you
anyone else
that I will close the hearing on 604 we
it is it is an early bill
and February 16th
that's transitive but it sounds pretty
good it's a Tuesday
the bills that are early have to be done
by the 18th and we will take it off and
believe that
that's
Bill 103 establishing a dental benefit
under the State Medicaid Program
and
that's
who is presenting that bill well I find
it in my number
representative Shapiro
would you please present your bill thank
you
thank you
thank you Mr chairman colleagues and
members of the public
for the record I am Joe Shapiro Cheshire
16 Keen
I come before you today to introduce
House Bill 103 a bill that establishes a
dental benefit for adult Medicaid
recipients
in order to explain the specific need
for HB 103 and what it entails it will
be necessary to give you a little
history
before I do however let me be clear
about the issue before us while dental
coverage for children on Medicaid is
guaranteed under federal law coverage
for adults is a state prerogative in New
Hampshire a low-income adult recipients
receive no meaningful benefits that
means when they have a toothache and the
pain becomes unbearable they have no
option except to go to their local
emergency room where they may be offered
pain medication
antibiotics or frequently extraction
there is no treatment no help for the
root cause of their problem
I am well I am well aware that many of
you here today have been involved in
this campaign for access to oral health
care for a long time far longer than
myself so I will attempt to be brief
recognizing poor oral health is a
serious Public Health concern the
legislature enacted a commission to
study Pathways to oral health care in
New Hampshire
in November 2015 the commission chaired
by Senator Jeb Bradley issued its report
noting the link between oral health and
overall health the considerable and the
considerable challenges to Access Dental
Services for low-income people
especially those in sparsely populated
regions of the state
it recommended the establishment of a
comprehensive adult Medicaid benefit
in 2019
House Bill 692 established an adult
Medicaid benefit
it was passed and signed into law
eventually it was rolled into house bill
eventually rolled into house bill 4 it
created the adult Dental benefit working
group within the Department of Health
and Human Services
under the leadership of Dr Sarah Finney
that group has been meeting to determine
appropriate levels of care
or the actual benefits to be covered
delivery models and very importantly
cost estimates for implementing such a
program
meanwhile another house bill was passed
last year which would have provided the
framework and timetable for the actual
implementation of dental benefits
unfortunately Governor sununo vetoed
that bill in his veto message he cited
immediate concerns about covid related
budget shortfalls but affirms his
General support for a dental plan in
fact the morning after this past
election responding to a reporter's
question about the possibility for
bipartisans
bipartisanship in the next biennium the
governor said he was confident that
Republicans and Democrats could work
together to create a dental benefit
so that brings us back to hb103
HB 103 is a road map to implementation
it will take the excellent work done by
the HHS working group and said clear
guide posts going forward forward with
specific dates
the day to put out rfps from managed
care companies a day to apply for
waivers from centers for Medicare and
Medicaid services and most significantly
a day to actually Implement coverage
it also outlines what benefits will be
included
preventive and restorative Services
treatment necessary to relieve pain and
prevent imminent tooth loss and then
Dentures when necessary
there are countless reasons to establish
an adult Dental benefit the correlation
with other serious and costly medical
conditions
long-term savings related to appropriate
treatment rather than repetitive
emergency room visits and the
disproportionate impact on oral health
for those with developmental
disabilities and mental illness are just
a few of those reasons
I will leave these I will leave these
issues as well as the specific
complexities of rolling out such a
program to others who are here to speak
and are more knowledgeable than I
why you might ask if so much progress
has been made a bill has been passed
establishing a benefit a DHHS working
group is doing its job
DHHS has put in a priority need request
for funding for the next budget the
governor appears to favor this new
program why you may ask is the bill even
necessary the answer is simple
the progress made is real but it is also
erratic and unpredictable the reality is
that after all these years as we sit
here today there are no dental benefits
for adult Medicaid recipients instead
people are maxing out credit cards to
get a root canal or living with chronic
pain
or having their teeth extracted one by
one
passing hb103 will ensure that within a
reasonable time frame a program will be
established and our neighbors will be
able to have the care that they need and
the dignity that they deserve
thank you and I am willing to take
questions
the representative Morgan
thank you Mr chairman this this is not a
question but uh representative Shapiro
has been a considerable amount of time
talking about costs and funding I would
like to make a motion that we have a
fiscal note prepared for this bill
pursuant to RSA 14465a
representative Joe you're okay with that
I I am completely okay with that I think
it's necessary I do have a procedural
question which is that I have
um an amendment
that moves the date of implementation
which I think would have an effect on
the financial note because it moves it
further out and the
inflated Medicaid population should go
down as covid recedes so
my procedural question is is it possible
to introduce the amendment before we
send it for a financial note
representative Weber would you help me
here please I would Mr chairman my
understanding is that they will not
prepare a fiscal note
um well no actually because the
committee is requesting it I think that
perhaps the thing to do is for the
committee to vote to request a fiscal
note and for the chairman when he is
requesting it on behalf of the committee
to let them know that a different date
is proposed because
um normally they only prepare fiscal
notes on uh something that's actually
passed
the committee and I think
at least passed the committee and may be
adopted by the house after the initial
one so
I think I think I think if we just vote
for one and and
if you
um let them know that there are two
different dates that are being
contemplated that would be helpful
uh I would like the representative
Shapiro a copy of your Amendment email
to me so that when I ask for a fiscal
note it will be on that basis
Mr chairman I've already emailed it out
to everybody but I'll email a copy
directly to you thank you very much
um representative Weber we need a roll
call to do this yes you need a roll call
to do everything these days
and and and I'm seeing several hands
sort of waving I'm not sure if it's in
relation to this or something else is
your representative
I have a question for representative
Shapiro
is that in order Mr chairman why not
um
representative Shapiro um thank you so
much for uh a thoroughly competent
presentation of the bill
um and this is a follow-up to the
request for a fiscal note representative
Shapiro in order to do an intelligent
fiscal note it's necessary to have the
data we have to know uh if we're going
to calculate the impact of this program
how many people are out there who will
likely to need these Services what the
cost of the services are so has Dr
Finney
who runs Medicaid's Dental Services
Program
prepared for you
the data describing the number of
emergency visits by adult Medicaid
recipients for dental treatment do has
that department ever given us the data
that we need to do the calculations
I can I can partially answer your
question representative sellaway which
is that
um the working group has done a
tremendous amount of work and they have
done all kinds of Actuarial studies
related to different
different tiers of benefits and how much
it will cost and my hope is that um Dr
Finney is on this call and she will be
able to answer with more of the
specifics
thank you
um yes Dr Sullivan representative Solway
with that in your opinion that data that
she might provide would that make the
asks for fiscal note more accurate
unequivocally Mr chairman
representative Solomon representative
Shapiro
um
during if we could
approach the request for fiscal drones
but with not only your Amendment but
with data supplied by Dr Finney in other
words let's if we're going to get a
fiscal milk it should be as accurate as
possible
could that happen could the two of you
speak with each other and so when you
send me some things to ask for the
fiscal note
um it'll be that accurate
I if if Dr Finney is not actually on
this call and and and does not answer
that question for herself I will contact
her
I mean like she just popped up
but I would also just like to take this
opportunity to say that
there are
I have tremendous up optimism that this
benefit will come into being
and um but there are an awful lot of
moving parts so this fiscal note is one
moving part
um another moving part is that there's a
parallel bill in the Senate
um and discussions and um and
negotiations there about that bill
um so
we'll have to take this one step at a
time with each of these bills and um
make decisions based on what's going to
result in the best possible benefit in
the long run
this is not an early bill
so we could bat it around for a little
bit and
then deferent
the further post you know defer the rest
of the hearing perhaps until after we
see conversations between I would guess
that there's a Senate bill on this
Senator Bradley and the governor
um is that amenable to you how would you
like us to proceed
yes I think there are negotiations
between several of the Senators Senator
Rosenwald and Senator Bradley and I
think that we um
it would be wise to not be in a hurry
with ex with making a decision about
this bill
well then since I cannot start the next
hearing until two o'clock we have about
a half an hour to get ourselves more and
more to speed on the necessity for this
and that's I think how I'd like to
foresee
uh the chair recognizes Sarah Penny
excuse me Mr chairman you still haven't
taken the vote on the fiscal note
[Music]
bye
and that was uh representative McKay
seconded and the chairman uh the court
may call them
I like that promotions
votes yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson
please get my vote because I was not
here for the rest of the discussion
not voting okay uh representative Acton
yes
representative gay yes representative
Cushman yes representative Folsom yes
representative Kelsey yes
representative King yes representative
yes
representative Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative snow
Representatives yes
representative nurse yes representative
Solway yes representative Cannon yes
representative Netter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes representative
Merchant
yes representative Pearson yes
ready requests officially a fiscal notes
and representative Shapiro with Sarah
Finney you can provide as best of
information you can for them to produce
a fiscal note thank you chairman Mr
chairman before you recognize the next
person
I just have one other suggestion
representative Weber
yes yes um
it when we are all gathered together if
one is in the room when the question is
put one must vote
and because we are not together it seems
to me that if one is
um
if if one is present to say I don't want
to vote on this
one was sort of present so if one
is not present for voting I think the
thing to do would be to simply not
answer the clerk has been very clear
about calling each person's name twice
so if if you were not there when the
question was put the thing to do is
simply not respond and we don't get into
the question of at what point did one
come back into the discussion the mouse
will be willing to vote please
uh I'm not questioning representative
Nelson's presence or absence I'm just
saying for future for future reference
um if if he says he wasn't there he
wasn't there
I thought it would be best that I did
not vote In fairness to the sponsor of
the bill
your vote will not
sufficiently impact the outcome so if
you would like to vote fine and if not I
didn't see you in the room at the time
the question is called
I will not vote
thank you representative Weber
um I'd like to recognize Sarah Finney
please
um good afternoon Mr chairman thank you
very much for this opportunity to speak
to this committee I will certainly do
whatever is necessary to create a
completely informative fiscal note
worksheet for this bill I agree with you
all I think that it is very important
that there is a clear understanding of
the cost estimate for the benefit what
the benefit will cover
where there can be savings
um in in other parts of Medicaid where
we're spending money now such as
representative saloway mentioned with
emergency department costs
um so I I look forward to working with
you and providing the information that
you need so that you can make an
informed decision about how to move
forward with this bill
and I don't know if you have any
additional specific questions
representative Mckay please
tell us if she is and what her position
would you please introduce yourself uh
Miss Penny as to who you are your
position
I'm sorry I I apologize for not doing
that my name is Dr Sarah Finney I'm a
dentist with over 30 years of clinical
experience I've been with the Department
as a Medicaid dental director for six
years now and
um I have been leading the work group
along with Henry lippman for about 16
months now and that work group has done
significant work towards defining what
the adult Dental benefit would look like
Matthew thank you
um you were signed up to testify before
we looked at the possibility of you
working with representative Shapiro
would you present the testimony you were
going to give us in favor of this bill
um the department
supports this bill we would like to see
there be an adult Dental benefit in
Medicaid for all of the reasons that
have been spoken about we realize that
oral health is integral to overall
health there are many areas that we are
spending money on other things that are
not addressing the root cause of the
dental disease and we're trying to put a
Band-Aid on those folks who have some
serious issues
um
I was going to mention that we did have
hb4 signed into law and that the working
group had been in process like I said
for 16 months now
and
um
I just think that it is time to try to
move this forward what we have to keep
in mind though is that there needs to be
an appropriation
because we need to know that the benefit
is going to be funded So currently the
Medicaid director Henry lippman has
included a priority need request for the
state fiscal year 22-23 budget that
would include the cost of providing this
benefit according to a cost estimate
that was
um was formulated in August of 2020.
any questions
I recognized
representative Morris
uh thank you Mr chair uh and thank you
for taking my question Dr feiny
um uh actually maybe we'll answer two
questions for me uh the first is
um given the significant increase in
potential patients is it going to be
sufficient Manpower uh to uh accept
these new patients I know and in the
medical community there are Physicians
who don't take Medicaid Medicaid
um and
um I used to cover Orthopedics for the
state hospital and to get dental
coverage there was quite difficult
um do you have a sense of Manpower uh
with this expanded patient load
I think that there is uh there is the
potential for an adequate provider
Network one of the members of the
working group is the New Hampshire
Dental Society so they have been working
alongside everyone else in the work
group and we have discussed at Great
Lengths what an adequate Network would
look like and what we need to look for
in the design of this plan but I do feel
that there are enough dentists in New
Hampshire that we could have an adequate
Network
uh
uh well I have another question I'll
wait for other people to uh ask first
representative snow
thank you Mr chairman I don't know if
this is directed to representative
Shapiro or Dr Finney but I think in
addition to all the health benefits that
we see I would hope they would agree
that the increased employability of
Medicaid patients once they have
received dental benefits is is a very
significant factor in passing this bill
toothless waitresses and Toothless sales
clerks Etc have a very hard time finding
jobs and having that kind of care would
certainly increase their employability
and have an impact thank you
any additional questions for the doctor
um Mr chair could I ask another question
Senate divorce is recognized well thank
you Mr chair and uh thank you again Dr
Finney
um on page two uh on line 23
um it is part of the outlining what
services would be included in including
smoking sensation cessation counseling
uh at least in the medical community and
I think for this Committee in the past
counseling uh has had a a fairly
significant uh and well-described uh
definition
um is that is that word the appropriate
word we need there counseling would mean
the dentist would then take them under
consideration in terms of their medical
condition the availability of
medications that could would be applied
um all of the things that we think of of
counseling in a physician's office
relative to a particular medical entity
is this the word we want here
um I think that this is a good starting
point
um what would actually happen is during
the process of having an RFI go out
prior to an RFP we would be asking some
specific questions about how certain
care would be delivered and there would
we would get more definition under what
smoking cessation would include besides
counseling and then that would move
forward into the RFP
did that answer your question
um partially we'll we'll watch it as it
goes along I have some concerns about
the use of that termite I understand
that the dentist should be saying uh you
you should be stopping your smoking but
rather than that individual counseling
my surmise would be uh you should you
should be in touch with your family
doctor or someone like that for uh the
best way to do that
I agree and I think that what we one of
the other
um one of the other things that we are
looking for after much discussion with
the work group is making sure that we
have integration of the medical plan
side with the dental plan and this is a
perfect area where the the two need to
work together to treat the patient
appropriately
I completely agree thank you
you're welcome
representative gay
thank you Mr chairman
um I guess I'm a little bit I'm new with
this committee
and I am surprised that everybody knows
smoking's bad for you so I don't think
there's any anybody would say there was
a problem with trying to get people to
stop smoking but in this issue I would
expect the
people who treat
people who treat people for heart
disease would be even more interested in
getting people to stop smoking it just
seems like adding something to the
Christmas tree at this point especially
when we need to get it paid for to add
counseling on top of dental care seems
like it's just adding one more cost it
doesn't need to be right here
so somewhere there's a question in there
how did y'all decide that smoking
cessation counseling or however you
treat smoking trying to get people to
stop how did you figure it really needs
to be in Dental
um I I would say that the reason that
it's very important to be in Dental is
that when you visit a dentist part of
the examination that we do is an oral
cancer exam a screening exam and so if
your patients are smokers they are going
to be at higher risk of oral cancer and
it absolutely fits into what we should
be doing as part of our care for our
patients
yeah
representative Folsom thank you chair
um thank you for being here and
answering all of our questions
um my question for you is will this
include implants
dental implants not at the last cost
estimate did not include implants
any further questions
saying none thank you for your testimony
representative snow has his hand up my
apologies
representative
yes no I I I had it up for the last
question I asked and I'm no longer
have no other questions
thank you
then thank you for your testimony the
chair recognizes Henry liverman from
DHHS
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee I think Sarah's done a
a nice job and answering a lot of the
questions about this we have worked with
actuaries to develop
um several estimates and the most recent
one being in August of 2020
um part of the estimate addressing
representative Woods question about
provider network adequacy was an
assumption that they would need to be a
rate adjustment over current Medicaid
levels to get the level of dental
participation and that's built into our
our cost estimate and I believe with
respect to the smoking cessation that
smoking cessation is part of the overall
Medicaid benefit so I'm not sure it
represents an increase in in cost per se
but we can come back with that
specifically to address that question
um I think the other issue that I would
like to raise is sort of one of timing I
think representative Shapiro in
introducing the legislation talked about
the enrollment
um you know enrollment
um before the public health emergency
was in the Medicaid Program was a
17 576
000 individuals including about 90 000
children
um today we're probably around 214
000 individuals enrolled in Medicaid the
largest group that has grown is the um
expansion the granite Advantage program
and I'm not sure whether with all the
other budget challenges in terms of we
would need to wait for the public health
emergency I think to really
realistically
um
Finance this we have not prepared our
cost estimates to this point including
that we would do it at the peak of the
public health emergency
thank you would you take questions
absolutely thank you
Mr chairman
yes
if I may yes representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman thank you Miss
lippen
um
with
Medicaid there's a cost sharing with
federal government
right is it applied to dental benefits
as well as to medical and Drug benefits
as well
yes it does um the assumption is for
standard Medicaid Program the cost
sharing would be 50 and for the
expansion granted Advantage Program it
would be 90 Federal
Mr chairman a follow-up
when the fiscal analysis is performed
will that also be noted in the physical
analysis for us yes it it will be and we
have been running it on that basis all
along
thank you
any further questions for Mr lookman see
where I'm sitting I I really barely
cannot see folks so what I've been
having is people have been texting me uh
telling me whose hand is up and I
appreciate that when the person doing
that is quite busy doing something else
I don't always see you so it's it's not
out of order for you to ask as
representative Merchant just said
anyone else
thanks
uh the representative from Salem is
recognized for is she quotes it one
little bitty question
thank you could you repeat the number
the cost sharing was it 50 50. all of a
sudden I heard a 90 and a 10 somewhere
so what's the real number so there are
two cost sharing
um
situations there's one for people who
obtain their eligibility adults say for
example someone who has a disability is
in the standard Medicaid Program the
federal participation is 50 and the
state participation is 50 percent
um in the Medicaid expansion or
otherwise known as the granted Advantage
Health Care Program in New Hampshire the
federal participation would be 90
percent and the non-federal share would
be 10 percent
thank you
welcome
thanks for the question
I recognizes an alumna
of this great committee quality Champion
RN
welcome back
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee it's so good to see you
all again for the records it's there are
new members of this committee hello
representative I'm getting a lot of
waves which is which is fun to see my
name is Polly Campion and I was a recent
member of this estimable committee it's
a pleasure to see everybody today
however I am speaking as a public
citizen from the town of Etna and I'd
like to very briefly share my support of
this bill
as you've heard HB 103 is based on last
year's Bill and a history that
representative Shapiro discussed
that HB 250 that was passed in both the
house and the Senate and came out of
your committee actually unanimously with
a vote of ought to pass
Governor sununu then vetoed the bill
based on anticipated State revenues and
there's been much discussion about that
to date while he did support the
addition of an adult benefit to the
state's Medicaid Program
what I'd like to share is my perspective
as a recent member of the HHS oversight
committee
and I think the last committee meeting I
attended was in possibly November or
December I can't remember frankly at
this point
but as a member of that committee I had
the opportunity to hear regular updates
from the working group that has been
discussed today and the working group
shared with us the fleshing out of
specifics of the cost of the number of
potential beneficiaries of a range of
potential sets of benefits and
um Dr Sarah Finney with Mr lippman and
other members of the committee did a
wonderful job
um engaging in an Earnest effort to
understand
what might be the best pathway forward
to cover the Necessities while making
the benefit more affordable to the state
and as you've heard there are potential
amendments coming forward that may
address extending the timeline and
potentially describing more explicitly
what the covered benefits would be
others have spoken about the need to
provide Dental Care to New Hampshire's
most vulnerable adults the covid-19
emergency has resulted in a greater need
as more low-income wage earners have
lost their jobs and therefore potential
health benefits
a growing body of evidence exists in an
association of poor oral health and
chronic health conditions poor dental
health and unemployment poor oral health
and the use of emergency departments for
treatment of dental trauma pain and
infection
medical cost offsets are anticipated as
has been mentioned as a result of
implementation of a dental benefit to
those that previously may have accessed
emergency care only
thank you for the opportunity to share
this perspective and thank you
explicitly to Dr Finney for all of the
work that she has LED and to
representative Shapiro for introducing
this bill to help move this critical
benefit forward
so I asked the committee to vote to move
the um this bill forward as Amendment as
amended if that makes sense and thank
you for your time and attention
thank you and again welcome back any
questions
thank you
thank you very much
thank you did you recognizes Michael
Arabic
from the New Hampshire Dental Society
just want to make sure you can hear me
yes
thank you Mr chair and thank you through
you to the members uh for the record my
name is Michael Auerbach I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Dental Society I I'm here today in favor
of hb103
the New Hampshire Dental Society is a
Statewide organization representing over
1100 members of the dental profession
including dentists dental hygienists
dental assistants and dental practice
managers our mission is to advocate for
the practice of dentistry and the
advancement of the oral health of the
public and these two items are not
mutually exclusive
for many years the nhds has consistently
advocated to create an adult Dental
Medicaid benefit
the first most important step was the
passage of HB 692 and its subsequent
iteration hb4 in 2019. of course that
bill lacks specific details about what
form such a benefit would take in New
Hampshire instead creating the hb4
working group which is comprise a
committed oral health stakeholders
including the nhds and Dr Finney we have
since been working diligently with the
with the group to give greater structure
and scope to this developing benefit
we all know that provider participation
in the state's Children's Medicaid
Program is very low when surveyed in the
fall of 2019 our membership identified
reimbursement the lack of care
coordination and navigation especially
with vulnerable populations and
increasing administrative burden as the
greatest impediments to participation
this bill represents a great first step
an opportunity to implement vital
patient navigation and case management
streamline the system and bring
reimbursement rates up to National
averages
the nhds and other members of the HP4
working group concur that an adult
Medicaid dental benefit must consider
the pent-up need of this population that
has persisted for decades perhaps their
entire adulthood without Dental without
Dental Care
achieving oral health may require
considerable time and effort from both
the provider and the patient we must
also consider that some cases may be so
significant that removable Prosthetics
like dentures and partials may be
necessary to Aid in a patient's
employability
the nhgs supports the principle of an
adult Dental Medicaid benefit and is
working diligently with the hb4 working
group to make this critical concept a
reality for New Hampshire patients we
hope that you will take into
consideration to conserve the concerns
I've just outlined and utilize our
dentist's extensive resources and
experience as you move to expand the
dental benefit to include adults the
nhds will proudly work with this
committee and all legislators to achieve
better oral health outcomes for in our
state the nhds strongly believes that an
adult benefit crafted in such a way that
it Fosters dentist participation in
Medicaid is needed in our state we
believe that hb103 is an important step
forward in achieving this goal and we
ask that you've voted ought to pass
thank you I'll take any questions you
may have any questions for Mr Oliver
I'm going to take one more and then we
will
recess this hearing to a later date at
that point we should know more about
what the Senate and the governor are
talking about and we should have
information for fiscal note but one of
the co-sponsors and state representative
I'd like to call on her representative
blazir
oh
oh God no
thank you so much Mr Speaker
um this is a representative Wazoo
representing District 17 Merrimack and I
will not take much of your time to
repeat what already been said and I want
to say thank you to uh representative
Shapiro for outlining all the details so
I just want to Echo of what he said and
giving my support to this bill and
hopefully you can and your committee
will support this bill to pass and give
some of those
um
have a joyful life and a smile to their
face thank you so much and I'll just end
with
well thank you so much and thank you for
good spots great with that
um
I'm going to
oh what's the right term but for now
this fearing to be reopened at a later
date when we have more information
and uh
we'll begin here on House Bill 363
creating a committee to study appointing
An Inspector General for nursing homes
in New Hampshire representative funding
would you introduce your bill please
hi Mr chairman this is uh representative
Alexander speaking
um I know you didn't recognize me but uh
representative Fenton right now is
having a child currently so I'm the one
that's going to be introducing
um the still if that's okay
then
yes thank you Senator Valentina
I am well thank you for the opportunity
for letting me introduce this bill
um for the record my name is
representative Joe Alexander I represent
the town of Goffstown or Hillsborough
District Six
um representative Fenton um contact me
earlier this year
um just as another another young
representative
um he outlined that New Hampshire has
the second oldest population in the
union and because of and perhaps the
nation's oldest nursing home population
and it's critical that we as legislators
can do what we do to make to make sure
that no stone is unturned
um in protecting our most vulnerable so
um just recognizing that the covid
crisis has really shown that there are
cracks in the system
um and it's been stretched although we
have tried our best to DHHS and nursing
home staff have done a wonderful job
um we've still seen 80 of our Cova
deaths involve residents in long-term
care facilities uh which is over twice
the national average we've seen
non-medical Staffing crunches including
short staff overtime extended overtime
and I personally heard from some
constituents from the Hillsborough
County home that
um just staff being burnt out from
overwork so uh while they're existing
while there is already existing
oversight this bill would look at the
feasibility
um to have an independent branch of its
own category With An Inspector General
um that's just in charge of General
accountability of our current system
regulation and inspection
um so we would first of all with this
committee study if the position is
currently needed given the current
system and what independent audits this
Inspector General would be responsible
for
um in the long-term care facilities so
um
just to reiterate I think this position
could be needed but I'd like to study
that further with some Representatives
so
um with that I would be happy to take
questions
any questions for representative
Alexander
representative Cushman
thank you Mr Sharon um thank you Mr
Alexander representative Alexander um as
a nurse who's worked in long-term care
facilities
um for quite a while uh we my experience
is that we undergo extensive inspections
as is and I just don't can you tell me
the demonstrated need for a separate
paid position
um a separate from the inspections that
the long-term care facilities all
already undergo and
you know aside from them having their
own budsmen what is the need for this
extra
well representative um thank you so much
for the question
um when I was actually contacted by a
Hillsborough County Administrator as
well that was asking me this very
question
um and I guess I would say that this
committee would look at
um to what extent this position did but
also like we've seen like even with that
thorough inspection already we're still
seeing problems in the system so I guess
having something that the legislature is
doing our due diligence to make sure
that these people are taking care of the
most vulnerable I guess that position if
if we determine that that's needed I
think
um that's an important thing to spend
our money on
follow up follow up do not the county
commissions which are made up of state
legislators already have the ability to
inspect
I mean I I believe they do I guess I
guess I would say is that
um that we are a different body than the
County government so
um we're doing what we'll do what we can
on our side and the county governments
can make their decisions for themselves
on where their funding goes
thank you uh representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you um
representative Alexander for taking my
question
um
I understand that this is
that this bill really calls for a study
committee
um so perhaps reasons why this would be
a good idea are premature
um but I my question is really why the
study committee would be made up
exclusively of senators and
representatives and not have other
stakeholders involved
um well thank you representative for the
question so
um I've only been on one other study
committee but the committee itself has
only been legislators and in the
legislators would call on others as
opposed to a commission which has um
different stakeholders on the actual
board the legislators are the ones that
call witnesses and ask for information
thank you
representative Weber
representative Weber you recognize to
ask a question
I'm sorry Mr chairman I had my hand up
for a question that has been answered so
thank you
all right thank you any other questions
for representative Alexander
seeing none I would like to call on my
phone tells me that the prime sponsor uh
representative Donovan Fenton is on the
call now representative would you like
to speak
my apologies he's not here he was just
on the list
okay then um
Jaya recognizes uh well they've pulled
their hands back down
rather than the cheer recognizes Teresa
Rosenberger to speak
thank you Mr chair and good afternoon
members of the committee I'm Theresa
Rosenberger I work for the law firm of
divine excuse me Bernstein Shore and I
represent the New Hampshire Health Care
Association on this bill and the health
care Association represents most all of
the private nursing homes in the state
as well as one of the County homes uh
needless to say we're always happy for
you all to do study committees and
particularly those when looking at
appointing An Inspector General
however we're not quite sure how this
position would fit into the existing
regulatory framework for example there's
appendix PP of the state operations
manual which is guidance to surveyors
for long-term care facilities it's 745
pages long
and it spells out specifically the
standards which the nursing homes are
held by by the state survey agency uh
and uh and and in the case of the
nursing homes in New Hampshire that's
the Department of Health and Human
Services so that's already one oversight
there's also
um
oversight at the at the federal level
and there's an in fact an office of a
long-term care Ombudsman which Advocates
on behalf of the residents and conducts
on-site visits and that does some of the
same similar things it's very similar
also what DHHS does which is
investigating
um and addressing complaints so I guess
our question would be where does it fit
into the structure how does it fit into
the structure there's tremendous
oversight now I will say during the
covet crisis the Department of Health
and Human Services has been absolutely
fabulous to work with needless to say
this has been a very stressful situation
for the nursing homes but I will say
there is not a telephone call that is
made that someone that at HHS doesn't
respond to and really has been working
hand in hand trying as best as possible
to deal with this pandemic as well as
protect the res residents as well as
keeping the nursing homes going so we're
more than happy to work on this needless
to say the most important thing right
now for nursing homes is finding the
staff and figuring out how to get the
census back up so we can actually have
the dollars to keep these nursing homes
going it's a really it's a really tough
situation at the moment I'm happy to
answer any questions I signed up neutral
we're happy to participate but also the
real question for us is where does this
fit in with all the other regulatory
schemes thank you very much
anyone else
to speak
and I would like to uh I have one hand
that just shot up I do apologize uh
chairman it's a Carolyn virtue has just
put her hand up
Fallen gambled by a nano stand well done
I'm gonna recognized to speak
thank you I believe I am unmuted Carolyn
virtue Granite case management
I work in
um community-based care I've accompanied
that does case management for a home and
community-based Care waiver
um a number of states
um have taken
um
similar actions
um such as this I would ask that as this
moves forward that you
um include the Homing Community Based
care portions of long-term care as well
not just the nursing homes
thank you would you take a question from
anyone if they have one yes I would
answer the question
thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
anyone else
and I would like to explore us to
hearing on Bill 363 and open an
executive session on the bill and
someone have I see a hand does someone
have a motion I have a motion for it to
representative Cushman has a motion and
your motion is that should make it an
expedient legislative
inexperienced legislation is the motion
is there a second
of March seconds March 2nd okay now we
may discuss
next
uh all right the motion to make this
recommend this bill be in expedient to
legislative because I think that it is
unnecessary it's yeah it's very
redundant
um we already have the ombudsmans who
Advocate on behalf of patients and
families we have the county commissions
that oversee the nursing homes and can
investigate and they work with the
nursing homes
um if there's any problems they can go
in and with permission and look
um and then we have the the state and
the federal government
thank you representative Solway
uh thank you Mr chairman uh I'd like to
draw your attention to an interesting
contrast this morning we gave our
blessing to HB 187 establishing
um an oversight over the Commissioner of
Health and Human Services I thought this
was a very responsible thing to do as
legislators it is imperative that we uh
provide
regulation over uh the executive uh
Departments of State Administration okay
now we take a look at the nursing homes
and we are aware that the nursing homes
are inspected by the federal government
they are inspected by the state they are
in about 50 percent of them in the state
actually it's less than that are run by
the counties and have County boards that
are overseeing them that's a lot of
existing oversight
the uh imperative for the legislature is
to keep state government lean effective
agile and I think all of this does is to
add a layer of Regulation that repeats
sets of regulations that are already in
place it will cost in terms of time in
terms of money and I don't think it adds
anything that isn't already in place and
I thank you for listening
to speak
Mr chair this is representative Marsh I
wanted to elaborate on my second yes
please yes and I thank representative
soloway who stole a great deal of my
thunder uh but I wish to also add that
the office of the long-term care of
bunsman adds yet another layer of
accountability in this the most
regulated sector of our economy in New
Hampshire and therefore I don't think
adding yet another layer on top is
necessary
thank you I would like to hear from
other members of the
wood
Mr chairman Mr representative Merchant
thank you sir
I would Echo both representative Marsh
in salivate
um I see a
cost Factor being added on to already
burden system with very little if any
value proposition to it so I would be
opposed to it because of those factors
we're adding a lot of cost to it with
very if any benefit accomplished by it
thank you very much
representative gays thank you thank you
for taking my statement this Association
of inspectors General that we all got
emailed
that sounds like they just found a nice
representative to do what they want to
do which is expand their organization
and get more people to pay dues
point of order
recognizes representative Weber for
uh I'm just going to remind everybody
that we do not speculate on other
Representatives motivation
or or
um you know what their motivations are
or how they were motivated I think
that's that's an unfortunate step in the
wrong direction and it's very much
against the traditions of the house
um you know opposing something is one
thing but attributing
motivation or or otherwise to a
representative is or anyone else for
that matter is
dropper
recognizes representative gay
I apologize for
I apologize for uh imposing motivation
on a representative
let's just restrict my my imposition on
the association of inspectors gems
representative Woods
uh thank you Mr chair
um I I too feel that this is not a
necessary entity
um I have viewed uh nursing homes while
I was in practice here in Concord for 34
years and used to make rounds at the
nursing homes on a monthly basis each
one on a monthly basis as well as having
family members at different nursing
homes and having seen some of the
difficulties that they encountered there
are currently mechanisms that are
available to both the medical side as
well as the patient side if there are
difficulties
um it's just a matter of uh like most
things being aware and then and then
advocating in that particular setting
um so I I agree I don't I don't see the
necessity at least at this juncture for
this entity
thank you representative Works anyone
else please
yes representative Shapiro yes sir
please
um
I would just like to say that
hopefully this is not a tributing
motivation to the sponsors but I would
just like to point to their intentions
which
um I think we would all agree that there
were was terrible tragedy in our nursing
homes during the past year and
um
that's not to blame it on improper or
lacking oversight but I think everybody
is struggling with the very high
percentage of deaths that occurred
within the
nursing homes so
I would like to vote for this but I
would have to agree with all the other
people who have spoken that I don't
really understand how
um
this is a solution that would add value
so I'm going to vote against it
thank you
someone who hasn't spoken what are your
thoughts
very good
it's not just that I like to hear the
thoughts of my colleagues
but I'm begging you to speak I'm trying
to undo
my painting myself into a corner
I had
said that there would be no votes this
afternoon meaning if somebody would need
to go somewhere you wouldn't be missing
anything so what I was trying to do is
see if we had a consensus
because then one or two people absent
doesn't make any difference in the votes
so uh thank you for failing me out here
representative Canuck is your hand is on
yes I just wanted to say that my initial
impression in this was that I favored it
and I favored it for the idea of being
able to bring together all the input of
the various other people and and have
one person who kind of had some
responsibility centrally and in
particular because we did see also some
various some disparities as I understand
in terms of response to coveted with
infection control uh between different
nursing homes however
I also am quite open to listening to the
very important uh comments made by
people who I respect who have made them
and they have convinced me that I will
actually vote against this even though I
initially favored it thank you thank you
representative Cobalt
thank you Mr chairman yes uh so I would
I would say my uh my views on this Echo
what we have already heard I think that
it adds
um unnecessary and unnecessarily
additional level of of uh regulation and
oversight it's not clear how that would
interface with existing oversight and so
I would vote in favor of the mass of the
motion to uh itl
thank you representative Nelson
I agree I agree with that what everybody
said itl
thank you
I reference uh my County delegation job
is to oversee the nursing home and
having visited people in the nursing
home all my professional life and much
of my childhood I do see a lot of
inspection going on already
anyone else
or we
follow a question
representative snow
I'll be very brief
I also don't think this is necessary
thank you
anyone else
the motion is 19 Barrel
moved by representative Cushman
second is my representative Marsh with
the Kirk please call the rules
representative Marsh
votes yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes
representative Acton
yes representative gay yes
representative Coachman yes
representative Folsom yes representative
Kelsey yes
yes representative King yes
representative Koval
yes
representative Weber
yes representative McCain yes
representative snow
yes representative
yes representative Callaway
yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter up on me yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes representative
Merchant yes yes
21-0
for a moment yes
all right the next bill is called for
three o'clock about consent should that
go in consent
rejection that you could
hear a reason for it it should go on
consent you know
no objection
yeah
representative Solway uh Mr chairman a
point of personal preference it is
nearing 2 30 and in the comfort and
warmth of my own home I have been
watching the national weather forecast
uh as it pertains to New Hampshire I'd
like to point out that uh snow is
forecast to begin in Earnest about three
o'clock and members of the committee who
are in Concord who live in Hillsboro
Rockingham and Stratford counties are
very likely to encounter snow on the
roads as they leave Concord may I
respectfully recommend uh that the
committee adjourn are going to recess
until tomorrow and give people a chance
to get home safely
any discussion on this
I will just say I don't think we can I
would check with the house clerk on this
because I have been chastised about it
before and I'm not sure how
how it came out but
I think if we recess today
for a hearing scheduled for today
I think we have to re-notice it but I'm
not sure I think but you would have you
would have to check that with the house
clerk okay please stand up please stand
by
Gary
all right
did you have a sandwich yeah okay a
question for Christina Christina can you
hear me
representative Mark Pearson yes I can
uh do we have a lineup of people wanting
to testify on uh HB 350.
yes we have about 10 people oh wow okay
thank you
could we possibly start early on 350. no
we cannot start before
that one actually yeah I would like to
point out though looking at the forecast
for Concord it is not starting heavily
it will be starting to snow but the the
hourly between uh two o'clock and seven
o'clock is only a half an inch
five hours half an inch is not going to
be a real big problem it's going to be
much more than that afterward that's
conquered and so I think that even if
we're down there
if you're down there I'm not I don't
think it's going to be that horrendous
because this hearing probably shouldn't
last that terribly long and it brought
it for you should be home before it
really hits with the teeth and the that
fits with the radar from the projected
radar as well
as one of the longer serving members I
will say time was we didn't stop for
anybody I've had hearings with three
committee members available for them but
um I understand the concerns that people
have about but I think it's for the
chairman and the person and people in
the room to decide that right and
actually if we're not going to vote two
people could conceivably say if they're
really worried they could leave
um if we are guarantee no votes right
you don't have to have a a quorum to
have the hearing you have to have a
quorum to vote and we'll all be here on
remote anyway we have a lot of people
here
Mr chairman if I may um with
representative Weber can we hear start
the hearing but then recess it although
we started it that's what the chair I
think is discussing with the clerk right
now because I think that I started a
hearing on one day and recessed it to
the next day and I think I was told very
firmly by the clerk that I couldn't do
that
um although I know very I know that I
did do it under a previous regime so I'm
I didn't want to either I will give you
the official answer or you can continue
to guess oh okay you go for it
Mr chairman if you wish us to continue
the hearing remotely and the people in
Concord have the opportunity to leave I
will be glad to continue the hearing
remotely and you can leave if you desire
and uh
yes sir with all due respect uh those of
you who live in what we refer to as the
provinces uh need to look at the weather
not in Concord but along the Seacoast
and in such uh Urban locations as
Hampstead in particular uh to figure out
if people are going to be at risk on the
way home
[Laughter]
perhaps we could all let our chairman
deliver his
deliberations
concerns
who is now a co-author of Masons yeah
I must start to hear it at three o'clock
that's right I can recess the here I
just can't bail on it
yeah okay
I'm prepared to stay for a while I've
got these big one snow tires on and
we'll Thrive slowly on the back roads
here
to leave I would encourage you to do
that or you'll have to answer the
representative Solway for the next year
it's at home
tuning in can continue I I think what I
want to do is get the thing going at
three o'clock I can't move it up
I'd like to uh go for a while
and then recess it get some of this
finished we have a few days to do much
stuff
so miss Mr chairman please
there's no penalty or punishment I won't
think you're bad for doing so
yes Mr chairman uh this is
representative Marsh again I will point
out that you noticed that this uh uh
hearing that we can hold executive
session during the day and we now have a
half an hour to kill before uh we uh uh
can begin the hearing on the next bill
so if you have anything you wish to exec
uh you could bring it up at this time
but if not we can all chat
Weber is that privilege just for bills
we've heard today or can we go back from
well
you have that particular notice in the
calendar
I've never liked that notice but
that's not my call so you can take up
any bill that we have heard at this
point
you uh texted me in some consternation
some minutes ago because you told people
that there would be no more voting today
and then we proceeded to take a vote
um so that is between you and your
conscience
um I think most of us are still here and
perhaps the thing to do would be to have
the clerk go down through the role and
just find out how many of us are still
here if we're all still here there's
absolutely no harm no foul for
proceeding as as you would and I think
you have the right to proceed anyway so
okay but that's up to you
okay okay we'll we'll take this in a
nice leisurely case
um okay this is for attendance
representative mark
president
representative McMahon here
uh representative Nelson yes
representative action here
representative gay here representative
Cushman president representative
I'm not sure
representative Chelsea present
representative
here
representative Weber here
representative McKay here
representative
no yeah
am I going slow enough
here
representative Sullivan
representative Soul away he has walked
out of his room because I see his chair
empty
but he's still on
um representative Cannon I'm here
to representative matter of purpose I'm
also here
representative Shapiro
I see you but you're muted I am here
thank you you representative Woods I
think I'm still here
representative Merchant
here
and representative Pearson a promise you
the Mind left the building a few hours
ago
and I would really really like to be
sitting in
um the same
ouch or whatever it is that
representative is sitting on it looks
incredibly comfortable it
all right let's take a look guys thank
you it's pretty good
once this is all over we'll have a party
at your house
I might have it cleaned up cleaned up by
the end of the pandemic so
representative Woods you uh introduced
your bill 131 relative to reporting oh
wonderful thank you I had to open the
door for Jennifer and I'll let Sophie
out you're you're unmuted Jeff
Jeff you're unmuted
don't say anything bad all right on
January 26th
we looked at
the club says we think except anything
we want okay I want the Red Sox to win
next year the relative to reporting of
Health Care Associated infections
representative Woods a week enough along
on this that we could uh
go into an executive session or would
you like us to defer someone
um uh at this juncture there were a
couple questions uh uh from one from
um uh representative kovalt and one from
representative uh Cushman and I was
trying to look at those and I had a uh
conversation uh with HHS and we have a
zoom meeting Wednesday morning uh with
CDC uh and HH
New Hampshire HHS uh to just get
definitive clarification of exactly what
the terms mean uh which the term that
came to mind was I came into question
was measures and what that meant uh and
what that might imply as far as what uh
this would allow the reviews to
accomplish uh the second thing was
relative to vaccines and relative to
what that would imply relative to the
administration of those vaccines and
whether they're required or not and if
so uh yes or no what that would imply uh
so I was uh in the process of getting it
clarified I can only get a zoom meeting
with HHS as earliest I could get was
Wednesday morning
um
so it's not ready for us to to vote on
yet I I would yes
foreign
what about hb290
you mean the one I have in my hand
perfect great minds think oh I didn't
even have that elbow that I felt
you know without being near each other
to Elbow each other they're still doing
pretty well
yeah
can I have the sort of a general nod or
a general
flying by the street here
you see it on 290
looks to me from my notes this is not
questions it should be regularly
disagree but it doesn't look like it
needs a lot of work
opening a hearing on Niceville 290
relative to excuse me I'm opening an
executive session on House Bill 290
relative to policies required for health
facilities and special Healthcare
licenses
I need one please be
written policy to restore that the
facility provides its services to all
persons who require the services uh the
facility provides regardless of the
source of payment the services provided
to any person and here's the change
unless
the facility explicitly provides
services to persons who make direct
payment for services for the purposes of
this paragraph a direct payment is one
that is paid directly by the patient
not reimbursed or otherwise paid by a
third party
and the question if you remember in the
discussion was uh wouldn't this be
skimming off the crane and people who
couldn't pay or couldn't pay at all
would wind up
going only to certain facilities which
financially might swamp them that was
the General tone of the discussion so
I'm hoping for further discussion
Meg may I Mr chair yes please
representative Canary
to initiate the discussion may I move
itl
you may and I would second it and that
was representative Weber yes thank you
thank you
okay so there's the there is the uh
function on the floor now let's discuss
would you like me to my motion
yeah continue to representative
okay thank you very much uh yes I the
reason I move itl on this is that it it
will do precisely what you were alluding
to a moment ago I served on the uh
legislative committee with uh Senator
Jeff Bradley a year and a half ago in
which we were looking at this issue
about the impact on critical access
hospitals of facilities which are
um licensed in an act in the somewhere
in the area of the critical access
hospital and that was for license this
one
um allows people to just go ahead and
just do whatever they want
um and I think the problem is that this
will skim off the high paying cash
customers or people who have uh
deductibles but are still paying some
cash
and it will significantly impact our
critical access hospitals many of them
run on margins that are either in the
red
or barely in the Black by perhaps a half
a percent and the we when we looked at
this even just the whole idea of an
Urgent Care opening somewhere in the
vicinity of a critical access Hospital
could be a Death Note because as anybody
knows a little bit about how we Finance
uh hospitals you don't get a lot of
money out of things like labor and
delivery because that's mostly Medicaid
you don't get a lot of money out of the
emergency room visits because they're
often uninsured or underpaid and you get
it out of the high-paying things such as
Orthopedics elective procedures physical
exams things like that that are
reimbursed better and they subsidize
what happens and including also Imaging
and all those things so if we allow
somebody who says hey you pay cash in
the barrel you can come here and no
problem and we can be anywhere we want
that may have a significant impact on
our critical access hospitals which are
critical to serve people and the comment
was made earlier to day I think about
losing for example labor and delivery uh
hospitals we have already lost some and
uh if we lose some more it's going to be
a real long time and in fact I already
understand in Laconia the fire
department has delivered many more
babies in the last year than what they
did in previous years because people
can't make it to a hospital in time to
have their child so that's the major
concern that I have with this bill is
that it really is going to negatively
impact a lot of our hospitals but
particularly critical access hospitals
it looks like it really deals with you
know lots of facility type of things
it's not just a surgery center but that
will also be an important impact because
if it takes away the surgical
um business that eats into the hospital
and lastly the comment was made that
this money would probably not be tracked
in terms of their deductible and so they
still would end up having to pay a
deductible later for something else I
think I understood that part enough
thank you
thank you representative Weber
uh thank you Mr chairman I was going to
speak to my second but I think that
representative nerk has said everything
that needs to be said on the subject so
I will just say that I agree with him
thank you
representative snow
thank you Mr chairman I believe we did
get an email and I don't remember the
source that I can't go through I only
have one computer so I can't go off here
to go look for it but I think it came
from someone within the Department of
Health and Human Services that said
there's already a law that states that
listing facilities hospitals blah blah
blah blah must take care of everybody
that comes certain other ones like
recovery houses support homes group
homes Adult Day Care Home and Community
Service Providers and doctor's offices
and
some kind of clinics
do not have to take everybody who walks
in
and so to me it becomes kind of
meaningful I mean meaningless I I think
it I agree to it should be itl because
it just draws attention to the fact that
this already laws that allows certain
people that should be taking everybody
that that comes in and don't come if
anything we ought to take a look at that
other law and look at ones that should
no longer be excluded from having to
take everybody that comes in
representative Marsh
uh thank you Mr chairman uh I'm in some
ways conflicted because I do support
free market Health Care as you know it
was my bill it was the direct primary
care bill that the sponsors are referred
to when they gave their testimony that
being said as I said at the hearing I am
troubled by the Association of uh uh
Hospital bankruptcies enclosures in
Oklahoma close to the surgery center of
Oklahoma which is the model that this
bill would follow and I don't believe
that there are adequate protections for
such facilities in the state of New
Hampshire uh we've lost enough hospitals
in New Hampshire already and we
certainly don't need to lose more there
was a a
analogy made between direct primary care
and this bill and as I pointed out at
the hearing I I don't think that that is
quite true uh direct Primary Care pays
Physicians on a retainer and in order to
have something similar to that for
facilities you would have to pay the
facilities on a retainer and in many
ways we could create a free market
system that's very much like Ambulatory
Care Organization like accountable care
organizations and I think we might find
the left and the right meet in the
middle if we were to explore that that
further so I'm afraid this bill is
drafted I will regrettably have to vote
in favor of itl
anyone else
I miss Mr chairman if I might follow up
I looked up in my notes and apparently
that that
you mentioned that I talked about came
from Paula minahan at the New Hampshire
Hospital Association
thank you for that clarification
representative
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman
um I will vote I mean I will speak in
opposition to the itl recommendation uh
emotion that's on the floor right now
um I support this bill as it's written I
believe that it will help to drive
health care costs Downs costs down
um
by allowing practitioners to only accept
direct payment
um there will be less administrative
costs no need to be under an umbrella
reimbursement system
um it'll help the gig economy and others
who work and people who work in it who
don't have traditional employer-based
health insurance and may not qualify for
Medicaid
um and I believe that it's only can do
good things for the healthcare Market in
New Hampshire and that New Hampshire
that closures of hospitals around the
Oklahoma
facility that offers this kind of
service there's no evidence that those
closures are directly related to that
and we have bankruptcies of hospitals in
New Hampshire without this in law so I
ask that the others that the committee
will vote no on in expedient to
legislation thank you very much
representative active
awesome thank you Mr chair
you know I understand both sides of this
story here and but it just seems to me
that we're we're stifling Innovation to
prop up a system that really just isn't
working and when hospitals are going
into bankruptcy that's a sign of of
problems that need to be fixed
themselves rather than shutting down in
essence creating monopolies for these
for these facilities and or for the for
the existing traditional hospitals so if
someone has um I'm still on the fence
here so if someone wants to try to
convince me feel free
foreign
policy Guru as much as uh some of the
folks uh here uh but I guess my sense
would be if this were taken to its
extreme let's just pretend that we that
would it in fact put us back to the way
insurance was the beginning uh there was
no direct Contracting uh you had your
insurance you got a bill uh you paid it
and then you had to get the insurance
company to pay you
um and it seems like
um taking and it's extreme that's where
we might end up going I may be wrong but
um
um and that that's not where we would
want to go uh so I'm I'm not in favor
what else
Mr chairman if I may presided Merchant
thank you Mr chairman I I support itl I
believe at this point
um the intent of the bill has some
merits to it but the way it's written I
think it's problematic
um I do believe that right now when he's
talking about trying to get a group of
providers together to deal with some of
the high level cost of things like
Hospital costs and so forth I don't know
where Primary Care Providers want to get
into that Arena to begin with is very
costly number two I think it
representative Marsh's point of view and
some of the other folks here on the call
um I do see a slippery slope where we're
starting to take some of the
um
opportunity for some of the critical
access hospitals to keep themselves
afloat and right now they're on the edge
of um going below water financially I
think this is going to be a possibility
of causing War disruption in that
Marketplace and ultimately lead to not
having Health Care in some of the Rural
America that we need to have so
therefore I would spoke to Ideal
thank you representative Co Falls
thank you Mr chairman
um so I guess I'd like to start by
correcting what I believe is a
misconception that came out of the last
hearing uh when we were talking about or
when someone was talking about
reimbursement
for those who direct pay would
if if they if they're on a high
deductibility plan High deductible plan
that they would subsequently need to
um meet that deductible again
um having been in a high deductible plan
I can tell you that
um whenever our family has direct paid
for services
um we hold on to those receipts we can
submit those to the insurer and they do
count towards the deductible
um so that's just a a
point of fact around around that uh
question I guess my you know my concern
is that you know we've talked about the
the value of free market health care and
um you know the the the concern is that
direct pay providers are
siphoning off
the most profitable customers from
facilities that will otherwise
um be be left with a with a less
profitable or unprofitable
population that they're serving I guess
to me that's a sort of a de facto
admission that there is a hidden subsidy
built into this and and while I don't
believe that we're necessarily going to
solve that problem by passing or not
passing this bill my concern is that
there are forces in play that discourage
Innovation and that discourage
um
you know effective Cost Containment and
that by encouraging this kind of free
choice for for consumers in the
healthcare Market as well as encouraging
Innovation and competition
we are we are encouraging the kind of
Cost Containment and an innovation that
that ultimately benefits everyone so I
will vote against the motion to itl
representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman um
to speak to representative Acton's
question
I think the thing is this
um
if we had a completely free market
in medical care we would be back to
where we were pre-all of the existing
rules and regulations and insurances and
everything else and that would mean that
people who had money would get care and
people who didn't have money would not
get care
and I'm not going back to that
um
some of us would actually like to see
Universal Health Care wherein everybody
gets care and that's that but I realize
that also is not the situation in which
we live
and may never be who knows but what we
have what the way I look at it is we
have to deal with the system as it is
now
and if we
thrust ahead with this Innovation which
you know is going to certainly change
things in some direction we don't know
what
um the real risk is taking what we have
now which is
providing critical care to people who
will be with it without it unless we
keep some of the current structure until
we figure out what to do for the best to
replace it
um I think I think it for me it's not a
great idea to kick one of the props out
of a three-legged stool before we've got
another prop to put under it
so my thought is that
um
let's
keep our critical do everything we can
to keep our critical access hospitals
going because they are providing very
very needed services that are not going
to be readily replaced by anybody else
because uh they're not the ones that are
the most lucrative so that's that's my
plea
thank you thank you anyone else which is
to speak representative gay thank you Mr
chairman I agree with Lucy that uh well
I agree with both sides because yes I
would like to see the cost of Medical
Care drop because as we would take care
of our own processing with our insurance
the real issue that I've seen ever since
my mother went into excuse me the
private pay plus Medicaid nursing home
is that
Medicaid simply does not pay enough to
keep hospitals open and so right now the
way this the fee schedule is if a
hospital only has Medicaid
of
what's the right word patience it can't
it can't stay it just can't make it so
we have to come out if we want to change
it and cut some costs this will not do
it because this will just wipe out the
positive slope of money that's keeping
the hospitals open so I agree there's a
problem I agree we ought to find a
solution but right now this is not the
solution we'll just stop keeping
hospitals open that right now cannot
survive on Medicaid
thank you representative canark
yes I just want to reflect back to some
previous comments about getting the free
market to work the problem is that
Health Care simply doesn't function as a
free market Health Care is
infrastructure and you in a free market
and it's a great option for a consumer
good you can have different companies
working to produce the best good at the
lowest price and you can buy it and you
can compare and shop and you also have
the choice to not buy it if you think it
is more money than you wish to spend for
that good medicine doesn't work that way
if you're sitting there in the Ew with a
broken ankle or better yet inflamed
appendix and you need it taken care of
you're not going to be able to shop
around other hospitals to find out who
has a better deal and the it's probably
not going to be wise to be able to say I
think that costs too much I will not
elect to have that surgery that's not
going to lead to a good outcome
so it simply doesn't function as a free
market and so what happens here is again
these places work you know nine to five
hours or maybe seven to five hours they
uh take the elective stuff that pays
well and the problem is that you cannot
as representative Gage has pointed out
support a local hospital on the
reimbursements that are left over they
will not be there and they the reason
they're called critical access is that
they're there to provide the critical
care for people in the community because
when you do get run over by a truck you
can't necessarily be transported 100
miles to some other hospital because
there's none around we need them in our
rural areas and even our more urban
areas for people who can't afford the
other hospitals the key issue is
no matter how you shake it if you pull
out the money from them we're going to
lose them and that will have an enormous
impact on the accessibility of all of us
to health care and and because it just
doesn't function like a free market
thank you thank you representative
Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman um
I think it's great that we have this
extra time so we could have a
philosophical debate about
um
about open markets and um but we're
probably not going to convince one
another I mean there are those of us who
feel like the problem with medicine is
that it's based on free markets and
there's prob and there's others of us
who feel like the problem is that it's
not free market enough
um so we're probably not going to
convince each other although I think
it's a good thing to talk about
um I also served on that committee with
representative knurk and for me
um
when people came to speak from critical
care hospitals in the North Country they
spoke about the possibility of having to
do without
obstetrics in their communities but to
me the most poignant thing was when
people talked about a hospital
the risk of a hospital closing and
they're just not being an emergency room
in a in a community and
um
you know we we are lucky to live in a
country where we are used to and feel
like we deserve to be able to go to an
emergency room in case of a critical
emergency and that just might not be the
case
um
if um Financial pressure causes some of
these hospitals to close
so I would support voting to itl this
bill I'd like to move on to our three
o'clock Hearing in a minute but uh the
last name I have is again representative
profile
I did not have my hand up I had I had
already given my comments thank you very
much the devotion
on uh
promotion is an expedient to legislate
moved by representative knurk second by
representative Weber
with the clerk call the roll please
representative mark
reluctantly yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yeah yes
representative Acton
yes
representative gay yes
representative Cushman no
representative Folsom yay
representative Kelsey no
representative King yes
representative colfault
now
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative snow yes
representative nurse
yes
representative Solway yes
representative Cannon yes
representative yes
representative Shapiro
yes
representative Woods yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Pearson yes
the team put three the most been
inexperienced respiratory passes
representative canark would you write
the uh
the majority report yes sir
and um would you wish to write The
Minority Report
representative questions thank you this
closes the executive session on
um
Committee hearing
on Bill 350.
for many qualified patients and
designated caregivers to cultivate
cannabis for therapeutic use
and I will point out to those on this
bill it is an important bill we respect
uh what you are bringing forward to us
as we do with all bills but because of
intending weather numbers of us will be
leaving
um I'd like to hear from
three to four group speakers on this
bill and then we will
um uh
movement to a continuance on another
date
representative Acton would you introduce
your girl please
okay thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
all for your time uh what we have here
is HB 350 permitting qualified patients
and designated caregivers to cultivate
cannabis for therapeutic use now this
bill has passed the house several times
so
um
I originally considered to be honest
with you um rather than going through
the same thing again and again
um of of re of retaining this bill and
dealing with the next next session but I
think that does a disservice to patients
who are suffering right now and let me
explain uh why I think that way
basically what we're doing is we're
allowing patients as designated
caregivers to grow their own cannabis at
home and it allows for Three Mature
plants three immature plants and 12
seedlings to be cultivated in a secure
location out of of sight of neighbors
um in a
within the uh either the caregivers home
or the patient's home so they you can't
set up a a commercial grow room or
anything like that so
um you know a lot of work has gone into
this over the years we we put a lot of
work into it in 2019 I've did a lot of
changes and so forth but um it just it
just unable we're not unable to get it
through maybe this time will be the um
the time it works uh let's just um you
know a lot of people who are who are
against this
um can't seem to
comprehend how we can allow people to
grow Canada how do you not control that
well let's take a look at the states
around us in Maine any adult not just
medical can grow up to six adult plants
in their own home any anyone it's a it's
recreational grow uh the same with
Massachusetts uh Massachusetts you're
allowed to grow six plants and two
people in a home can uh you can grow 12
plants you're also allowed to give an
ounce of of uh cannabis to each to other
people in Vermont you're allowed to grow
nine plants and this is all once again
not just medical it's it's anyone Rhode
Island six plants
um so this is already happening for
anyone in the rest of New England uh
Connecticut uh doesn't have this but but
as far as all the states surrounding us
and even in Canada
um
adults are allowed to do this and we've
yet to even allow our patients to do it
now why patients need to do it is is
first of all affordability it is
extremely expensive we created this
program with a lot of overhead a lot of
regulations and the end result is high
product uh high prices for for patients
and um you patient you know these are
these are desperately ill people and
they really it's it's difficult to
afford going to the uh alternative
treatment centers
um secondly is variety there's uh you
know we've learned over the years that
certain strains have different effects
for various illnesses and effects on for
different people and so forth uh the the
alternative treatment centers can't
provide that they can't have that it'd
be a possible for them to have the the
variety of strains and that are needed
for to treat individual ailments so this
would allow patients or designated
caregivers to
um grow the specific Strays for the for
the specific patients
so really that's that's what we're
trying to do here um we hear a lot of
fear-mongering sometimes about how
people uh you know what are they gonna
they're gonna give it to their friends
are they gonna is it you know kids and
so forth but
we're far behind other states and and I
just don't I don't understand anymore
why uh we can't just allow patients to
do that so
um I'm going to go ahead and and
conclude my testimony and there's
certainly if anyone has any questions
um myself or one of the speakers coming
after me can answer that thank you
any questions for representative action
yes
um representative Folsom thank you chair
um thank you for taking this question
um this I I've been reading all the
emails that have been coming in about
this and so
um it's left me with some questions on
on kind of ambivalence on this whole
thing but
um one of the things I wanted to know is
what is approximately the current prices
for an ounce of marijuana uh purchased
at a
um dispensary
of the going price in New Hampshire is
uh between 350 and 400 dollars
and that's very expensive you know
that's a lot of money some people need
several ounces a month for their
treatment so that's
um and that price could be cut
tremendously by growing your own okay
then my next question is
um
not with not incriminating yourself but
uh what is the going rate for Black
Market
marijuana
the going rate you know it it's it
depends it's usually
150 to 200 uh probably pushing 200 for
the medical quality that has been grown
in a controlled facility and so forth
and that that is part of the problems
you just on the black market you don't
know what you're getting and um
and in this case growing your own you
can control the the process and and uh
know that know that you're producing
quality product for yourself and how
much and how much uh would uh an ounce
thrown at home
eventually cost the person thinking
about lighting in heat and
sure uh it's usually you know
for three plants you'd you'd use a
probably a high uh you know high power
lighting maybe a thousand watt light it
costs between fifty and sixty dollars a
month to run that so it's really it's
Pennies on the dollar less
um
it's just overhead costs it's it's
utilities and and you know time doesn't
matter but the but it's it's basically
the the utilities and the fertilizer and
the the hardware and so forth which you
buy once and you can use repeatedly
so that one more so that would
um equate to what per ounce
probably
um 25 an ounce
thank you
any other questions for representative
Acton
yes Mr chairman yes representative
Nelson
one is how many plans can a designator
caregiver grow for people can they grow
for 10 people or just one or two
no that's been limited uh so a
designated caregiver can only grow for
one person yeah we didn't want to create
you know pot shops or or commercial
Grows Where one person can bring off and
then you know they had that issue up in
Maine where you could have one paragraph
could grow for six people and and you
know so we wanted to avoid that so it's
really a caregiver is um allowed to grow
for only one person
and now a um
a patient can grow for themselves and
also grow as a caregiver for somebody
else so that would be the maximum of six
plants for one location in in that
instance only
follow-up question sure yeah are all
these people registered who is going to
receive it or who could grow it for them
yes see well um
everyone has to be a part of the program
so you have to be licensed um either as
a patient or as a caregiver and uh
there's strict rules we create a special
felony for diverting cannabis out of the
program and say if somebody was caught
selling it to just whoever uh they would
actually be guilty of of
the special felony that we created for
this program as well as any other
generic felonies that already that are
already in a book so you're in big
trouble if you get caught diverting
therapeutic cannabis out of this program
to somebody else I I don't believe
they've even arrested anybody on that
yet
thank you
representative Gary thank you Mr
chairman
um not that I disagree with it but I
thought you just said that you could
grow it for one a caregiver could grow
up for one person but on page one uh
lines 11 and 12.
as well from 215 it says a caregiver can
assist with one or more not to exceed
five qualifying patients and if they
live greater than 50 miles away they can
assist throw it up for real cannabis for
up to 9 12 5 patients I'm not
disagreeing with that I just wanted to
point that out
yeah you know it's been two years since
we went through this line by line so I
may have to get clarification like if
Michael if Michael Holt is here that
would be uh but yeah they um
I may have gotten that one wrong there
we'll we'll have to um clarify that for
you
representative yeah thank you so uh I I
keep wanting to make a statement and I
haven't figured out how to make it into
a question actually you representative
gay can I just have a follow-up on the
last question a a caregiver can assist
patients by say going in and obtaining
cannabis at the alternative treatment
center for them but you can only grow
for one person so you can help patients
in the traditional uh role of of being a
caregiver which which is you usually
just if someone's too sick to leave the
house you have a caregiver go to the ATC
and get that for them being being the
caregiver they're protected from arrest
if they get pulled over something but
you can only grow for one person so you
can't grow for five people and have a
house full of uh pot plants
any other questions for representative
Acton
Mr care representative can Eric
yes please just a quick one um we spent
a lot of time talking about financial
barriers uh is that true also that they
are geographical access barriers for
patients in the therapeutic cannabis
program and could you discuss those
yes uh well that's a better problem from
the get-go is is the location of the
atcs in the the uh small amount of
licenses uh like for instance for for me
to go to the
alternative treatment centers it's it's
in Dover it's about a 45 minute drive
but it gets much worse as you go north
and uh so be able to grow at home as
always you guys get to run to the deal
up there but um what we you know what
we've allowed we've made some some uh
in the law itself there there's uh you
know
some
some things have been changed for that
but in general it's hours of driving if
you're in the North Country to get to a
treatment center so growing
at home and and thank you for reminding
uh me about that representative because
that is an issue uh that us Flatlanders
down here uh forget is that it it takes
you got to drive two hours to do
anything other than you know so it's
unfair to the patients up north
thank you
anyone else
yes representative Olson
um and for uh thank you Mr chair um
representative Acton um are there any
guidelines with regards to training or
um
classes of some kind for individuals who
are going to grow the Cannabis on their
own and then turn it into whatever form
of product they want so they understand
potency for
gummy bear
yeah this there's there's not much
formal training
um certainly not New Hampshire because
it's it's really not
there's just no Market
um
all
information you'd ever want to know is
all on YouTube so so you could there's
thousands of hours of of training videos
online that people can watch and that's
how I got a lot of my information just
watching uh because you know this has
been going on for for 10 over 10 years
now around the country so the the body
of knowledge is quite amazing so the
information is there it's just all
online rather than
going and actually training at a
facility or something like that that
doesn't quite exist certainly not here
in New Hampshire and I'm not sure where
else but the information is out there
and very specific recipes and and so
forth to follow
bill
um the chair would now like to take out
of order uh Chief I have one more
question
sure
all right
representative act and thank you for
um introducing this
um we've talked about
um relative pros and cons of
um you know not wanting to promote use
for adolescence
um
you know ways that that
that cannabis grown at home might fall
into the wrong hands
um on the other side there's the
geographical issues and there's the cost
issues but I'm wondering if you could
conceive that people who are actually
able to grow their own cannabis that
there might be some value added just in
being able to grow their own
um
in terms of self-reliance in terms of
um putting their hands in the soil in
terms of
you know just this is to Live Free or
Die State and and might there not be
some value gained in people being able
to take care of themselves
yes um well that that's part of it as
well and patients I think want to be
there's a therapeutic aspect to Growing
to we all understand who are gardeners
there's a therapeutic aspect of that and
and so to be able to produce exactly
what the strain that you want
um and and controlling you in in your
own home I think there's there's value
to that
um I you know I don't I haven't grown
but I I I'm an avid Gardener and I
there's
there's an intrinsic value to that that
really
um it is part of of the healing
because it was snowing I guess you're in
the you can't talk on the phone I'll
tell you in a few more minutes thank you
very much
um the chair and I recognizes chief
rapunzky
foreign
yes good afternoon can you hear me yes
and and Mr chairman Wong the chief is
unmuting could I remind representative
snow to please mute I think we're
hearing background conversations
oh sorry
well and I'll apologize for my telephone
going off when I was unmuted I'm sorry
one more chance for chief for fun Steve
yeah
can you hear me yeah probably could it's
happening you're muted again sir
okay let me just I have to hold the
space bar down apparently okay
okay
okay uh ready to go all right so I'm
here representing the New Hampshire
Chiefs I'm sorry for the technical
issues
um the chiefs of police here in New
Hampshire are opposed to this bill for
the following reasons as we all know
cannabis is already widely available to
qualifying patients and they're
well-regulated therapeutic cannabis
program but again as a reminder cannabis
is not commercialized uh in New
Hampshire like it is in our neighboring
states of Maine and Vermont so that that
is an unfair uh comparison because it is
not commercialized here this bill we're
concerned primarily because this bill
removes the necessary regulatory uh and
Regulation and controls over the
distribution growing and distribution of
cannabis for medical purposes there are
ample studies that provide scientific
proof that high potency cannabis leads
to a host of medical and behavioral
problems in a adults as well as children
if this bill is passed members of the
committee there is no regulation of the
quality and potency of cannabis that
will be used for medical purposes no
medicine in any developed country used
by medical practitioners is homegrown
and dispensed as medicine without any
degree of Regulation to ensure its
quality Effectiveness and most of all
safety so uh
if homegrown cannabis is approved there
will be absolutely no effective means
for law enforcement to control homegrown
cannabis there are absolutely no
Provisions in this bill to ensure that
the requirements for the number and
limitation of the amount and number of
plants grown and produced is maintained
that's our principal concern now if the
bill had ample regulatory applications
that would allow for regulatory
inspections of locations that are
registered for home grow and home
cultivation then the chiefs of Police
Association would take another look at
the bill
law enforcement and any other regulatory
agency is powerless as the bill is
currently constructed to conduct any
kind of periodic regulatory inspections
and in fact in the previous testimony as
it was introduced there have been uh no
cases of the diversion of cannabis from
the
authorized growing sites and the reason
for that is is because of the State
Challenge that law enforcement faces in
being able to control cultivation of
marijuana without any regulatory control
there's been ample cases in other states
where commercial Growers have exploited
homegrown cultivation so this bill
basically takes the breaks off cannabis
and unleashes commercialization With No
Boundaries controls or mechanisms under
um under the veil of Compassionate Care
so we're opposed to this particular bill
for these reasons basically because of
the ability for any regulatory agency or
law enforcement agency to be able to to
control it so thank you for your time
and thank you for listening well you
take questions too
so
the chair recognizes state
representative running coaching a
co-sponsor of the bill
is representative Cushing does not
appear to be available
the chair recognizes
Paige Steinberg
hi there
hi
um so is now when I read my testimony
now is the time perfect thank you so
much clearly my first time doing this
but something I'm very passionate about
so my name is Kate Steinberg I am a
resident of Ashland and Grafton County
and I'm here today asking for your
consideration in supporting HB 350.
I I have been working in the Cannabis
space for about five years
um specifically working for a medical
cannabis company and I have seen and
heard both sides to this debate
um but I am here today to speak on
behalf of the patients
who are the very reason the state of New
Hampshire initially passed the bill
allowing medical cannabis patients to
access this alternative treatment option
so I asked that even for a moment you
look at this bill and consider the
impact it would have for the thousands
of patients in the state
with that being said I would like to
note that these thoughts are solely mine
and do not represent the thoughts of the
company I work for
I was diagnosed with depression and
generalized anxiety disorder at the age
of 14 and severe thoracic problems at
the age of 20. I had tried various
Pharmaceuticals with minimal success and
maximum side effects until I discovered
my home state had a medical cannabis
program within one year of becoming a
medical cannabis patient not only did I
start my dream job in the Cannabis
industry but I also discontinued all use
of pharmaceuticals lost over 40 pounds
and felt more myself than I had felt
since I was first diagnosed
there are two reasons I would like to
ask for your consideration in supporting
this bill today lack of access to a
medical cannabis facility and The Proven
benefits of Horticultural therapy there
are only I believe five dispensaries in
the state at this point in time which
means that patients in Pittsburgh must
drive up to two and a half hours to
reach their nearest dispensary
that's a five hour round trip and to a
patient with debilitating back pain or
severe anxiety this can be an immense
barrier to access
let's just say that patient had young
children and a full-time job finding the
time to make that five hour drive would
become an even larger barrier
in addition to the patient who has found
success with only a handful of strains
due to the cannabinoid and terpenoid
content none of which might be available
at their nearest dispensary this can be
an immense barrier to those of you who
may not be as familiar with with the
medicinal properties of cannabis there
are both the cannabinoids like THC and
CBD but there are also terpenes which
are the essential oils found in there as
well and they all work together to make
every single strain different
if you were to try a strain that worked
perfectly for um let's just say your
severe PTSD or your severe back problems
and it wasn't at your nearest dispensary
you may not find success with the other
strains available
now to those of you who may not be aware
there is a practice called Horticultural
therapy which is a form of therapy
utilizing gardening growing vegetables
fruits flowers and other plants for
therapeutic purposes Studies have shown
Horticultural therapy to improve quality
of life for patients with dementia PTSD
anxiety cancer and even for sexual
assault survivors Horticultural therapy
has been shown to help improve memory
cognition task initiation coordination
balance strength and endurance so
imagine the benefits for the patients of
New Hampshire should you pass this bill
and allow the option for home
cultivation
while patients living hours from their
nearest dispensary could utilize home
cultivation as their primary source of
medicine those living nearby to an
alternative treatment center could just
grow one or two plants therapeutically
while still supporting their local ATC
that's what I have today but I wanted to
thank you all so much for your time and
to let you know to please consider me as
a resource should you have any other
questions that I can be of assistance
with
thank you does anyone have any questions
from the Steinberg
thank you for your testimony thank you
so much the chair calls Justin Johnson
hi there I
hello
can you guys hear me
hello everybody
um thank you for having me here today
um I am a New Hampshire cannabis patient
I
have been following the story
um since the legislation has started
in terms of the medical cannabis reforms
specifically
very interested in how we can continue
to work with local communities to help
people that have debilitating illnesses
and diseases acquired the right type of
treatment that they need at a
cost-effective measure as stated by
other people previously it's very hard
for patients that have these
debilitating diseases to one be able to
pay for everything when
the cost for just a single ounce is is
drastically higher in our our state and
in one location
um it's very hard again to rely on the
strains that you're specifically looking
for to treat your
ailments or uh to treat anything
specifically
um and it's it's difficult because we're
getting to a point where in the
hospitals we're not able to have a
conversation or a solution around
um what's the best best method as to
getting people the treatment they need
with the proper resources available
there it's very hard
pulling them all together when
um again we have over policing uh still
being an issue and it's not that we
don't want to
um you know add more things to the bill
as the police chief was saying we do
want if needed uh to to have you know
people come in and check just to make
sure that things are going
correctly and it would actually be even
better if there was a program uh by the
state to help patients or caregivers
grow or to teach them more like more
Horticulture classes or whatever is
available just just more for the
community so we can actually grow and
continue
um to push forward in these uh these
hard times it's
it's only made it more clear
um that traveling out of state isn't an
option anymore for these patients
um originally this started with
you know a woman suing the state for her
right to just get a card so she can go
to Maine to get medication that she
needed
um and that's not an option anymore for
anybody
even though the surrounding states are
are legal um it's it's not wise for
anybody to go out of state to travel
with medication from a different state
into your own State just based on the
current legislation on a federal and
state level
so we still need a lot done that is
obvious but the first step would still
be to make sure that patients have the
right
or a right to grow the specific strains
that they need in the smallest amounts
possible because again the centers that
are available
we don't always have the amount that you
can pick up for the strains that you
need so again those
those profiles on the strains that you
need aren't aren't helping
um
so it's it's a very tough issue I know
um there's a lot of different areas that
we still need to work on but I hope that
somehow we can figure out
um how we can work together
um not just on a state level but you
know the whole North Northeast here uh
to figure out what's the best method to
try to you know alleviate some of the
terminally ill people
um and their treatment and the resources
that are available that are just very
hard for people to reach
um and to pay for
but I do think that allowing this bill
to be passed would
um again displace the illicit market and
make sure that people have equal access
um and a cheaper cost
um
that would dramatically help their
condition in the long term
of life
and thank you Mr Johnson for coming to
testify before us
chair recognizes Lisa powers
hello can you hear me you can
hi everyone thank you for being here my
name is Lisa Powers I live in Manchester
New Hampshire I am a nurse a cannabis
nurse a cannabis caregiver a cannabis
patient I do teach people how to grow
safely and just for the record you can
get by with thirty dollars a month
increase in your utility bills if you
use the right kind of lighting three
months of that you're under a hundred
dollars and you can have several ounces
of your medication that you need for
your condition and if you do it outside
very little cost and your plant can grow
more for you outside typically so um I'm
I'm in full support of the bill as you
probably figured that out by now
um hold on just a sec
so I fully support this and I sent a
testimony in and I did put a a little
snippet of a cost of the amount that
they charge for cannabis at the
dispensaries because you can just go on
Google and see that information in the
state of New Hampshire and many other
states
um as a nurse that supports people and
how they use cannabis for their specific
treatment options it's very important
that they have education and they do it
safely and I agree that testing would be
great but that's going to be too costly
and there's no at-home test kits just
yet I'm sure that will be developed at
some point but patients know when they
plant a seed or acquire a clone of a
specific strain they pretty much know a
lot about it already because it's been
heavily documented on leafly.com and
other sources online where you can read
about the common effects that that
cannabis provides to many many people so
you know it's it's another way that
cannabis Growers can figure out what
they're growing how strong is it and how
much should they use so that that's not
a big problem and what I'm seeing
um and patients do need an ounce to
maybe four ounces a month depending on
their conditions and just as an example
I have a female patient who reduced her
opiate use by 80 percent and under 30
days using medical cannabis she couldn't
afford all that she needed but she went
to Maine and other probably black market
I don't know I try to stay out of that
and she managed to do that she can have
bowel movements again she is very happy
we shouldn't stop people from having
this medicine it's unethical and it's
inhumane and that's my nursing
perspective because of all the success
I'm seeing we don't want to give it to
the children unless well it's medically
needed we don't want to divert we don't
want to sell what we grow because we put
our effort and our compassion into that
it's made for us as patients we're not
going to sell it we won't have enough to
sell we need it for ourselves because if
you harvest say you harvest and maybe
you get 15 ounces
you're not going to get rid of that
because you need that for the whole year
if you're only growing one time a year
so I'm not worried about diversion like
the police said and yeah the the police
did say the word control many times I
know they want to control cannabis but
this is different guys this is medical
needs
the the police have control already well
maybe they don't because cannabis is
just everywhere you know but patients
should have a right to grow their own
plant their own medicine for the
terpenes the flavonoids and cannabinoids
it's all in my um written testimony if
you want to see more details I'm not
going to read it to you and I want you
guys to know
I am a licensed Federal licensed hemp
grower in the state of New Hampshire if
anyone would like to learn how to grow
contact me uh you can come over I'll do
a show and tell
and do you have any questions
any questions
thank you yeah how do we contact you
in my email testimony just use that
emailing Reach Out
thank you thank you the chair recognizes
Heather Brown
Ms Brown are you available
no
foreign
looks like she may be having some
technical difficulties she's unmuted but
we're not able to hear her she
recognizes John
Pierre Bellini
I don't see anyone by that name thank
you the chair recognizes Grant Ellis
good afternoon Mr chair can you hear me
and thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee for hearing this testimony
today and for consideration of this bill
my name is Grant Ellis I'm the president
of the Massachusetts cannabis reform
Coalition here in my personal capacity
and I'm offering testimony as a bit of a
subject matter expert on medical patient
and adult use home grow in Massachusetts
in the event that anything that uh any
lessons we might have learned might be
able to assist you in your process I
know this bill is multi-years-old at
this point and there's a lot of support
and I'm hoping it will be passed in the
short term so in Massachusetts uh
representative the representative who
introduced the bill HB 350 mentioned
earlier we have six plants for home grow
for adult use if you're over 21 12
plants for home grow in a single home if
you have two adults over 21 in the home
our medical homegirl actually just got
expanded after three years as we had so
few issues with it medical patients in
Massachusetts without a hardship grow
license can now grow 12 flowering plants
which is a mature plant and 12 immature
plants and they can have unlimited
clones just by having their medical card
and that happened as a result of the
fact that there were so few incidents
related to home grow and one thing I
will say Mr chair through you to the
committee is in response to testimony
from earlier it just does not follow
naturally based on human patterns of
behavior that someone who is growing
cannabis at their home giving all of
their information over to the state
putting that information in a database
and basically putting a big red X on
their back would then go on to divert
the small amount of cannabis that they'd
be able to grow under this bill one
thing I will also note to the committee
is related to the caregiver provision so
caregivers in your bill now can only
grow for one patient at a time and then
can go to atcs for up to nine patients
depending on where they live
Massachusetts just increased the number
of patients that a caregiver can grow
for at any one time from one patient to
five patients because because what
Massachusetts found was there were a lot
of patients who could not grow their own
due to either lack of space or lack of
Technical know-how and those caregivers
became a vital resource for access to
cannabis at accessible prices and I
myself saw that firsthand I felt
disabled while in graduate school in
after I felt disabled I was in the
hospital for 18 months and on a
substantial amount of narcotic
medication within 30 days of starting
medical cannabis I saw that narcotic
usage drop by 30 percent and within 12
months I was narcotic-free so thank you
very much for your time and I'm happy to
answer any questions Mr chairman
any question questions from Mr Ellis
yes
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question Mr Ellis
um
I'm a little embarrassed to ask somebody
from Massachusetts about the specifics
of our bill but
in listening to
um the chief from the police Chiefs
Association and trying to quickly read
through the bill
um
it's unclear to me in this bill or in
your statutes in Massachusetts if
someone is
growing cannabis at home for medical use
do they have to register that with the
state and if so
wouldn't that um contradict what um
law enforcement's concern about it being
completely unregulated
Mr chair through you thank you for the
question representative
um the the New Hampshire bill I believe
provides for registration of the
caregiver and the patient and then
indicates where the grow will take place
as it may only be at the home of the
registered patient or caregiver
Massachusetts for home grow goes a
little bit beyond that and what we
actually have is if you want to just
grow for yourself at home either as a
medical patient with that 24 plant cap
or as an adult use home grow you don't
have to do anything you don't have to
register it you don't have to be in the
system if you're a medical patient you
have to be in the system but if you want
to grow more than that if you need a
hardship or if you're a caregiver
growing for more than one patient you
then have to get an electrical
inspection a fire inspection and then
provide handwritten records for the cost
that you put into your grow for
inspection by the commission but I think
the distinction there is the size of the
grow so grow below 6 to 12 plants where
the person's name and address are on
file with the state through the medical
program I don't think that extra level
of oversight would be necessary
thank you anyone else
thank you Mr Ellis thank you Mr chair
the last name I have on the list is Matt
Simon
good afternoon can you hear me
thank you Mr chairman for the record
Matt Simon I live in Manchester and I
work for the marijuana policy project
we're a non-profit dedicated to cannabis
policy reform
I've been coming before this committee
for the last 14 years often with a
number of patients who who then
testified and I would strongly encourage
the committee to continue
The house's long-standing policy of
supporting bills that would legalize own
cultivation of cannabis for registered
patients and caregivers so for the last
15 years patients have been testifying
in this committee seeking permission to
grow their own cannabis without risking
rest and felony prosecution it is
currently a felony for any New Hampshire
resident to grow even a single plant
um the house has consistently supported
that position since 2009 and I did email
you a one-pager that lists all the bills
that have passed often with the support
of this committee sometimes despite the
lack of support from this committee but
it's always past the house floor when
it's failed it has been somewhere else
um
so in light of that history I believe it
would be unconscious unconscionable for
this committee to do anything other than
to vote ought to pass on HB 350. eight
years following the passage of New
Hampshire's therapeutic cannabis law
patients are still complaining about
insufficient Mission access product
selection and lack of affordability
since home cultivation is currently a
felony many patients have been traveling
to Maine in order to obtain products
they need at prices they can afford and
many patients have moved out of the
state of New Hampshire and in order to
live in a place where they feel safer
and less likely to be oppressed by
people wearing Badges and carrying guns
today cultivation of cannabis is legal
in all four neighboring jurisdictions
not only for patients and caregivers but
for all adults
and there is simply no excuse for
maintaining criminal penalties to punish
limited home cultivation by patients and
caregivers in the live fear dye State HB
350 does not need additional work and it
does not require further study it only
needs to pass
finally with regard to the police
chief's testimony I'd just like to
remind you the police Chiefs Association
has opposed to every medical cannabis
bill up to its passage in 2013 they've
opposed every home cultivation Bill
since they opposed any form of
decriminalization until the legislature
finally passed it in
2017. they oppose any bill period that
seeks to improve cannabis policies in
the state of New Hampshire the last
thing that patients need is for police
officers to enter their homes to inspect
their plants weigh their cannabis
that is the last thing that somebody
who's battling a serious medical
condition needs to have happen to them
in their own homes and as the previous
speaker noted the cultivation location
must be reported to the department DHHS
will know who's growing and for whom but
law enforcement only gets involved and
this is something that we had to work
out details of when the original
therapeutic cannabis will pass
the police Chiefs wanted to be able to
search that registry they wanted to be
able to go check on anybody and make
sure they're complying and that law had
to be written very carefully to protect
patient privacy so that law enforcement
could only get involved when there was
evidence of some kind of problem that
indicated potential criminal activity
and so I would encourage you to pass
this bill as quickly as possible let's
have the state live up to its motto with
regard to home cultivation of
therapeutic cannabis I'd be happy to
take any questions
Mr Simon and
seeing no thank you for your testimony
the chair recognizes asthma alhuni
hi can you hear me yeah yeah thank you
my name is and I'm speaking on behalf of
Rights and democracy New Hampshire
um I will keep this short
um y'all I don't know what to say about
this bill except um it shouldn't be a
controversial Bill uh this is a way for
people to afford their medicine you
heard
um that there are therapeutic aspects
there's medicinal aspects you heard
people shouldn't need to drive close to
two hours to get to a dispensary you
heard about this working fine in
Massachusetts so I can't understand why
anyone would vote against this people
don't um we don't deserve to have a wall
between a patient and their medicine
um let's talk about the fact that if you
vote against this you're keeping people
from stopping anxiety or from keeping
um physical pain away right that
cannabis treats for Sleep problems or
the many many other reasons why people
need medicinal cannabis but can't drive
one or two hours to get to their
medicine
um and I mean do you think it's okay to
travel for for your medicine when you
get medicine right or do you have the
decency and deserve medicine not too far
away from you
um yeah and just want to say people grow
herbs I know the police officers said oh
people aren't no people grow herbs for
medicinal reasons and there's many
different herbs that people grow in
their Gardens that help them so this is
no different so do the ethical thing
please and pass this bill already the
people of New Hampshire deserve this
thank you so much
thank you very much for your testimony
it's all on Ellen Brown
hello thank you very much for your time
my name is Ellen Brown I am a United
States Air Force veteran and I am also a
medical marijuana patient in the state
of Massachusetts and I have been a
medical marijuana patient since 2010.
the reason for that is once I got out of
the service I moved home to my home
state of Massachusetts and there wasn't
a medical marijuana program and it
wasn't home grow so I moved out to
California where they had a functioning
medical marijuana program hear me I
moved from Massachusetts to California
in order to be able to obtain my
cannabis safety in order to be able to
get the cannabinoids and the terpenes
that I needed and from moving out to
California to a state that did allow for
home cultivation I got my medical
marijuana card and within a week I was
able to start growing my own plants at
home and it was a beautiful wonderful
experience I don't want to reiterate a
lot of what we've heard today except to
say that I completely support all of the
wonderful facts information that has
been presented in support of um House
Bill 350 when we talk about the
importance of having patients cultivate
so that they can have the best
cannabinoids and terpene profiles
available for them and whatever their
ailmenting condition might be as well as
the importance of talking about therapy
for cultivating
um as a as a veteran and working with
the veteran population it is very
therapeutic to be able to cultivate your
own cannabis at home and to be able to
grow what you need and to be able to
have that freedom to do so I think is
very important
um
what's going on right now in New
Hampshire where you only have five
dispensaries is something that you need
to look into as well
um we are you know looking into
expanding home cultivation but I do
think that the um medical marijuana
population is no disrespect but being
clearly underserved if you have five
brick and mortar dispensaries and no way
for cool for patients to cultivate for
themselves New Hampshire is a state that
their motto is live free and die and
something I would like to talk about is
the importance of cannabis for
palliative care and for myself
um my mother passed away
um five years ago and she was in the
state of New Hampshire she lived in
Nashua and this was back before your
medical marijuana program was in effect
and just for myself for somebody who has
done hospice care and taking care of
somebody who cannabis absolutely could
have helped and benefited but it wasn't
available at the time my heart
definitely breaks for those that find
themselves in a position where they have
to go to Alternative States or they have
to
um you know pick between am I going to
be able to pay a bill versus pay for
medicine so um by allowing for home
cultivation those would help to
alleviate those problems and to better
serve the medical marijuana Community to
better serve the patient population we
always need to act with compassion and
we always need to take those that are
the most vulnerable into consideration
those that are unable to drive for
themselves those that are unable to pay
those dispensary prices and how home
cultivation could improve quality of
life and you right now have the
opportunity to pass the bill as it is I
agree with the last speaker without any
um debate or looking for
um you know extra to add into it just as
is passing this bill so that way we can
get on the right track to providing
those patients with the access they so
desperately need
um I truly appreciate you taking the
time to hear my testimony I also hold
educational seminars in Massachusetts
and I'll put that into my written
testimony but I'm here to help other
people are here to help you have a great
network of resources that are ready
willing and able to help you for free to
help those patients so thank you very
much for your time coming to the end of
our hour and we've got one more name
that's been given to me actually it's uh
two fun and it would be Heather and Joe
pinto and I'd ask you please to be brief
because we're coming here to the end
we are recognizes Heather and Joe Pinto
um I'm actually Heather Marie Brown
um so I apologize I don't know what
happened earlier but if it's all right
I'd like to go ahead when
all right well my name is Heather Marie
Brown I have been a lifelong resident of
New Hampshire
um I am a therapeutic cannabis patient
and have been for several years now I am
speaking on behalf of house bill 350.
um I you know I heard some comments
earlier in questions in reference to
cost affiliated with this and I just
want to let you know I myself it would
be nothing but an outside grower which
means I have a very limited season in
order to produce what I need for myself
um it's approximately three months I
mean you guys some of you are gardeners
I'm sure you're aware of our growing
season and the way it is
if if I were to be successful and
acquire what I could acquire per plant
um it would cost me an initial
investment of approximately 100 150
which would bring the cost of each ounce
down to five dollars an ounce and that's
only if the plant provided me with
approximately four to five ounces per
plant and has a lot of you know from
growing outside that is not always
possible to get the yield that we want
from our garden
um I also want to give you a couple of
other facts my income is only
approximately 20 000 per year
of that I currently pay sixteen thousand
eight hundred in rent I pay 2400 in
electric and I pay 1200 in heat per year
just those three utilities come to
twenty thousand four hundred dollars per
year as you can see that's four hundred
dollars over my income in order for me
to supply myself with cannabis I am
looking at an expense of spending eight
thousand four hundred dollars a year
now from those numbers I just gave you
where am I supposed to pull eight
thousand four hundred dollars a year
from it's impossible uh I found it very
difficult to be able to get what I need
to take care of myself for my own health
conditions
um and because of the location of my
dispensary which is over an hour away
and the fact that I have children it
cost me approximately sixty dollars in
order to even just take a trip to the
dispensary based on gas child care and
some of the other added things and
um then you know you're looking at seven
hundred dollars for me because I use a
THC CBD blend so I would need one ounce
of each and with the discount it's still
350 dollars an ounce it's still 700 a
month potentially
um currently I do have a caregiver who
lives approximately 35 to 40 minutes
away from me in Maine where I can
acquire my medical grade cannabis for
approximately a hundred and fifty
dollars
um you know I may still have the
expenses involved with child care but
I'm spending less time on the road I'm
spending less money on a product and I'm
getting the same quality as I would
receive in the state of New Hampshire it
would be an absolutely ridiculous thing
for you guys not to pass this bill it
has been it's time I am not a criminal
and I'm sick and tired of feeling like I
am a criminal in my state and as far as
the comment earlier from the police
chief who wants to be able to go in and
do random inspections and check out
people's homes well I can't think of any
other situation in life where you need
to disclose your medical information to
a police officer and allow them to come
in and search your home nobody does that
for diabetes to make sure that you're
using your needles for insulin and not
you know for something else no nobody
does that for anything I I feel that
this is that would be the Chief's Way
and the police their way of overstepping
their boundaries and trying to control a
program that they have no business
trying to control I have complete and
utter faith in Health and Human Services
to be able to control this program and
monitor this program so that it would be
effective for any and all patient that
chose to participate with the home grow
version of this do I think this will
impact the dispensaries negatively no I
do not because for the few of us that
want to take on the challenge of
attempting to grow at home there are
thousands and thousands more that will
still maintain using the dispensaries as
they always have been
and I really appreciate you giving me
this opportunity to talk
um I also have a lot of background in
just about every single aspect of
cannabis there is from my past and I
would be more than welcome to answer any
and all questions and leave you with
this thought by not
providing and passing medical homework
home grow and by keeping the
restrictions so difficult on a patient
you are in essence helping to continue
pushing patients to potentially Black
Market sources where they may not be
able to acquire safe and natural product
for themselves
thank you so much for your testimony we
appreciate that
or if there's anybody else left to speak
we have Josie Pinto
Josie
Jones Josie Josie
the chair recognizes Josie Pinto uh good
afternoon all my name is Josie I'm here
as a lobbyist for New Hampshire youth
movement and I'm in full support of HB
350.
um so last week the criminal justice
committee voted to retain two bills that
would have expanded cannabis use in our
state allowing voices of out-of-state
people to outweigh the massive support
from people within New Hampshire with
963 people signing in to support HB 237
and
1109 signing in to support HB 629 I want
to urge this committee to listen to the
clear opinion of people in our state and
vote to pass HB 350. right now this bill
is our last chance to do anything that
would meaningfully make a difference in
the lives of medical cannabis users
I'm going to keep it brief I know
there's a big storm coming but uh being
a medical cannabis patient is incredibly
expensive not to mention that most
cannabis patients are also paying for a
whole other set of medications that they
need we already have some of the highest
national costs for health care if we
knew it was safe and easy to make these
other medications from herbs that grow
naturally would we stop people from
doing that millions of people use
natural herbs to treat conditions every
day and this is the case with cannabis
it's a medicinal plant that's used used
to grow naturally before we even made it
illegal
I urge you and the live for your die
State let's allow patients to make the
decision themselves and allow this bill
to pass today thank you so much
and thank you Ms Midtown
since there is no one else
closing now the hearing on house film350
hello everybody
be safe and we'll see you tomorrow
remotely as Republicans I hope to see
you soon
thank you everybody
everyone
stupid